be in there somewhere i'm sorry if you go to store and then
you go to sorry i got stuck in a quick play we're still
sorry we're just warming up i don't know if my audio and the
strange skin are both alive are you guys alive if we do
gambit game should i run cloak vegetables don't play golf
potato chips no canada it's time wait what does chips mean
yeah this one's not as good sorry I'll try again.
Shipping is a golf goal.
Are you, like, stealing that idea from your chat?
Yeah, that one is not the best.
Did that come from you or from chat?
He just started playing.
I made that one up, but that was not good.
I'm sorry.
What am I playing?
Coach, help.
If we do Gambit, are we doing 2-2-2 or 1-2-3?
There it is.
Coach muted.
Fox?
Coach not here.
We have to coach ourselves.
No, no, sorry.
I was muted.
Yeah, sorry.
Aramori, can you go, can you go Emma?
uh warn yeah that's good and then fan think you go like sue
get a game on sue oh yeah all right here we go cloak is
actually good no see what you what you say warn is hella not
a combo anymore no not really the the other hit skins in the
game are just so much stronger than them oh interesting yeah
it's like cyclops elsa bucky star lord that's kind of Let's
go.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Oh, we're running Gambit.
We should ban Loki because we can't run Loki.
Most teams don't like to opt into the Gambit Loki because
it's hard.
I'm walking up.
I'm gonna put my ass towards the point.
Good half.
I'm gonna back towards my end.
Keep it pressure.
I'm keeping pressure.
We're down one.
Okay, I'm chilling.
I'm backing the point.
I'm back.
Oh, I got you.
We're down one.
We're down two.
Maybe you can trade out.
Just so we have point.
They have to push it.
They have to come into us.
I'm going to use my heals then.
I'm max charge.
I'm looking at you.
I have no cards.
Things coming off the point.
I break it.
I have the cards now.
I have to use it.
Back soon.
Back in two.
They have an off angle.
Can we push?
They're all here.
We're all here.
i still have a great angle on the back right big spin i'm
pushing yeah i got him i got it i got it i'm gonna clutch it
don't worry it's nice good job no heels no heels no heels
sorry i let you die punish your way i guess i'm healed
always no heels no heels no heels bro uh i'm coming back
soon.
What the hell?
Jeff 1, Jeff 1.
Oh my god, he didn't heal.
It's my world here.
We're here right now.
Show what you're doing.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, the jack.
I got all, I'm about to look for something.
I have a little here.
It's all the, Mr. Whole Team.
Mr. Whole Team.
Why don't you start, Lord Gambit?
Combo.
Let's, uh, let's group combo next fight X.
Oh, group combo, okay.
with whale a group no more yeah okay i want to keep up guys
for it oh i can just kidding i'm leaving oh he saw that oh
my god that's okay that's okay that's fine he's one hp i'm
in i'm in i'm in it i'm in it too i'm in it i'm shooting i'm
shooting i'm shooting i'm shooting i'm shooting i'm shooting
i'm shooting i'm shooting i'm actually still alive okay we
last i'm here oh no we save alts for next right yeah yeah
hello forget the alts carry over all right this is just
quick quick warm-up guys not the actual tournament we're
just warming up but he doesn't know what he's doing dude
they got jelly bean thing jelly peanut no no not jelly
peanut yeah
x and uh and I'm warning sure for you, I remember, I don't
know how much rivals you guys plays, but the alts transfer
over from round to round since we're only playing Dom, so.
I just have to kill the Jeff that had her.
No, that was such a good, that was such a good.
There's a Jeff.
Jeff, you can, I mean, not Jeff, sorry.
Warren, you can use your NMOR whale to kill the Jeff alt.
Yeah.
Okay, while I'm in it?
Yeah, so when you chance it when the circle comes up below
you.
Yeah, I was saving it for dear life for our insane combo.
Yeah, so like, so like, Warren, when Jeff pops alt right,
their his like circle pops on the ground of like where he's
gonna eat if you aim your whale in the very center of it and
pop it even if you get eaten your whale will kill him yeah
it's like okay so that's like that's what all the mars do
yeah yeah but it is a timing thing it's it's a little hard
but we should we should go close right in and gambit all on
top of them yeah yeah from right we are not right though we
go main we go main it's okay we just go for gambit all early
okay whenever whenever you see i'm ready i'm not yeah i
don't think you got it that's okay oh there's a I don't know
who I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm a dead I'm a dead caps
on point at the moment just poking them I'm turning now cap
one HP down lady Loki don't don't don't break it don't break
it don't want you to just just because my energy wait why
why explain she can't farm energy off the clones oh I didn't
know yeah okay yo we grew It's like my Zarya charge.
This is it.
Huge anti.
Yeah, yeah.
We should look for it here.
I'm going to save it.
Okay.
I need heals.
Look at us.
I'm meeting them in.
It's big.
It's huge.
Boom.
Nice.
Oh, that's my grab though.
Gap is deep right now.
I will tune to you.
Chill, chill.
They're even.
I'm 95 on mine, okay?
Help me make mine and I can all.
Oh, I'm gonna get sucked.
I'm sucked.
I'm trying to.
I know.
I'm sucking them back.
I couldn't live enough.
Yeah, no heals.
No heals.
I'm not gonna get that here.
I'm getting at the moment.
I'm dead here.
Oh, my brother.
Oh, you dead.
I'm dead as far too.
I have my ult for next.
But they're gonna have Rocket, Hella.
Oh.
And he's old.
Hello, maybe.
It's just really hard to kill him.
So I'm hitting top right for angles when you guys walk.
Tell me when.
Okay.
3, 2, 1, walking.
Okay, I'm here.
Oh, I couldn't anti him.
We're turning cap right now.
Yeah, cap is half.
I got a low on point.
Hello, absolute on point, dead.
Nice.
I can flip point.
You guys start walking, though, because they're going to
push me right away.
She gets red.
We're even.
We're on me.
Nice.
I'm looking at my walking point.
I'm walking point.
I'm looking at their B line.
We're fine.
Yeah, me too.
Cap on point.
Invis woman dead.
Cap cap.
Is that Invis woman?
Who did he get?
What?
I don't think he got anyone.
No, yeah, he got me.
I got it.
Oh, okay.
Oh, he got it.
Cap one.
I have all here.
I'll use, try, I'll use my first aggressively.
They've got Rocketol.
They're on White Fox now.
They've got Hella.
They're gonna have Emma.
They're gonna have Emma soon.
Are you guys ready?
I'm a one.
Can you say here?
Um, yeah, we can go.
We can go.
Hello, hello, hello.
They have brush.
I'm breaking this.
I'm breaking it.
I'm not healthy.
Okay.
I got you.
I've got wail in two seconds.
Almost have our group combo.
Karen, I'm all like here.
Okay.
I'm all like here.
She's gonna look for it.
Can I wail over here and counter it?
Is that an offer?
It doesn't stun her.
She has CC immunity in her all.
It can do.
damage to her though so like if we're trying to kill her
they would be like okay but it's fine watch out watch out
i'm got you i got him too yeah what's hitting me i don't
even know it's the it's the hell nice guys you gotta look up
bro yeah gamers can't look up fan fan you said fan you said
that you're uh you're not really comfortable playing rocky
right no strange i can i can i just i don't know why i'm
really bad at rocket i go i charge all the same speed as
luna in my games that's okay i mean we could always just ban
rocket if we know they have a new support we don't really
have to like play it yeah yeah yeah for dunk for dunk for
dunk all right guys what's fun yeah well what's the thing
like these teams are probably gonna get the value from what
we've seen most of the teams like their sandbags are on
support rather than other roles yeah well yeah i know and
like our backline is probably best in best in this
tournament exactly we just ban rocket insane like yeah we
could just play whatever support needed yeah like what what
i'm at least thinking of doing right now is like prioing x
on grute right and then either just protecting mantis and
letting him solo tank or and put aramori on support or
protecting gambit and letting doki carry on gambit right and
sure for you'll probably just be going around between like
cyclops we should if i'm playing gambit i don't that's the
thing dokey i don't think i don't think these teams are
going to be good enough to play that yeah it's like not even
most pro teams yeah most pro teams don't even like playing
it man i just see it too many times in rank i've got
paranoia about that yeah like it could it could be an issue
but i don't think we'll run into it very often unless like
the back line because again loki's hard gambit's hard all
right so that's fine then if you think the other team won't
play loki then i'm cool of it i just fucking hate playing
against gambit loki yeah no i hear you i hear you can you
guys look at the team canada chat yeah all right team usa is
oh yeah you guys just don't say it out loud though yeah
hello my bad my bad my bad my bad my bad i didn't finish the
sentence true
we got a few games until then but yeah just yeah i was like
i was so confused because i was looking at i was watching
the matches because i have really bad sleep schedule i was
like why is your seven players on koreas i was like why did
they have seven and then found out like oh coaches are
allowed yeah i actually think i actually think usa is a
pretty easy team to ban against i kind of agree yeah no
first match is against brazil yeah are you playing against
brazil out of like these all right what's three okay but we
have to figure out uh this first i i do this if anyone yeah
i don't know oh doki i had like a i had some i do it like
that aura let me look that's what i would do yeah yeah but
they i but that they were practicing as a full team like
today so that's i was like does anyone know what i've got
i've got one of my managers just figuring out what like the
the Brazilians actually play and then and then I can figure
something out aren't we against team America's first no it's
oh they team America it's Brazil first yeah no it on the
start GG it says round one Brazil yeah yeah oh I got a
Brazil jersey on right now too yeah it's it's Brazil then
America United and then they saved USA Canada for last it's
opposite in the discord it says we play it squared really
yeah it's It says we play Amer United first and then Brazil
after.
Well, Sargigi is the public one, so I don't know.
I don't know either.
Do we know the bans for any of them?
Yeah, yeah.
For America United, I have one.
It's fine.
Okay.
I'm just waiting on information on Brazil, which I thought
was first.
So it's good to go after.
I thought it was first, too.
I don't know what's right.
I don't know if it's Sargigi's right or is it?
Yeah, Sargigi or Discord.
Admin's help.
I mean, we could just, okay, at, what's the staff thing?
Is there a staff tag and be like, who's playing for, who are
we playing first?
I'm going to add Winfrey.
I've chosen them.
All right.
Oh, Fox can come down a bit more.
I just got information on a...
I came down first.
Also, if we don't ban Rocket, I can go Rocket.
Like, I wouldn't want to put Doki on Rocket.
because if if rocket gets through my rocket is fucking nuts
just broken that's that's america united that's america
united's uh hero pools guys all right okay i mean it looks
like we might be like close to mirror and i think we're just
better on the mirror no yeah i agree we banned that guy we
banned the last guy yeah fuck that oh yeah like like this is
this is probably what we would do
what this line in my opinion okay okay really i think
they'll definitely protect the second one that's what i
would do yeah you think i think wait here yeah i don't care
about that character i don't care about that character yeah
i don't think it's i don't think it's that strong though I
think I think if we we can push her for on better
characters.
I think that's a crutch character for a lot of hit scans
right now.
Yeah, it is me included.
I don't think it's that strong.
Oh my god, guys.
Oh, come down a little more.
Okay.
No, I'm actually so I'm actually so happy you were here
because I was stressed the fuck out today being like, oh my
god, I don't know if I can make these decisions.
I'm gonna feel so bad.
yeah and if we lose we blame our coach yeah exactly that's
what you're ready for that yeah for our coaches it's fox
from swamp gaming uh so if we lose it's his fault if we win
it's our cap our captain led us to victory but if we win
stage one then it's dokey's fault no no if swamp wins stage
one then we blame dokey word yeah blame yeah wait when then
no i get all the credit i should get their prize money bro
true true true it took me every balloon to get the damn emma
skin i'm pissed but but now the strange skin is half off
yeah now the strange skin is okay i got the emma in like two
in two pools and then i got the strange in six it was sad
the last balloon they they really got they really got the
gotcha down man but it's it's actually addicting i was like
i can't stop popping the balloons all right i'm nervous guys
i'm i'm really thankful y'all are mori lemon kiwi just asked
me as team canada are not going to be on broadcast are are
all the games not all broadcasted i don't know i think i
don't think so skin in Tekken.
Oh, okay.
So we're full.
Look at that.
Look at this then.
Yeah.
As soon as it barks, I cancel my reload.
Look at this.
Where are you guys in?
Oh, so we do.
We do play America United first.
Okay.
I knew it.
All right.
Start GG was wrong.
It always is.
Guys, I'm practicing rocket in practice range.
Yo, can you make your skin red?
So we can do so we match?
Wait, we're making all red skins?
We should be all red.
No, that's so cool.
I don't know if I got that much cosmetics.
Hold on.
The people highlighted in yellow, my analyst just said, the
people highlighted in yellow are the people who actually
play the game.
So that's actually even better for us.
My analyst said that's not true, but it's okay.
I mean, we can have a meeting with us in a minute.
My analyst said, it's okay to drink coffee with your food.
My analyst said vegetables don't have phones.
Onion rings.
Oh, um, I can go to Yemen.
I'm an Lister.
No, you're right.
He actually is like a soundboard.
Okay, are we doing the red skins thing?
Like, we all rock in red?
Yeah, dude.
Depends on.
I don't think every game guys are at skins.
We need team Canada skins.
Oh, this, this, this, they could go so crazy with this, man.
But one guy was not going to play out in one day, right?
It's not in one day event, is it?
Well, it's, if you make it to the finals, you make it, you
play Sunday.
I don't have a red skin.
What?
No.
Guys, there's one fatal error with my Squirrel Girl red
skin.
I'm trying to see if there's...
Do I have... Is there...
It has antlers, but it's like, hey, shoot me in the head.
It's like shoot me in the head here.
All right, let me equip all the red skins.
See, that's red.
I don't know if I have to play.
Well, that rocket, does it not come in red?
No, he has a red skin.
He has a Christmas skin.
This is as close as I can get to it.
I got a good one.
Wait, is that a sentinel jersey?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I'll do that.
Yes, guys.
There's the sentinels.
Bundles in the esports tab.
Buy the send bundle, everyone.
I bought it.
I just put it on your server and it's like a half naked
widow maker.
Buy the swamp.
Oh, what do you say?
I used to be on sentinels before.
Yeah.
Wait, really?
Yeah, I was actually part of the forming the...
uh a squad the forming of the org yeah oh gee i just
remember your earliest days as just a dallas player or yeah
real i remember too holy xqc primal um yo i'm nervous guys
i'm nervous thank you guys thank you for all the good luck
everybody people in this vc too and i'm super nervous muted
now because i was asking what where's the furthest that we
went with karen's though because i i don't remember um he
was on a team when he got a second place i think you guys
got third he has the he has the bronze metal yeah i got it
the bronze metal is actually um it's actually metal but the
silver one is just plastic and it's falling apart oh wait
how old is it How old's the middle?
I mean, it was falling apart when I got it.
So like eight years?
It's been a while.
I thought plastic was non-bi-agreedable.
That's crazy.
It was falling apart.
There was also some budget cuts.
So this is when the budget cuts hit in.
Yeah, X was asking for you, Shephor.
Yeah.
I was pooping.
Pre-game poop.
get all the get all the shit out of you haha I always had to
poop before every Overwatch League match that's how you do
it that's just the body yeah that's just the meta God
cleanse your body even before the great bamboozle sure for
yeah every time they'd be having the pregame a pep talk or
whatever and I would be just muted on discord no excuse me
showing the metal right wait oh the overwatch league the
world cup medals so that one's metal like actual metal oh
and then the second year is plastic yeah i saw like the
paint chipping off is that where you're asking earlier when
i was near yeah i was asking where i thought we went with
crimson if he was uh if it was there when we got second oh
big first against team korea 100 no korea's always been like
it's not much you do about it Maybe Korea got the metal, the
metals, the metals, and then second and third were plastic.
Yeah, I wonder whether the gold metal was or not again.
Yeah, the gold is real gold.
But yeah, you remember 2016, Shreveur, how locked into Korea
was?
They were like so ahead of the curve.
It was kind of abysmal.
They were so good.
We had Joe Meister, I think, right?
And yep.
It was either year one or two.
We're like...
Sound guy, is it better now?
The audio?
waiting for our lucio to beat and then just booping him in
the air after he beat it and they would just kill him
mid-beat oh yeah it was i remember i actually remember that
yeah like it was so depressing because like we would just
sprint we would just sprint and they were right right behind
us in the booths in their practice booths and they were
yelling comms and we were just like sitting in silence
pretty much almost because we were getting enrolled it's
like a ptsd trauma sharing right now i do remember team
canada scrimmed korea they started telling people that the
hardest team they scrimmed so far was team canada and
everyone was like what that's when i had like huck poke and
oh yeah we have the best i think it was oh that's before i
came yeah that was before oh i was muted fiona do you know
how the balls work because that might be why your healing is
low like bouncing it on the floor yeah when they go through
somebody it heals them for 50.
okay I'm here.
Oh, could you show me where to bounce the balls?
Just right at their feet.
Yeah, like.
It hits them twice.
It hits them on the entry.
And then once it bounces, it hits them for another 50.
And that's like a free instant 100 healing.
Okay, so if I'm healing a big group of people, I just shoot
it down the middle.
Down the middle, but try and like aim it low.
Try and make sure it bounces at some point.
Okay, okay, okay, got it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, are you labbing Rocket right now?
Yes, dude.
I think the hardest part is just throwing all jump.
Do you know how to super jump on the walls?
Uh, yeah.
Okay, okay.
I'm, I, dude, I played, I play, I've been on rocket duty so
much in ranked and like any competent Luna, I get ult
charges same time as Luna.
Yeah, but Luna's building ult super fast because of how much
she does damage.
So it's not even like that bad.
That is a little slow, but like that's not that bad.
Because like some Luna's build ult like crazy fast.
Okay.
Because they're just like flanking and killing things.
Oh my God.
getting dove yeah the ice for rocket is so much fun he's so
much fun i don't understand why because it's like he feels
like he should be like a brain dead character but like he's
actually so much i think like when you're in the higher he's
he's funny more fun because because everyone knows how to
dive a rocket now so when are we playing i mean are they
late by an hour plus i don't i don't know they're late by
about 40 right now oh 40 so i guess we're could run up
another one and I'm so down to play I mean 40 as in it's
been 40 minutes since you're supposed to start okay well I
mean someone checked the broadcast and you can see yes I
cannot you make a dozen bubbles because I said no when it
prompted it asked me for my discord uh like on the site for
like approval what's the what's the broadcast guys um it's
they only have one round uh oh wait I think they might do
another they might do another game so we can have an actual
live broadcast up too with casters yeah yeah it's on the
marvel rivals channel spain are playing right now yeah so
emea looks like they're gonna win so we might they might run
another game so royal palace is being played yeah because
it's all domination oh let's just run another quick play i
think we have time yeah yeah um i just had someone suggest
we should warm up versus chat if anybody wants to like is
like good at the game chat yeah yeah we it's coordinate that
it might be but if we just open a lobby maybe they'll join
and be good wait wait hold on wait i have a question it says
we're playing against brazil first and we don't have brazil
bands oh no no we're playing no we're playing united first
we're playing it's united first yeah oh yeah even with the
thing that we were just yeah yeah the admins oh that's u.s
and brazil sorry i'm done i'm done yeah we're round two it's
team canada america united i can i can make a lobby yeah
make a lobby and be like celestial plus only yeah we kick
you out if you're good no one's joined like it's gonna be
all xqc stream snipers and these guys don't even play video
games oh wait wait oh we need we need sure for and sure we
can play against yeah you guys can play against me i could
be on the enemy team yeah you guys can get out of train
range we can add you guys in oh my god three warrens tough
what was it there's no way you're flaming my ranks no i'm
not i'm not i'm not i'm not i'm just like no no way d how
much have you played this game though warren i don't i don't
know i never see a stream that's it um not much i just
playing tournaments win and go back to overwatch and we got
i need i need x in here and oh i can i can invite sure for
it right now leave your leave your practice range yep come
in hold on please i'm against these walls waiting okay all
right oh we need to kick someone get that person out of here
oh the whatsapp snipers yeah our ping is much better
day you were a thor player right you played everything on my
old account yeah i did it right i was like i remember you
being like a like the one of the oj ores well the first time
i got ranked nice solo queue it was yeah fighting mostly
playing fucking mantis oh wait wait wait can i can you kick
someone on the enemy team so we can go go against dive yeah
who should i kick anyone physical levels it's supposed to go
against dive really yeah you want landmine in no i want he
played the highest i got on ride among us was rank 12 on
thor hold on let me find out what the first map is we're
playing against somebody named spunky beaver that's aura if
you please dive first map is crocoa okay what what do you
mean dive like what dive characters just dive like dd yeah
wait guys these are good wait what the fuck it's good
practice it's good practice i'm sure for up we can't hear me
practice is that not a game is that no this is not a game
our match lock the this is just a four this is just a four
fun warm-up guys okay these guys are more higher this is
grand final 300 000 first place grand finals will win 300k
for fags yeah this is the grand finals one of them is
literally in the this this i know they probably like twice
as as hard as the finals yeah probably yeah so lock in if we
win this we win it all i mean so if we're going What are we
running in the backline?
I'm probably mad to snow for sleeps.
Well, we won't have a way of sleeping.
Oraling, though.
It'll be, wouldn't be Rocket Luna?
And then...
I don't think we play in Rocket, right?
I've been labbing.
Nirk the shit.
Because, like, I hit the sleep and then...
Or we might be able to kill.
Amory, coach.
Coach?
Me?
I said...
is phoenix been nerfed oh okay our coach left us already our
coach is deafened he's not even listening i forgot he's
playing where's jane i think i think i think i can go cloak
right dokey yeah you can yeah is is jane phoenix got it yes
jean oh my powers can't repair the time
they got star venom oh geez daredevil top right yeah focus
top right all of us i'm i'm on daredevil right now all right
someone's behind us double stun double stun cap cap cap cap
i need help i need help here any help oh my god no i got
venom venom on your squirrel i fear jumped up yeah you only
Okay, I'm chilling.
Can walk now a little bit.
I'm looking at this game.
They captured the mission.
Someone behind us still.
Yeah, they're going hard.
Yeah, Cap's gonna go behind too.
I need help.
Uh, Dare double button.
Yeah, Dare wouldn't mind.
I need help.
I need my help.
Bubble, bubble, bubble.
Over here.
I have a, I have a, I can upgrade and I can go back then.
Should be easier for you guys.
I have my, I have my, I have my old, uh, on the muda.
I'm frozen.
Okay, okay.
I'm walking.
I'm gonna take slow.
Cat boy, cat boy, I'm gonna focus.
Oh, when you need.
I don't think we...
CD, DD, behind us, one.
I don't think we need alts.
We don't need alts here.
We should win this.
Good.
Support low.
White fox low.
I'm on her.
Oh, I'm froze.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that's good.
All right, they're gonna have both the portals close,
Daredevil.
Okay, yo, I'm gonna use my ults to force the support.
I'm gonna force the support all with my ults.
Okay, I'm holding top here.
Someone is top.
Luna close.
Luna close, Luna close.
Oh, it's not gonna fall.
venom i'm out i'm out you're back go back go back go back
i'm gonna look to oh my bad
we don't need us we don't need us i'm following our aura
guys all the way back so we can't oh it's on caps down to
caps can you help this can you help this
There's a DD back here.
I can hold you.
I might just sneak it in.
Can we touch?
I'm on it, but I might be dead here.
Yeah, I got one.
Oh, I'm lucky.
Can we touch?
Really important to touch.
I'm on point.
I'm going to die at one point though.
I'm with you.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to roll right now.
I have ult in 10.
He's hiding.
It's okay.
Okay.
Be strong together.
All right.
Let me see myself.
I don't think we had a support all yet for their shot.
We did.
Oh, we had, yeah.
We had blue.
We had blue right below you.
Just far away.
Oh, what the fuck is my team?
They're double to your left.
Walk, walk left side.
Walk left side.
We make Luna and then we can go point.
Okay.
Come left.
I don't see DD.
Oh, I don't see.
Right here.
Shoot him, shoot him.
Everyone shoot him.
Should I go in that bubble?
Yes.
I got it.
No, no, no, no.
That blinds you and does damage.
Hey, take TP.
Okay, grabbing.
Where does this take us?
It takes us to the point, point.
They're gonna have Capo.
Care backline.
Cap is low?
Just healing right now.
Frozen or someone?
Oh, fuck.
I accidentally dropped.
Sorry.
She's down to heal.
Yeah, they had support of her.
He's gonna die every set.
Oh, sure.
You get a, you get a, like, a phase thing where they can't
do damage and you can't get healed.
It's like cloak fade.
No.
No, Deadpool.
End your birthday.
They've almost got it.
I'm probably dead here.
We might need a portal.
Yeah, I am out of spawn so.
All right, we walk.
We might be able to touch.
TP, TP, TP.
On the left, on the left.
Behind, behind.
I should make it.
I stunned.
I'm on TP too.
Oh my god.
Venom low.
Venom really weak.
I'm dead.
Trying to keep you up.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, I could.
Oh, my God, I'm sorry.
The captain body black.
Goodbye, Waldo.
Yeah.
No, I'm just 98.
So we have it for the next round.
I'm on, I'm on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I'm dead.
Control loss.
No winner yet.
Going to overtime.
Ah, yeah, we don't get touched.
I think we got it like anyone TP.
Nobody TP.
Everyone won.
Oh, boy.
I just...
If I switched, I wouldn't have made it in time.
Worry, wait, do you know how to TP, Worry?
Yeah, I TP'd once.
I should TP.
That's your TP.
But at the time that again, so if I spawned in strange,
which is a good goal.
We make it if you spawn, you don't make it.
We need a fortune.
Time to bring out the shotgun.
I think I'll go rocket here just because like I freeze, but
I think I'll still die.
Okay.
Yeah.
So it'd be harder to kill both of us now.
Hey, I like your firearms.
Yeah, I'll save bubble for dying, please.
let's see ion turret photon reaction chain gun mini i think
i think no more would be better than troll girl here yeah
yeah right right right they're running like quad dive yeah
yeah the end i think only necrosis team can play full dive i
don't think the yeah there's not too many most of these
teams are doing front to back these guys are like dive
specialists uh we should have support old advantage here so
we should just fight on point and try and build our Come
right side.
Come right side, just fight on point.
I'm a little behind.
Walk fast, walk fast.
Keep going, keep going.
Walk the point.
Ignore that guy.
I'm alright.
If we need, we can just hold, okay?
Yeah.
Oh, she's low.
D .D.
I'm on D.
Venom deep.
Can you walk?
Yeah, you're holding my gun.
There's a D.D.
just beating my ass right now.
Yeah, I'ma shoot the D.D.
Where'd he go?
Oh, this is bad.
I am...
He died, he died, he died.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm still behind him if we can walk with it.
It's on the back point if you want to walk.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
We're fine.
I'm fine.
I'm walking up.
Good luck to Zumi.
Whoa.
Is that too soon?
Thank you.
We don't have spoils right now, so gotta be careful.
Uh, did they Venom all?
No, they didn't.
They're gonna die on Emma.
And Fox.
They use Emma.
No Emma.
There it is.
Okay, okay.
Tap HP still.
Oh, I do not have res.
I just got res.
I'm giving the one.
Okay, let them use.
I'm going on their back line.
I'm just gonna die.
I think she'll be no TP.
No TP.
Let's pop back up under there.
Oh, I'm not gonna make it.
You're ready for it.
Um, we should go bottom right here, I think.
All right.
Hey, let's do it.
Cyclops is top left at the moment someone's bottom right I
think it's Emma yeah watch them diving here watch them
diving here wait why is there Luna here Luna it's Luna half
it's because Luna DPS goes high okay walk walk here the run
DD behind here I might need you have yeah yeah yeah thank
you oh I might wail this in a sec wail dwelled wail nice I'm
down here I'm down here I bubble for us bubble for me we can
maybe we can maybe trade out me and the me and feds that are
not alive anymore all right we live for a while though he
didn't see me at the point i don't want to launch anymore i
was gonna say we were so healthy i'm close to mine better
for dive here i'm walking up
to tb to point for the next time yeah yeah because we just
walk up we're gonna push i'm on dd i'm on dd i'm turning
backline oh oh shit okay you thank you you probably found me
on our oh yeah oh no it's okay i was on a plank as well i'm
looking luna luna of course i have a lot after this we had a
little white box white box she said she said excuse you and
i are coming back i'm holding luna Oh my god, I'm home.
Venom's half?
I'm frozen!
Venom's really low.
Ah, he's gonna die me next.
Aw.
Oh, they're not on TP either.
Yeah.
No TP.
Oh god.
I threw it out.
Live.
Touch as long as you can.
Just live.
Oh, never mind the health is gone.
That was not bad considering we were against an all
Celestial plus Yeah, yeah, you know, yeah.
Better than DD eating my whole ass.
We, I don't think we can play 2-2-2 against that with...
Against dive?
Like, I think we just go Ultron or something.
I think so.
Yeah, Ultron is good, yeah.
Um, it should be you, Morn.
Like, Namur does nothing against that.
Like, Namur is so outdated.
He's one of, like, the first fucking characters that was in
this game when it released, right?
He doesn't do enough.
like damage to deter the dives anymore like daredevil just
gets a bajillion freaking hell and venom just gives a
bajillion hell like the squids are they're just tickling
them like the whole honestly we I should we should have done
Luna white fox or oh yeah yeah white fox what do you think
of that yeah white fox go to anti-dive it was good oh yeah
why is she go to anti-dive also yeah because she can like
brawl she can brawl like DPS and gain HP while making HP
yeah she's she's super strong as a suzu also we got stuck in
the lobby we have to go to the next lobby now we fogs oh we
do oh we do they said they it's up it's match time let's go
yeah all right let's run it down right the back way yeah
we're we're banning that should be tournament room right oh
i see fox if they're playing dive what's the best the best
thing we could the best thing we could play is it's mainly a
about our backline so it would be like Luna White Fox but if
we're able to play triple then it would be like Ultron Luna
White Fox right if we are really deter triple um can you
pass me band flag cookie oh yeah but then the other thing
I'm allowed to be in lobby right I can I can I can between
games you can be yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
um DPS wise sure if we're probably playing something like
like Star Lord would probably be best um to deter dive and
then x can be on strange right like you did a lot on tank
pool it was it was very annoying do i want frame jet on it
maybe yeah you can have it on no but do i want it i didn't
turn it on most people have it off if you have a giga
computer of hell you don't really need it on yeah okay i
think it's bad for a guy ghosting and but i could be it
gives you like input delay like a tiny bit so it's probably
oh that's absolutely horrible yeah input delays like the
world the worst negative features you can have it's marginal
though when i think it's like yeah for people who have like
shitty rpcs it's it's probably better for them i haven't
eaten yet so i'm gonna take a few bites i'm gonna take a few
bites right now america united right that's our first game
luckily guys i don't think these people play daredevil and
he is like one of the hardest characters in the game so i
don't know how many daredevil will actually run into get
some food in my system boom boom boom boom num num num num
num yeah i um oh a mary united is the one with the um with
the scary phoenix with an 80 something percent win rate i
just look like it yeah yeah but the thing is it's like
banning his phoenix we just move him to starlord or if we
yeah exactly cycle up so it's really there's really no point
in right yeah in trying to ban him out yeah so let's just
let's I agree with that.
Oh, so we're choosing not to, uh...
I do think Brazil might be the hardest team.
I don't think they play it, Warren.
Oh, okay.
I thought they did.
No, yeah, I've got their hero pools up here.
Right here.
Now, that should be basically right.
There might be a little bit missing from there but that
should be basically right oh yeah someone should invite uh
fox in oh okay wait which team was i missing that though
armory which was the team with it that might have been
brazil oh yeah it may have been i am realizing my game
because i'm turning off from changes to try it if you're
okay are you gonna reload your shaders oh god they've got
three coaches no they got two coaches oh they got two x did
you turn off that dlc bullshit in steam it's right no what
is that okay dude if you right click marvel rivals in your
steam uh games and then you go properties dlc and uninstall
the high resolution package rank wise i think america united
and brazil instantly boosted my fps by like more hiring
players like like average as an average i think yeah yeah
well i'm not i have to be loading minima because of my
that's why i'm like it's fine it's fine listen they've
already delight delayed this tournament by an hour and a
half whatever yeah like i looked into their ranks and they
have a lot of like one above all eternity players excited to
hang out with you guys more yep hey
that's why i was just like not the vc going completely
silent as i'm like oh sorry i'm typing in our in our chat
because like i was running a book a lot of people were like
saying canada's the strongest but uh we have players that
like oh even more tickets now jesus we have players that go
play the game consistently including me i don't play the
game but how do you uninstall the high resolution uh ameri
you and oh whoa whoa this is weird i have more frames but my
mouth is like very very like play consistently a lot oh what
um what's the polling rate on your mouth consistent players
are mostly in support i mean we just use 1000 no Mine's
4.8k.
If it's above 2k, you have to cap it in an external program.
What?
It depends on the chemistry.
I think like you like lag.
US and Canada, like, wait, okay, I am running 8k, sorry.
Yeah, I have the 8k as well.
Which team is like, in your mouse team is like, software or
cap it.
I'm trying not to cap it in game, but just like, which team
seems like a way to cap it in game.
Because I feel like Canada, USF are very like, try to cap
it.
Similar wise, because their best players all play rivals
consistently, and they're not, like distributed between
three different roles um they play rivals consistently
distribute between three different roles you have time and
then uh okay well in Canada we have pro players who are good
at other games but they don't play rivals consistently so
it's like you can't really you know see like how it
transfers over to rivals um so like that's why I can't tell
which teams have the advantages of Canada versus US well
this is interesting with there's an in-game pooling rate to
change the polling rate when running games super
consistently like almost every day okay so like i can tell
judge their most games only support 2k so i do 2k i can
judge their skill level based off of like how many much they
play no thank god bro i can't play but like because like you
can look at our team our highest ranked players are all in
support but then we have x warren and surefour who are both
really talented fps players in other games so but it's i
think you can on this game they're low elo whenever i went
in practice so it's more so like you know it's so hard to
tell and you're like a team usa their best players are all
consistent players on different roles morian fox can you
check the chat and yeah uh first game i'd like gary and foot
fox um i mean i'm not gonna downplay x's accomplishment he
was one the best tank players during his peak in overwatch
at that time um because i was i was within the overwatch
community he was really he was like before he blew up as a
streamer he was an insane like tank player before he blew up
in streaming um and like he was really really good
and he's he what he he he is still i think it's more like
that um He still has, like, the game sense and the game
knowledge.
That's what I want.
Okay, okay, perfect.
If SureFour is playing that, I think that's going to have a
lot of impact, and then that can help Aramori.
Yeah.
And then I think that backline is actually, like, kind of
really strong.
Kind of really.
Well, it's weak to dive, but I don't know if we'll be
playing against it.
No, I don't think there's many teams playing dive.
Who are we missing?
We're missing you, Warren?
Wait, what do you mean I'm missing me?
can i go p yeah they'll ask us where are so we can they they
asked oh they would oh you can go p you can go p man phase
takes a while well the other team isn't r yet so we're fine
i'm gonna say we're ready and then we can yeah man phase
yeah the the one pivot would be like this for you doki i
think we could go like this okay are you in fan fan oh that
is what i think would do because of uh when do i when do i
when do i go that though um on specific maps like i'm
talking i'm thinking like okay yeah that would be one um
yeah that would probably be the main one uh maybe like maybe
like that map too yeah okay Okay, perfect.
I think you're not allowed now.
Now that you're not allowed.
I think he has to go when Ban phase starts.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Bye bye bye.
No, after Ban phase, right?
No, it's like- I'm not allowed to be in here for Ban phase,
and then once the map starts, I leave.
Oh, yeah.
This one is, for this one, we're doing, for this map, we're
doing this.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, wait, we're, we ban first.
That's awesome.
Warren, you're talking in game.
What do you mean I'm talking in game?
Your mic's open in game.
No.
Uh, I'll just...
Who's the leader?
It's Armory.
Me, I am.
Oh, okay.
You're also, yeah, he's not allowed.
I'm yummy, I'm yummy, I'm yummy.
Stop.
Uh, Falx is not allowed to type.
Am I banning?
No, no, I'm banning.
Okay.
We're good.
I thought it was something I had to deal with.
It's okay.
Just be passenger princess X.
Mantis ban.
Oh, good.
Save Gamby, right?
I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm having my brains out for these.
Oh, shit.
And then what do you...
Yo, yo, yo.
Guys, guys, can we start protecting Squirrel?
What are we doing?
Then, yeah, yeah, Elsa.
Okay.
Please protect her, please, I beg.
It's not going to get banned, Warren.
Nobody's banning Squirrel Girl, bro.
believe i've got an intel from my analyst they would want
they would want us to play squirrel girl at that point they
might ban it or like teams that like know you personally
like team usa yeah team usa may have been yapping about it
but maybe last second clutch what do we just in case can you
say can you say brute yeah it's not getting banned if it
gets banned we'll protect it but like okay deal yeah that's
not getting banned bro If I knew you were wanting to play
Squirrel Girl, bro, I would be as happy as can be.
Sighlock initially.
Yeah, can we ban Sigh?
Yeah.
Okay.
Since, okay, wait, Ban phase is almost over.
What do, can you check the chat box?
Yeah.
Oh, nice, nice.
Okay.
Ooh.
Wait, so who, who, who me?
Uh, you are...
Sue or a cloak?
A chat box.
I don't do chat box.
Go that.
Can you, and Flake, go Flake Oramori, okay?
Okay.
I go.
All right.
Good luck, guys.
Bye.
Yeah.
All right.
My heart was pounding right there, guys.
I can't lie.
Here we go.
It's okay.
No, no.
It's not.
If Squirrel Go gets banned, I lose my identity.
Wait, I don't think teams...
Teams would want us to play Squirrel Girl.
They would want us to play Squirrel Girl.
They're going to change their mind very quickly.
We sure a long way from the biggies.
All right.
in this calm I'm gonna need my like core so like XQC and my
supports just chill me yeah sure for yeah can clear things
often okay if I'm that's why we played this if I'm having
trouble with Luna do you think I swapped the invis or cloak
with the gambit since there's gambit in the game you can you
can do invis if you want okay just are we all right if
you're if they're playing dive and they get on top of you
just put snowflake on yourself and clap your team and okay
like self-healing to you though let's game all right should
i always be flaking myself to clap or just keep it on you no
just keep it on me okay i'm gonna go top left and clear all
right we got this guys let's go i'm winning point they're
going point they're playing player yeah yeah point point
point point right now i'm ready to go behind i'm i'm ready
to go They'restäivo.
They're point.
Okay.
Y'all just poking out political, the b-line name.
Get low in the back.
Huge anti.
Okay.
I'm walking up.
I'm clapping.
I'm grabbed.
God.
Oh, can be lined?
on me, laney weak.
Or gambik.
Gambit low.
Huge anti.
Help, brig.
Help our group.
Help our crew.
I'm behind them.
I don't have cards.
You know, I'm getting pushed right now.
I got you.
I need help.
I need help in here.
I think who is that?
Nothing.
Rogue one.
Oh.
All right, listen.
They're playing like a crazy, crazy, crazy brawl comp.
So I need my front line to play really slow and wait for me
and Shreveaux to set up and get behind.
Okay.
I'll do that.
Just play slow right now.
Play slow.
We need to make our waltzes as well.
Let's hop left.
On us.
I'm going to go.
I'm going to go far right.
Okay, Shreveaux.
There's two here.
There's two here, bro.
Three, three, three.
We're waiting for our group.
We're not ready yet.
I got kidnapped.
Yeah, you got it.
I can trade perhaps.
I got you.
You might be able to go here.
Oh, Lord.
I scroll left.
I'll go left.
Need to heal.
See what?
You tell me I'm on play.
I'm on play.
We're going to keep you up.
Oh, yeah, yeah, we can.
You're alone.
You're all alone.
I'm 72.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to go, Emma.
We're going to just fight front to back.
Sure.
I'm gonna keep my flake on you.
Fanfan, you might need to go sue here.
Yeah.
So we can go swap now or after all.
After all, I think.
I haven't been able to.
I haven't been able to build my ult that much here.
Let X walk up and take some damage and nobody else walk up
behind him, please.
Let him take some damage and we make our Luna.
They have double good ammo.
Yeah, yeah.
Just slow.
Just really slow.
Really slow.
Let me build out here.
Let me build it.
82.
I'm getting sucked off.
Come on, Alta.
Maybe we can try to get a trade.
If you're a little bit more patient there, sure, for we make
our gambit and we can combo okay and we can kill through.
But you went you went early so they have they have more also
so they just win.
yeah catch catch catch yeah i don't think we have to is next
game next round okay okay just go next go next go next just
build ups here sure i what's the name of that character we
should be comboing right yeah we need a combo here we get
yeah i'll go i'll alt and then i'll swap all right i'm gonna
have to go strange i think i'm super exposed um if you want
sure for you can also go pun puns really good with gambit
and it just kind of melts dino like you can just shock on
him in the mouth that sounds good oh yeah i think ben when
you all just go sue so you push okay people away from the
wolf because wolf has alt now yeah yeah yeah we have we have
gambit all advantage here i could use gambit all first yeah
we should i'll use i'm feeling a little awkward like poking
from a distance i just need i need to get in their face yeah
so their comp is better at doing that so we just need to
like this fight we have really fast but just in general we
need to play a little bit slower okay okay they have dino we
don't dino is is king he'll he'll grab you if you get in the
space i can stun the dino let's own him uh he's unceaseable
wait what yeah we might have to stop us girl girl too all
right walk close let me start behind us all right call for
it i will i will ready three two one let's go Okay.
No, they're low already.
Wolves looking for grabs.
Huge anti.
You got one.
We're up.
Oh, he got me.
He got me.
I'm on wolf.
He's absolute.
Oh, he's holding my round.
I'm holding my round.
I'm on each other now.
Where you stand there?
Okay.
Do you want TP or not?
No, no, not TP.
Okay.
Uh, they're gonna be 50 to another gambit.
Let me start with my alt.
Okay.
Do I need to wait for Gambit?
Okay, no, I'll just ult whenever.
Wait for me, wait for me.
I'm not there.
I'm out there.
Wait for me.
They're just going to give me a speed energy here.
Yeah, just wait, wait, wait, wait.
I've got a nice chance.
Waiting, waiting.
Alright, I'm here.
Ready?
There's a wolf ring on the left side.
I think I'm holding on the coin here.
Alright.
Nice.
Dino's half.
Yeah, I anti-die.
I anti-die too.
Five, four.
I'm inside again.
Two, one.
I got it.
i got grabbed i got grabbed here unlucky i got grabbed i'm
stopping nice that's two dead by the way rogue is the
halfway point but he's woven star in gambit a bit of heals
i've got squirrels open i don't know am i just ripping this
all maybe i scroll first we're gonna triple dps here what do
we do for the punisher and shoot oh anti i'll scroll first
to try and force cooldowns and then you then you all china
right yeah they're gonna have gambit all here so they're
gonna push with that really fast okay we can use uh fun
defensive but just be ready because they're gonna try and
kill through okay wolves coming in hot outside i'm grabbed
i'm grabbed i'm grabbing i'm getting yeah you're getting ran
out yeah i think we have time for portal whoever dies first
has to portal oh so whoever oh i don't think we can portal
now no i don't think X comes first, no?
No, not as much.
No, no, no.
Not enough.
I don't think we get it.
No.
No, it's okay.
That's only one game.
Yeah, I mean, it's best of three.
Okay, let's talk to Fox.
We can, right?
Yeah, no, we can.
Oh, wait, between the games.
In between games.
I saw Team Korea did that, so we should be able to.
Wait, is it PO3 only one game, is it?
No, it's best of three.
okay okay okay that's all um i mean i mean this particular
car is just b03 on that particular crop as well it's best
it's best of three for this match yeah against them oops
yeah x when you when you play against a grute or a bucky or
anything when you put your group big wall down and you hide
it somewhere whenever you're within what is it like 20
meters 10 meters something like that you are unceaseable
like so you can't get grabbed you can't get uh just anything
you can't get slept nothing um so what group players will do
is they'll just like hide it and then they'll um walk up and
they can't get grabbed by wolf at all okay i'll try that
okay what i think this guy's like literally like it doesn't
matter what you guys do he'll he'll literally ignore
everything and just go for me every time it's like which way
which guy i think we just run olive rain yeah yeah i think
we ban wolves so we can play like regular well we can also
mirror it because again we're playing grout and they're not
so it's like we could always go sure for on wolf and then
play like a super death ball type of comp with like cloak
loki do we have a damage with wolf squirrel girl though with
the yeah let's ban wolf let's ban wolf you want to ban it
yeah let xcc play the game all right that's the problem is
like we can't play oh i was gonna overwatch we can't play
rivals with with wolverine snatching i yeah i think we
either ban dino or battle brain but having both of them up
at some time is undealable they double kidnap it's really
lame it's like it makes the yeah yeah we only have one push
too from the zoo okay okay all right i think we should leave
dino up dino got nerfed he's not as good if i'm on emma i
can just beam him like the the counter to dino is just
shooting him actually um okay we could do something like
this then that's like something we can do is it two bands or
oh he's a three bands never mind it's three it's three bands
right and i'm thinking our protects could be something like
yeah i think we uh prior ban on so down so down stupid ass
wolverine it it even when i stunned him twice he's one hp
gets four elf armor yeah it's very bad it's very very bad to
build a player against not fun why are you running the
squirrel he's a squirrel girl one trick They all have hidden
profiles.
That's why.
But we told him, like, we told him he has to swap off if
it's not working.
They're all hidden profiles.
So most likely he'll swap off this one.
They're all, Armory, they're only able to do that because we
protect a Gambit.
If we don't protect Gambit, we can just do it last.
Right?
Okay.
What do you want to protect instead then?
Um, probably this.
And...
that maybe it's a curse okay maybe it's a curse if warren's
on my team we're not gonna we're we're gonna get last it's
just no i don't it's just a turkey warren curse it was like
the turkey gail curse remember the turkey gail and we're
both together on a team we get last place in tournaments and
then like the moment they split us up we stop placing last
like gail and i the moment we stop being together on a team
we both were like gail got first i got second i swear we
beat them yeah i'm not gonna either we're gonna win guys
don't worry this is just the first game flute yeah like
we're both good players individually yeah it's just it's
like it's like it's like a curse
yeah because i think i think if we if we ban that last i'm
glad we don't i don't think i'm i'm just a listener that's
what i'm saying i'm saying i feel like then like fan fan on
sue or cloak or rocket i feel like i agree okay what you do
you think you want to do this doesn't work then for our next
match we can start pivoting and see if we can do like the
solo tank triple see how that works let's destroy them i
think you're playing well on the on the tank i'm i'm
actually vibing right now honestly but that's what i'm
saying i think like i think emma united and brazil have
really strong teams because their most consistent players
are the highest not our men that's what i'm saying at the
end of the research their analysts are not popping off so i
knew their teams were gonna be super strong yeah we're going
doing it second they might say that they're protect or they
protected Jitmo's character last time.
Oh, guys.
I think they protect the wolf.
If they protect the wolf, then we can do the the die.
We can ban Dino here.
That's fine.
I think they have their manager analyst listening in on to
Mimi.
We can do the we can do the Dino here.
Okay.
It just means sure four is going to mirror it, guys.
It'll be fine.
I think Brazil might be hired.
We're talking about the picks and bans in like team chats.
you guys want to like have input that's where it's happening
yeah i think if our main tank player says we should ban wolf
we should always ban wolf first oh okay all right
that's okay and then just take out the rogue last year yeah
yeah all right
all right let's go is that a galley game again i'll hide
wall i think a big difference okay okay so if we go grew
tank pool or may or emma you could probably play emma here
low key let's piece him up go go emma go wolf and then warn
you do your thing and then we can go gamut luna or gamut sue
goes go go sue uh okay fan fancy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay just play guys play really really aggro when x is
walking right like when we're on that first point and like
we're on that back high ground just play with them play
aggressive play fast and try and go first okay they're not
going to be ready for this if we go first and we play fast
with the wolf we're going to be in a good spot okay all
right yeah all right good luck guys thank you thank you all
right let's go let's go team i ain't gonna lie this might
sound like i've never played that map before outside of that
just wait this map is the most on the maps no no no the last
one with the tps and stuff i was lost i didn't know where i
was going let's just um let's just debate the dive you poke
your nose out and then you uh you cannot dive walk backwards
walk forward our coach said just be aggressive and go first
yeah but we should just go aggressive we're gonna be really
we're gonna be so much stronger than them we're gonna dump
it's like we overruled is coach your captain we follow okay
come throw an emma yeah maybe mirror no they have mag inside
we have a stronger front line i'm walking up okay let's do
it look shoot the star on the right shoot the star on the
right back line already.
I'm grabbing.
Pulled, pulled, pulled, pulled.
Nice, nice.
I'm looking for a kidnap.
They have no bubble.
I'm on Meg.
I'm like, I'm trying to help.
Oh, I couldn't keep you up.
I tried.
You're still trained?
It's not over.
I'm with you.
We'll battle.
I didn't have enough heals for that.
Yeah, I was plucking him as well.
Yeah, me too.
I haven't used my cards.
Warren, you might have to swap here.
Real shit.
What do you stop to?
Like Cyclops or Phoenix or Stars?
He has to stop after death.
Ancya, is Mag?
Hold on, let me know.
Favor bubble.
Where's the wolf?
I stunned him.
One HP, one HP!
Scylark behind!
I can't do anything about it.
I'm shooting at my mana diamond!
Stun again!
Stunned again, Mag!
Scylark up again in the back.
I need help, I need help!
That's all.
I can't do anything about that.
I need Warren to look behind Warren.
You need a looking he did.
Oh no, he's still behind us.
Broke me Weak weak we don't have anything we have anything
yeah, we have
We have invisible.
Yeah I'm okay.
We're up.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Yeah, war.
If the Starler's behind you have to look behind Nothing else
no one else can do it.
Watch out.
That's what?
That's okay.
I can try it Okay foi, I need help here.
I need help here.
Oh, no.
They're coming, coming, coming.
Wait, I grabbed him.
I could stun.
I'm here.
I'm putting nines.
Yeah, I need farm.
You're gonna put the game runs, I'm vital here.
I'm gonna let them just go.
Just go.
Okay.
Interesting.
I waste my health for that's okay.
No, 94, 94, 94.
Let me heal us, let me heal us.
We can go for gurgle here on corner.
I'm ready.
I'm ready!
X!
Oh, multi.
Get on.
I got a star on.
Oh, I'm trying to get in it.
I got grabbed.
I got grabs.
Three two one.
I got out of... I got grabbed out.
Held down point.
I force Glpoke.
I have Gambit's fortnight.
That's huge.
Gloke is behind us.
I die I die.
So don't push up.
Don't push up.
Good job.
I could farm another squirt.
They have no support ults.
Yeah, we can go in with They have mangled, okay?
Really important we carry this mangled.
Okay.
I'm gonna be late.
I'm waiting.
Star behind.
Star's still behind.
Story's on you.
Grit's on him.
Are we ready?
Yeah.
Right up to this corner.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
I got an M.O.
That's thunder.
Stunder.
Star's still behind.
I'm contesting.
Sorry.
She's not behind anymore.
I'm looking forward.
Oh, we just walk up with it.
Looking for nice.
Support that.
I'll support that.
We don't need it anymore.
Nice shield.
No ults.
No more ults.
Star lord.
Star lord on point.
We're shooting.
Yeah, looking for him.
He's one, one, one, one, one, one.
Nice!
They're gonna have star lord ults here.
We don't have squirrels, but yeah.
I've got ults.
Can we take a quick fight with my ult then?
Before they even like...
Yeah, we have no ults for the star lord.
But we need to...
Let's all walk on it.
I'm a third person.
I don't think we should go to...
Take damage.
Excuse me.
I'm not healing.
I'm gonna have to die though.
If they walk this.
Don't get grabbed.
Yeah, no, I'm walking.
I'm looking for a kid now.
Okay.
I'm about to go.
Yeah, three, two, one.
I'm alting.
They got split.
Stun, stun, stun, stun, stun, stun, stun, stun.
Come on, Emma.
Their backline's getting pieced up.
Emma, Emma, Emma, Emma.
Nice, nice, nice.
Someone's behind us.
I'm walking up.
All right.
I'm letting you build.
I'm on Starlord up top.
I'm with you.
I missed my.
I'm letting you build out.
Okay, chill, chill, chill.
I have my own here.
I'm not doing anything.
They're going to play out.
They're going to ult the gambit.
I will ult the gambit.
I'm on strange.
I'm holding him.
Oh, you're so far from me.
Strange one.
We can win.
We can win still.
Are we looking at?
Oh, I need help.
I got you.
I don't think I can get everybody though.
I'm on mag.
Get on point, get on point.
We need TP.
Yeah, yeah, I'm just wanting to run out of it.
Okay, I'll only go in.
Oh, I don't think we have TP.
I don't think we can TP outside.
I don't think we can TP inside.
I can lose also.
Dude, that was close.
We did better, though.
Yeah, we did.
That was way better.
I understand the matchup now.
It's just, we should have, we should have what we had on
fight, like two or three, like off the gate.
So it should be way better now.
Okay.
Klein needs to really care, like, Ols, like, way more.
Like, you guys need to talk to each other about where you
want to play and make sure you guys are scissors.
No, that was my fault.
I went somewhere else.
Okay.
Or, like, they portaled right in front of my face.
Yeah, yeah, she got incredibly split off.
This map is, like, is, like, baby mode for supports.
You got the little, like, doorways on either side of point
is so safe.
You guys should just be able to, like, live in there
forever.
It is playing next to me, because I was playing behind our
team.
Okay.
I kind of have to...
Did they gambit at the end?
I don't remember the gambit will get out of portal okay
they're gonna have close
cloak I can try and Wolverine all the let's destroy them we
need to play right side opposite of the whole we don't want
to be in the middle I'm gonna get tossed in every time it's
boring I'll try to grab the you just got to be more
proactive let's react sorry lord's behind us already heard
i'm keeping angles on uh wolf you had to come to me come to
me okay i'm coming out yeah yeah she's just gonna i we have
to i got grabbed out of it out yeah he's just gonna keep
doing that stun him nice you have no supports though yeah
they're just gonna save wolverine all for his yeah all the
time you have to like jump and stay in viz so or like in
this in front of you not in like in the walk um walk top
right everyone walk top right yeah stop them um they
shouldn't have support like if we go really quick with like
a wolf or something if you want to try i can try and build
up too here wolf under what was up here okay i'm walking i'm
dropping i'm walking there's a wolf below us star lord half
he's pushing your squirrel i'm dropping back Need heals?
I couldn't.
I saw there one HP in the sky.
Dead, dead, dead, dead.
I'm strapped.
If it's winnable, I can ult this.
Is this winnable?
I don't think so.
Okay, well he ulted, so I'm doing...
Oh.
That's fine.
Let me.
Yeah.
It's fine.
They mag ulted.
I did it because X ulted.
Fine.
I got squirrels.
Both is right side.
Hand side mag.
Cool right.
You should pull.
the angle we have to push in or outside of the space going
in star behind yeah i'm just making this the star i bubble
you guys me stunned wolves stunned wolf no never mind i got
both i got grabbed they used a lot there though they they
know i've also they're really just all looking at me so i
need like we need to go in unfortunately yeah i'm trying i
think i'll score this in i don't know
they've got cloak old
maybe emma That's a huge anti!
Oh, they clinced it.
I'm right.
Mold behind...
We'll come in, hot!
I bubble behind you.
Why behind you?
Try behind me.
Oh, I'm trying to get to you.
I got you.
Hold on, mo, mo, mo, mo, mo, mo, mo, mo, mo, I contested for
Starlet.
I'm gonna touch last second.
Yeah, I'm gonna touch it.
Awesome.
Be engaged.
I'm going now.
Yeah, so I, yes.
Florida's on your scroll.
I'm for the...
I'm trying.
No, Starlet's above us.
I'll try.
I cannot contest him yet.
I can try and contest him.
I'm gonna have old for this next fight.
I'm gonna let FanFan build her all up.
I'm gonna have to go on the cloak and force her all early,
okay?
And then FanFan, you have to old later in the fight.
Okay.
Really crazy.
We don't have portal.
Emma and Wulbilt.
Emma and Wulbilt here.
And Star.
Okay.
Star and Wulbult.
You're going early, you said?
Yes.
Okay.
I'm grabbed.
It's on point.
I'm gonna attack by a wood again.
I'm trying to keep you up.
I got you.
I'm trying.
I'm dead.
I'm trying to keep you up.
I just almost got it.
That's 10%.
No, I don't think you're...
No.
I do think we might need to get a squirrel girl because we
had no one contesting the starlord but me right right i
literally had to chase the starlord so fan fan was by
herself a lot okay because we need someone to shoot the
flankers yeah we need a gun we have no gun like i i had to
chase the starlord all the time yeah i mean for sure i mean
i could i could go namor for anti-dive i know you guys are
saying it's bad but we should if we ban wolf if we ban wolf
then sure for is good at hit scan yeah yeah yeah that's
that's my fold x i'm sorry bro i i didn't think they would
protect it because they protected uh one of jitsmo's
characters last time so i didn't think they would first
protect the wolf so yeah i you can first my my redundant was
just because it was so effective that i feel like they would
have locked in on like it's just doing so well like it was
just protected you know what i mean yeah yeah it was rolling
you're right you're right you're right so we we go next now
we're not against these guys anymore i needed you guys out
how did i do that sorry sorry i don't want to yeah yeah i
think that i think that can solve a lot of our problems my
only concern is like if if teams get their uh their first
protect and it's like a daredevil or a cap or something like
that or like a venom then it's like that'll force us to play
dive and that forces to play against diving that's gonna be
hard but i don't see what we'll see dive is a lot worse in
these kind of tournaments as well Fox that's something to
keep in mind yeah yeah yeah so what's the scouting on Brazil
can we get a Wolverine Billy I think they have a wolf player
don't they uh I can share my screen uh I mean we first ban
wolf it's fine they say this is what they play what's
tournament format like what what does that entice what does
that mean that we lost a game we just need to win the next
and then we'll be we qualify so this is what it says that
they play so these people are the people who play the game
and then these are their i think players i don't play that
often it was just hard because because i had to contest but
then uh but then our xqc was getting so much damage that
like yeah what chat it was hard because it was just one
support keeping him up but it should be it should be our
other pps contesting the starlord not me because i don't
have i don't have the privilege to contest yeah yeah like i
don't have the privilege to to contest the moment i and then
i was like can you please contest but and then i was just
like fuck it i'll i'll go after the starlord yeah but they
like the the guy this guy also doesn't typically play it but
he's a one-of-a-ball player but yeah and then so like they
had two one-of-a-ball couldn't contest because he was on
wolf duty too so i guess they just flexed on to wolf that's
so that's why i really want to get off scroll girl besides
because if they have a flying character and we if we if they
have a violent character i have to be the only one contest
but it's really hard because so i have to be still if they
really don't want to play against it because i get i don't
want x to feel like he can't have impact in the game Yeah,
let's just ban to play what we want.
And we know we want to play front to back.
So let's just fucking ban the wall first.
And then we can go from there.
And I do think if teams play like cap venom, that sort of
thing.
And we're just like really, really hard brawl front to back.
I think we'll just win off of just mechanics.
Can you tell me a little bit more about...
Hold on.
Can you guys tell me a bit more about the Gambit rogue
combo?
Because that was pretty devious too.
They just have a team up.
Yeah, Gambit has a team up with rogue.
that just makes her do more damage and heal her allies when
she punches people around her interesting okay well so when
are they ready to play it was really hard there to do damage
from on my end because everyone's taking so much damage so i
had to force my cards in the heal but a lot of times so guys
here's what uh if you look in team chat that's what they
were playing oh they're playing now i could scout them out
yeah this is what they were playing the other day
right i mean they're playing right now so you can see what
they ran yeah uh oh
um x have you played group with the new wall change where
you don't get cc'd uh yeah yeah i tried but these guys are
like locked in on it they had flankers like shooting in and
whatnot yeah just someone was breaking it really fast
sorry i was kind of afk what do we know what they're banning
i mean do we know what we're gonna ban against them uh not
really i mean like what i'm thinking about doing against
this team this is just a suggestion again if we really want
to take out the wolf is like something like this that kind
of forces them in the front to back group me or versus us
but it risks them protecting mantis first of them then
playing triple support with group but that's okay well we
can just do the same then yeah okay this is a close game
though between them and usa where we and we have to be both
yeah we have to be both we have to be both yeah to qualify
for day two because it's like whichever team has three
kingsman and flats we're not playing against them right now
though no usa is the last the last one let's focus on uh
let's focus on brazil first yeah that's what that's what
we're looking at so brazil band cat gambit and ultron all
right so maybe it's good for us maybe i don't know something
like that
who's that call out at did someone invite someone yeah i
don't know
fan fan what's your what's what's your best character like
if we're playing if if we put Loki on like Luna or Loki.
What would you want to play with her?
Cloak or Invis.
Okay.
That might work though.
Because if we're playing Groot, Loki, Cloak, that might be
really strong.
Especially if we ban the Wolves.
We'll have just Cloak Alts permanently.
So that could be really good.
I don't know.
Armory, what do you think?
What?
What do you think of like the line that I put?
They'll probably play like what they're playing right now.
Like this Mantis.
like that guy handless off of it or what off of of which
character that character she just wrote that's what i was
looking at too maybe i don't know but like are we really
concerned about that character when surefork can play it no
but i think he might be handless off of it no i mean that
guy's he's level 36 and silver one oh shoot a plot one sorry
my bad that i mean that literally pointing click okay i mean
okay what i would like to do then i guess is like i'll let
you guys decide then if you guys think that's a good idea
because like that's i think is the best you just put him on
that that's characters broken anyway yeah yeah i oh yeah i
know i know that the what i just put in team chat is like
what i would like to do but then then that risks that
so oh instead of banning it first yeah but they're not
playing it and they haven't shown the ability to play it so
yeah but if they can play it and they saw if they're also
scouting and they saw how yeah exactly I agree with you Doki
I feel like if anybody was watching what just happened to us
they're just gonna insta like they're just gonna do that
they also but but keep in mind guys they also like that DPS
line we just played they're both one above all top 500 DPS
players it but i felt it very quickly so so like they're
they're arguably better than kingsman j3 so right yeah but
also like it did put our tank out of commission too so like
any other dps characters they play we can do more for our
tank fair enough yeah i i also i think it lets us play like
loki cloak without issue too or like luna cloak guys on
spider-man What's the first map of this?
I don't know.
I think it's random dong.
Is it pre-selected?
It is pre-selected.
It's pre-selected.
It's husk.
Husk, then burning to cello, then royal powers.
Oh, oh, MRC bands.
Oh, Brazil band Cyclops Bucky Magic.
Oh, that's right.
It was a USA band, Cap, Gambit, Ultron.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
They're, like, pretty even.
Guys, no matter what happens, I did my job.
You know?
Whatever happens, it's not me.
It's true.
It's never my fault.
Yeah.
I just, I wish I was able to do more DP.
Yes, like on Gambit, because I'm like, also, because
everyone's allergic to portaling.
I do think we gotta get our portaling strat down, because I
feel like everyone didn't want a portal when we needed a
portal.
I think, like, yeah, that was something that we, like, this
is first person dead, right?
Yeah, it's first person dead.
Unless it's a support with all.
First person dead portal.
like we just walked all of us just walked out of spawn
trying to figure out who's gonna portal
yeah i looked in front of me three people in front of me
it's like guys portal
yeah they win a point wait this is close let's go to brazil
this is good this is really close i mean these teams are
pretty even yeah
yeah i just think it's just it's our first game together so
chemistry synergy is a chemistry synergy is off right now
just because like we're not we're not synced up together i
just thought it was so funny i'm just guys portal and then
can you guys look at the in an x portal but he died like
second last oh okay sorry i was looking at the the last one.
I just thought it was funny.
Yeah.
It's just...
We just need to figure out our comp in general.
I think, like, the hardest part was just the fact that I
couldn't DPS as much as I would have liked to as well.
I felt like every time I tried to DPS, like, I needed to
heal.
So it's like...
My damage was so low.
Because, like, the whole thing about Gambit is that I have
the damage, i felt like i never had the opportunity to like
if we play like we can yeah hold the fan fan look at this
because the starlight was just like free shooting us for
like a full full two like three minutes that's at least what
i'm thinking because it's like then it shouldn't be that bad
but yeah it's still not ideal like i was just like guys he's
still behind us guys i was like picking which one of those
characters we don't want to right
yeah and i my whole point is that i have to be able to
damage so i could build my alt fast so the other gambit was
out building my alt too like i wasn't building all as fast
as i should have
been that's what like i was just like oh you know on the dps
deadpool i wish i had more of a chance to do more on gambit
i wanted to swap off gambit too at that point because i felt
like i if i was on luna if i was on luna or something else i
Like, I don't know.
I think if I was Luna, I could have 1v1 the Star Lord
better.
But as Gambit, it was a lot more difficult.
Yeah, we're fighting Brazil next.
Because that's what I was saying.
People were like, oh, Canada's the strongest.
And I was like, I don't think so.
I looked at the teams individual-wise.
I was like, Canada is not the strongest.
I think America United is the strongest.
Based off of, like, who they're best.
players are like who their most consistent players are our
most consistent play the most consistent players are the
support players because like you know they might have good
like it's just more so of like game knowledge we're
the most well-known we have the most well-known players yeah
we have the most well-known players but that doesn't mean
our team was the strong is the strongest that's That's why
people were like, oh, US, US, Canada.
I was like, I thought, I'm a United individual-wise.
Individual rank-wise, or average-wise, I felt like I'm a
United in Brazil were scarier for me.
I felt like, I don't know, I feel like Sheriff were playing
a deep, like, hit.
I wasn't sure if we're on a hit-scan.
Like, that's his little strongest versus Wolf.
I think, like, I should be more...
vocal and be like let's put sure if we're on hit scan
because i was like just put him on hit scan he can do so
much on hit scan this is next quality what about you talking
about did i miss something no we're just like usa is about
to win against brazil yeah it looks like it yeah about to as
in it's going to distance well actually well no well it's
it's it's yeah that's why it's like there's a lot of people
that you might not know individualized a chance to win right
now in brazil but like i the rank wise they are higher in
terms of rank average yeah i don't want i'm trying not to
think too i don't want to like counter call it too much
though that's the thing i
think we just want to get rid of squirrel girls okay
everyone's everyone's thoughts is just like we gotta get rid
of squirrel girl like i'm sorry warren because like this is
more more high elo players america region is just harder i
think our region is like really hard that's so tough oh no
king's been went out early because um wait they might lose
this yeah the other creator oh that's such a good my goals
that was so good the other create tournaments uh you might
kill them though there's a lot of i guess like players who
are don't who don't play rivals that much but this one i
think our region like we have so many really really good
players in general yeah portal oh i think they went that
they went that i didn't want that dude like you like you so
long he's in a shotgun contest well we were last fight what
yeah this is last fight okay yeah he's saying we're good
like oh yeah i have a question guys what you guys do we do
we really need to ban the wolf i swear these guys don't play
it i think it's okay it's a hard character okay okay what's
the payout what's the payout like like like what do we win
from that like what's the alternative thing that what we win
is they don't get mantis is the ideal if they get mantis
again i think the only reason this game between them and usa
is close is because they're playing triple support i mean we
could marry i mean i mean if you just simplify this the the
risk is game one and the payout is no mantis i i'm okay with
taking the risk that's fine sure let's do it yeah because
like because like if we can ban damn 37,000 damage on
Punisher I mean if you win a round with Punisher I mean yeah
he's gonna have a lot of damage yeah he's either useless or
doing like a bazillion like yeah yeah I mean he owned this
game for sure
I mean low-key armor wait hold on we could let we could let
the mantis through and then take a triple support mirror but
x will be solo tanking is that fine yeah it's fine just just
wolverine uh just i mean did they play wolverine at all did
they they played they haven't shown it they haven't played
it in scrims nor they played it on okay then then let them
deck on the game one that's okay sure let's do it oh okay
all right all right if if if they play it then sure fork and
mirror but if not then i think we can And I think we'll be
set well.
Let's hop in this lobby.
These guys need to hop in.
Otherwise, we're playing against Brazil right now, right?
Yeah.
We're playing against Brazil.
What's the timeout for DNF or whatever?
For disqualified?
For DQ?
What do you mean?
Like, how long do they have to not show up for in front of
the BDQ?
Because I'm not fucking waiting here.
Oh, I think they'll show up.
I already can't hear these guys.
I mean, I'm good at it, man.
I don't know.
we're already tired of waiting dq i'm gonna go i'm gonna go
website i'm gonna find out on the rule book oh my god he's
timing them get that stopwatch out i'm not doing it as we're
speaking
armory i think that's what i would like to do for map one uh
i just sat down let me see worst case scenario they play
this i think like
we we let this character through but i i swear there they go
i mean everybody's gonna snitch about what just happened is
the problem what do you mean yep abel yeah it's fine about a
way about like how our last match went you mean yeah their
last match the people are gonna watch our last match like
he's not like a brain dead character that you just you you
pick and you win right like he is there's some sauce to that
character and the reason it felt so oppressive is because of
how good that guy had sauce that guy was good yeah like like
you like fan fan with suult and he would just wall vault us
out of the out of the suult which is like another star lord
player as good as that guy that we just played against no no
no no that guy was a no that guy was like he didn't rank one
and everything he's currently yeah the thing is like we just
needed a dps to contest him because i couldn't the moment i
turn around to contest him like we couldn't we our team
scott instead i grabbed him i think i think this team's a
lot more like simple the the the the biggest risk with with
this with this if they have the ability to play dive.
But like Aura Mori said, these teams aren't like super,
super dive.
I think the only dive like team is literally Necro's team.
That's the main.
I think the best, I think the worst case scenario, like Aura
Mori, if they go like a dive comp, right, or they get
something off, I think you just abandon tank and go triple
support and play like, we can go like Luna White Fox rocket,
something stupid, right?
And just play to like live, right?
I can do that.
But were they not on dive that last team?
No.
That was not that.
Wait, no, no, no, no.
That was Brawl.
Oh, no, that's Brawl.
Yeah, Rogue's a Brawl character, yeah.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
But, but, okay, Wolverine is considered Brawl not dive.
Yeah, Wolverine's Brawl.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, interesting.
Because he has max HP damage, so he does a lot more damage
to tanks than supports and DPS.
Are we putting on the balance latency thing?
I hope not.
No, it's each team is...
makes ping really bad x what was the time i don't know i'm
just i'm just saying i'm just saying i don't know
i'm just saying i'm just saying i literally can't even can't
even find the rulebook we can make up our own the rulebook
is in the announcement it's in the announcements if you
scroll up it's it yeah you see it it's the second post
matches overview second post okay yeah that has all the
rules Yeah.
DQ.
I don't think they...
I'm skimming through it.
They don't have...
They don't have it.
Oh, wait.
There is.
There's an extra.
Please see the rules.
Where's that?
I don't know that disqualification, though.
Oh, they don't.
It's like...
There's a link on it.
There's like, please see more rules.
Yeah.
X, they didn't add it.
They didn't add disqualification.
Really?
No, they didn't.
Yeah, I guess they have the expectation that everybody is
going to be mutually in good spirits.
Guys, it's a four fun tournament, guys.
Somebody go to the bathroom for the next 18 hours.
I got you.
You said somebody was silver armory?
It was the Fakata guy?
No, I lied.
It was, I said, I said it, but I mistook it for Platte.
uh same thing same thing no their scariest one is lou boo
he's been svp and vp and he plays like all tanks on cap oh
my god the cap is a little scary i can't lie but yeah i
think he was also i think he was also like uh he was a high
mrc player too like he he was on a team yeah the nerd team
that did really well in the last it benefited him
It benefited him because he didn't hit MRI so he could join
this.
There is the...
MRI players are losers.
There is the wild card.
We could get the wild card seated.
If we don't win our next two, if we have the most final
hits, we get to qual as the wild card qualifications.
So basically we just need to have the most final hits.
Can we ask them to do a fan-voted wild card and then we'll
win?
or just win it's like we'll be selected by total hits as the
first point of criteria so two teams from uh from the entire
like who are who are eliminated get to uh still continue
nigger nigger nigger nigger whoa what the hell i leave it
there's no accidents it's not my fault sorry you leak the
discord oh wow that's not good no well xqc viewers everyone
oh really really really i don't think it was our viewer i'm
deafening i'm deafening i'm deafening i'm deafening oh my
god oh he he he he leaked the discord
because he opened the document on stream.
I didn't realize he opened it on stream.
I
can't believe it.
Is it, is the Discord locked?
Is the Discord locked?
Yeah, we good.
I think we're good.
I mean, I can't get into it.
I mean, I do my best.
Like, I didn't realize you opened it on stream.
No, that's funny.
That was hilarious.
though so you were like oh the that was a random and messed
up no it's just i didn't realize when you're like oh the
discreds on it you were saying you had it in all the fans
though like there's no there's no uh like usually there's
like a show is on stream in big whiteaaauls yeah yeah it's
it's just a sign please do not share this with anyone else
that's all they need the they need the You need the yellow
paint for it.
Let me look at the analysis.
It's not a streamer tournament unless some gets leaked.
Am I right?
Oh, yeah.
They're already here.
And it's Team Canada.
Also, it says evolve the production.
Does that mean that my management does for something?
Your management made this tournament.
Oh, okay.
It's running.
by your your production your management team and very nice i
mean you'd give them a note be like in the future please
have big yellow paint yeah i did wait that means we won't
get dq'd if it's run by your guys yeah people have had a
community this is a right of passage for tournament making
so it's all good so leaking this card yeah yeah i mean i
mean streamers and leaks it's just This is how it works.
Not me.
I make sure to never have any desktop capture.
Me too.
Only game capture.
This is, yeah, so I can avoid moments like this.
It's a dangerous thing to have desktop capture.
Oh yeah.
Okay, are they ready?
Cause we're ready to go here, no?
All righty, yeah.
I'm ready.
Someone re-post what we're banning.
Yeah, yeah, I'll post it, I'll post it, I'll post it.
I have so much faith.
boy it's in the top of our team chat it's in the top of our
team should we run it should we run a service more in the
middle or what is yeah because this is like uh all yellow is
kind of lame for them looking i mean my pink's looking good
at 11.
well we can't really get we there's not really a better
server it's predetermined as well so they this is the best
server for them yeah wow that is they want us on northern
virginia yeah it says under each thing so next one will be
game versus kind of one of the unfortunate realities of
being one of the south american teams like dallas is good
for everybody right because it's good for me it's the
routing is very good for that particular server yeah wait
why am i on better ping wait what are we on northern
virginia oh virginia is good for us but it's bad yeah low
key but dallas will be still great for us and it's a little
bit less bad for them pretty much yeah basically are they
asking for dallas It's Virginia Dallas in order.
You know, the tournament ordinance that they want.
That's just a rule book.
Oh, Dallas are green.
Grin.
Are we down for Virginia?
I like being on 18 and you're on 19.
Wait, are we the closest XUC from Quebec?
Yeah.
It's just sort of routing stuff.
The rest of us are West Coast.
Wait, Virginia.
Virginia's right here.
Are you looking at a map?
Should I visit Quebec?
Is Quebec a good place to visit?
You should go to Quebec City.
If you're going to go somewhere, it's very nice.
Both, bro, both, both, both.
Me and Crimson are like looking at vacationing around Canada
because why not?
Not Montreal, two days, Quebec, two days.
Maybe you go to Quebec City, you go to the castle, maybe you
go to like the Falls, something like that.
The Lower Streets?
You know that, no, there's like the Lower Street area with
all the market.
Yeah, yeah, the market.
Yeah, yeah, the Kansas City.
Armory?
I've been there.
What's up?
You haven't been there?
No.
The Falls?
Nope, I've only really been to like Vancouver and Toronto.
That's pretty much it.
Yeah, Montreal.
I loved Vancouver.
You should move out here.
It's the better province.
Okay, well.
Yeah, we need to start.
Yeah, can we just say, are they ready?
They haven't asked us already.
Like, I'm about a straight bang.
Like my brain doesn't like this.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Then just hurry it up.
Tell them where are.
They just said R.
Yeah, yes.
Still CR.
R stands for.
Ready.
Dallas R.
Let's go, guys.
Let's get to 1-1 and then let's go beat USA.
All right, let's go.
Let's go.
Beating Team USA to qualify would be general.
Let's get it.
Let's make them not qualify.
What you are here?
Let's go.
Let's game.
All right.
I'm going to start banning score going on my games because
of you.
You should start disliking.
If he makes a video about this tournament, we should dislike
it all together.
All right.
Mantis first.
What do we do now?
What other tank do you play?
Strange.
Oh, strange.
We're chilling.
Yeah, that's fine.
I only think they'd be bad.
Yeah, we don't.
No.
Yes, yes, yes.
Save it.
Yeah, you should save it.
They will fold them in my whole roster.
Yeah, just save stream tracks.
They do that often.
Um...
Next one for a note says punny.
Mm-hmm.
Should I cap or should we say punny?
Yes.
Yeah, don't do punny.
Um...
And then they plotted Luna.
That's fine.
We can go.
It depends on what they do right here.
Oh, interesting.
They're going to save Wolf.
I think.
They banned Sue.
They're going to save Wolf.
I was going to say that.
The next game we.
Interesting.
No, just ban it, though.
We can just ban it last.
Yeah.
What am I saving?
You can save White Fox.
Save White Fox.
So, we have Luna White Fox.
And then we can just ban Wolf last.
I guess I'll play.
fox okay that's fine yeah we we knew they wanted to play cap
it was just whether whether we could get it last or not so
it's it's fine you guys we'll just have to patty cake really
well and then armory if this if this is going poorly for you
like go go loot go strange tank pool right and then flake
armory and if that's not going great or the cap is getting a
lot of value just pick another support and just go triple
okay pick like ultron or something i don't know oh okay This
is fine.
What did they ban?
Cyclops.
All right, that's fine.
Rockets open.
Yeah.
I don't think you want to play Rockets into his cap, though.
Yeah, I was going to say, we need this for cap.
Yeah, just go Luna White Fox goes strange.
What hit scan you want to run now?
Phoenix is good here.
Elsa is good here.
I think it's up to just...
Oh, I feel like Small Girl Phoenix is so much damage.
Like, it's so much AOE.
Boom, boom, boom.
Yeah, you can do that.
You can do Elsa.
You can do Bucky.
It's whatever you want, sure, for.
just play your heart's content this is you go wild just just
shoot heads good luck i will say like um gambit is open by
the way they might play gambit okay yeah i mean we could
don't worry okay nevermind i was gonna say we could run
again gambit triple gambit loki is open it's a good
offensive like we walk forward with it might be goaded i do
think like i said it at the very end of last game like
whenever we were more proactive we were winning fights
reactive we were losing every single time Maybe it's just
for keeping in mind.
Um, I don't think we were ever reactive.
There's just times where we need to play slow and make
bolts.
Okay.
Yeah, sure.
Four, three, two, one.
We were pretty solid on this map, though, when we played it
earlier.
If the cap isn't that bad, I can swap the yammit.
Okay.
I can also pick up if we really need it.
Let's get it.
Do we want to take angles?
Can somebody follow up Phoenix?
Top right?
I'll go with...
the DPS.
I want the DPS right now.
If you're in Job, let me know.
Star combat.
It's cap.
He's walking it upright.
He's there.
There's a star back there.
Yeah, I'm on him.
I'm on him.
They have no gambit.
They have snipers up top.
I'm shooting them.
They're low.
Just playing slow when cap comes in.
Caps, cap, cap, cap.
It's top.
Yeah, I'm on cap.
We're peeling cap.
We're peeling cap right now.
Let me know when he's out, okay?
He's on me, but I need to fix myself.
I'm here.
I need to go.
Okay.
I'm here.
I need help here.
I need help now.
I can keep me up.
Oh, my other two of them.
Yeah, I got it.
You're slow, low, low, star load half.
You're down heels.
Yeah, I got shot by a cap.
We can't lose to a solo cap.
No, the cap came with the star lord.
I thought we'd be here by now.
Star lord's been flanking, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
If I haven't hit out a lot more, I can just walk it out a
bit more.
Because I was already on E.
Okay, let's all walk top together.
Sure.
okay cap is closer I'm might go gambit here I don't think I
need to place like Fox okay not stay stay for now I think
look at the cap look at the cap everyone shoot cap okay cap
HP half HP walk up a little bit like a little bit big space
yeah everybody walk they're gonna go when you when we drop
you're gonna go you guys I have to do that our Lord is like
hard flanking nice good job good job I need heal.
One more again.
I'm looking.
Come out.
Let's do it.
Let's take a full team fight on point.
Follow X.
I'm clapping front.
Yeah, I'm playing.
Luna weak in the back.
Half HP.
Luna really low.
I'm on their back line.
Shooting their strange and Luna.
Luna weak.
Cap is back.
I'm trying to help.
I'm really good to my arm.
Doing our thing.
I can all...
Nice.
Okay, nice.
Come here.
I stunned Luna.
Stunned Luna.
Okay, they're mirroring.
I'll ult after.
Come on.
I'm trying to get out.
Three, two, one.
Oh, I got hit.
I got hit.
We traded rocket dead.
I froze him.
I'm getting shot.
I'm trying.
I'm trying to get out of here.
Star Wars one.
Thank you.
I'm missing.
I'm missing out.
I'm all seeing the tanks.
I'm dead.
Oh, you're so far over here.
I'm just low on the air.
I just low on the air.
Always one.
Nice.
Good, good, good.
I'm almost back.
Looking cap.
I'm looking cap.
I'm breaking this.
You only have heals.
I can't do anything.
This can break and break.
That's one.
Tapped in the back.
Okay.
Touch, touch, touch.
I can't.
I'm going to go strap pool.
I'm already upgraded.
What do you want me to go?
Just stay.
Just stay what you guys are playing.
Okay.
If you want to go cloak, you can, but...
Mm-mm.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go down here.
I'm gonna triple.
The stall is really putting us off because they can
repopulate really fast.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Like, shit needs to die.
yep part of that is running i can try to dps more than heal
so you get gambit alt faster yeah i'll just try and focus on
dps as well like we might have to just like once we get a
pick on event we might we might just have to like focus fire
more the stranger's low but we he was alive for way too long
i love the smell of superhero team-based pvp combat in the
morning Are we going lower?
They're close top here.
He's in right now.
Remember, we're on three support now, okay?
We should live.
We should...
Yeah, shooting strange.
Force him down.
Wait, Luna top right on me.
I can get some help.
No, he's one, one, one.
I'm just not peeking.
I'm just not peeking, man.
I'm not peeking, man.
We broke.
I'm with our DPS.
I'm with our DPS right now.
Okay.
need heals oh yeah oh yes you're by yourself you're by
yourself yeah i couldn't
war got you we need to be we're a bit too split up here come
but on left okay their cap is gonna be set up above us and
we just have to live okay you're gonna come behind does
everyone stack together
top left.
Don't follow me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cappy cap is only behind, but this should ignore him for
now.
It's nice.
I got him.
I need help though.
Push my hand up, pushing up.
Yeah.
I'm with you.
I'm out.
I'm gonna hold us forward.
Ready?
Yep.
I got you, sir.
I'm just really low behind us.
Alright.
Nice.
That's funny.
Guys, I'm in my support ult.
I'm in my support ult.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Got you.
Okay, my ult's over.
There's our lord still behind us.
I'm 80.
I'm 80 right now.
I'm playing in bunker.
Adai, huge Adai!
Huge Adai!
Any help?
Heal, heal, heal, heal, heal?
Thank you.
Oh yeah, cap one, cap one.
We shouldn't need Gambit here.
Yeah, we don't, we don't.
We'll get a star fire.
Oh, that's our fire.
Sorry, please.
Okay.
Help X, help X.
Help X.
Okay.
We can- kill, kill, uh, train, train, train.
Train, train, train, slow.
I'm going high.
I will here.
Can you?
You guys follow up high ground?
There's a starlight behind us.
I see that.
Top right, top right, top right.
No flip.
Oh, that's okay.
We should go really early.
Can you, can you gambitle then?
I'm doing it now.
Yeah, I'm doing it now.
Oh my god.
I couldn't get to you.
I- Oh my god, I shouldn't have altered.
I think it was- I should have just hit.
You should just hit.
We get 30 and that's it.
No.
Do I saw more?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't know.
I'm going to attack you really hard here.
I'm with you.
Same thing.
Let's walk bottom left again, okay?
This feels empty.
They're close.
Cap is close.
Cap is very close.
Up the right.
They're going to engage.
We can look for a strange role at the defensive, okay?
Play together.
Please stack.
Yeah.
I'm playing bunker.
All right.
I'm on cap.
Cap absolute.
All right, Try and stay on.
If you die, then you're going to have to TP, okay?
Everyone has to TP.
Walking up, walking up, walking up now.
I don't have it.
We don't have anything.
I'm trying to live.
I'm on the point.
I'm on it.
It's over.
I can't get on.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna lie guys like I I feel kind of cooked yeah
what can we do what can we do I feel like we should have
married captain America honestly is there back line okay
their back line's not that strong it's the front line that's
strong or
we get more final hits we just get more final hits working
of the more broken characters right now like he's just like
he's the most broken character tank right now okay that's
good to know okay guys we just need more final hits
oh no i don't i feel like maybe i should be on luna i don't
know i think we should not play neymor Look, I think those
characters are buns and ass.
Well, I mean, I was getting picks, so I don't think I felt
like I started to get more picks on Namor.
That's fine, right?
But the actual, like, you picking the hero, you could do so
much more on Elsa or Phoenix or anything else.
And Warren, you need to be on support.
If we want to fucking win this, we got to do something
drastic.
Warren, you're playing support.
We're going to fucking play Cap, and I'm going to play Emma,
okay?
Yeah, I just don't got time on support, but yeah, we can try
it.
Yeah, well, we'll figure it out.
And I'm all for comp things, but I'm going to tell you right
now, I don't think Hella was anywhere close to a problem.
I thought like when I went Namor, I started getting picks.
It was working.
When we do Hella Namor, it just, it doesn't do enough.
Like, those characters are OG characters, and they're just
not good enough right now.
They're just not.
Like, even though we're up by one, like, we're still losing
it.
Yes.
where did i'm playing cap where did fox go yeah i'm first
banning gambit are you playing cap or we're banning i'm
playing cap like 100 okay they weren't running i mean is
that everyone played out or we want to ban cap i mean what
is first banning cap oh yeah like we banned no no i think oh
no they're i think we play it i think you you play it's fine
i'll play him now we banned star lord from this match i'm
banning gambit okay they weren't they weren't playing gambit
they weren't on banning it either way can we can we can we
consider a starlord ban i feel like last series this series
is a problem for me i'm gonna save strange so you can go
back to strange like we wasted that ban they weren't what if
she doesn't want me to play gambit just tell me not to play
gambit i just thought we were running triple so i might as
well go gambit a little bit passive aggressive not gonna lie
yeah i think we banned starlord so we're not just gonna ran
down by the same comp just tell me gab it was a bad choice
short short
i think that was weird i think that was weird i don't think
i was the problem okay
i don't know i i think that was fucking weird i was just
they're like i'm gonna play i think i should play gambit she
could just said no what
about what about punisher why don't we put finisher and just
put output out there we just do some damage i'm down i'm
actually so down because i'm telling you guys we don't have
the output right now to break shield even after the cap pick
to actually get another point and cap they waste so much
time by the time we get to the point we they have 80 points
and then it's over yeah i'm down what do point sure sure bro
put me on punisher then i don't mind that okay just my
backline just play like like luna cloak and then we're gonna
play like the moon i shine in darkness i just think that was
a waste yes cloak is a dank year cloak right click it i
think that was such a waste of pressure i would have swapped
off Phoenix.
Which one do you want?
I just felt like I was just like...
You really wanted...
Torch is open.
Torch is OP this season.
No, what do you play?
What do you play?
I...
Like, it literally doesn't matter, like, Elsa, Phoenix,
Torch.
It's just what you think you're going to get value on.
Yo, X, I think your chat wants me to tell you not to play
Cap, but I don't think we should...
Yeah, but I was like, the only Cap player that was the next
season one.
Oh, you're different.
I actually think you're a goat on cap.
No, he's about to go crazy.
Cap used to be terrible, and I was very disappointed.
Put Snowflake on our cap.
And then X, just tell me when you're in, okay?
I'll be able to walk forward when you're in.
I basically just stand on my backline and make sure they
don't get run over.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
All right.
Our lock-in guys.
We got this.
Don't get your muted by the way.
Come left, come left, team.
Come left.
Left, left.
They're gonna engage on you guys, so be ready to back, okay?
Cap is in.
Cap two bar.
Walking up.
Train down point?
Yeah, I'm set up.
I have an angle.
Let me know when Cap's on you guys, okay?
Oh, Caps aren't sure for.
Okay, okay, turning cap, turning cap, turning cap.
Looking cap, looking cap.
Oh, I might be cooked, guys.
Oh, you're way too far up.
Yeah, I was taking an angle, not bad.
All good.
Bubble, bubble, bubble, bubble.
We're even, we're even, we're even.
Turn cap, turn cap, turn cap, turn cap.
Oh, I got hit, bud.
Punish the chair left.
Whoa.
They captured the mission area!
Come back.
I go tank pool here.
There's nothing for me to really shoot.
Okay, everyone, everyone walked left side together.
Our caps is going to go from right side, okay?
Everyone left side.
My supports need to stand in a doorway and literally like,
don't walk up unless you guys have walls.
And be ready to turn and peel this cap together, okay?
I'm going to walk through this doorway here.
I'm walking through.
I'm going to touch point, okay?
No, look at me.
Cap behind.
Walking up, walking up.
Halting cap.
Luna, no snowball.
We're turning cap.
turning gap right now i'm just being slow it's half hp
really low thank you thank you i need a bit of heals on
punishment okay i'm walking up again i'm gonna look where's
cap where's cap not there yet behind behind he's in he's in
i'm shielding him okay we're even help your help your
thankful help your team's cap behind us melting cap i'm
really close to my arm
I froze them.
Nice froze.
I'm trying to live so I can go back in with my all.
I'm ulti, I'm ulti, I'm ulti.
Nice, okay, I'm going in, I'm going in.
I'm going in.
I'm gonna die.
I'm bubbly.
Fuck.
That's okay.
We can still win.
I have one here.
I have no shield.
I have cap on me.
Okay, I'm turning.
I'm turning now.
Luna dead.
You have no heals.
You only have ultron.
Someone needs a snowball in the face.
Yeah, it's just you.
I'm dead.
They have Luno coming back, okay?
Morton, you can kill through Luno with Pani shotgun.
It's their side, it's their side.
Walking through, walking through.
Yeah, we're through, we're through.
I'm here, I'm here.
I'm shooting strange.
I'm on it.
Oh my god, you're all split.
I think fives might be off right now.
Oh.
How are we dying?
Fives are down.
What happened?
I think Cap is isolating people and then just clapping them
in the back line.
I try to pull out my shotgun towel, but he just gets out.
What do you know?
We play it?
Any squirrel girl.
Okay.
I think play, play, play, whatever you're good at.
I think we're doing better with that.
Okay.
You know what we can try?
We can try.
born on Punisher and then we stay together as a group of
three.
How's that?
I think I'm just gonna play Squirrel because what I'm comfy
on.
I'm not- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Play with, like, like, let's just go with vibes.
I mean, strategy didn't work.
Oh yeah, let's go with vibes.
Okay, okay.
I mean, I'm not getting, I'm not getting this war out now.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was just like, yeah, okay.
No, no troll.
I think I'm losing vibes because I'm trying to play
Punisher.
No, okay.
Yeah, we'll just play for that.
I'm gonna go left side, okay?
And make my own.
Yeah, play left room.
We play balled up together for now.
Let's try being completely balled up for a little bit Cap is
here, Cap is here Whole team here, whole team here They're
gonna fight early with an old Okay, my supports play back
Sports play safe Suncaps Suncaps Back back back back back
back Back back back back That's a bad joke, thanks I'm
trying to live, I'm trying to live, maybe we can trade it
after Okay Okay, nice, no one capped yet, so we're good
Alright
Let's do this They're mission area!
They have eye.
They're going to fly up an eye.
Okay.
I'm shooting.
Luna alone on the left.
I'm hit.
I got Luna.
Can't win.
I don't have you.
How does it not hit him?
I got two.
Nice picks.
They're cap ulting in the back one.
the face reset going yeah yeah yeah i'll have squirrels to
get out on the stairs they're gonna have mantis ultron cap
or did they cap what you guys they cat bolted okay mantis
ultron pun okay we should clip bolt first um yeah come on
cap i'm on cap i'm on cap i'm poking yep chilling I'm gonna
get it.
I'm okay.
I'm a point.
We have ult advantage here.
Sports are low in the back line.
1 HP, 1 HP, Luna.
I'm shooting cap.
I can't.
I froze cap.
Stun him again.
He's in.
Stunned.
96, 96, 96.
I'm gonna play back for it.
I have it here.
What do you get?
What's pop?
Nice.
Good job.
I'm walking up.
Now I'm walking up.
on the stairs behind us i'm back now i'm close to my out
okay i'm feeling it i'm feeling carry your death pool carry
double i'm trapping it i can go with my own really soon oh
my god weak i can go with my own after we have tp we have tp
i can't touch i'll sleep i'm asleep i'm trying to help oh
pun pun pun pun i have the keeper
They're not TPing.
NTO, NT.
NT, NT.
This is unplayable.
Doing that shot, guys.
Fuck.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
That was last map against this team?
Oh, too?
Yeah, that was the last map.
Why was that so unplayable?
It's just...
Yeah.
They had all-time Mantis triple support.
And triple support, yeah.
Like...
If I'm on Phoenix, they just sit in the back and I do Z DPS.
yeah then the captain america is just that's it like
anything i feel like i can't kill they get all their shields
back like cap wolf like it just it's weird meta i don't know
i don't know if it's meta but i feel like it's tough to kill
anything anytime they're low they're back to full instant
uh wait are we out out now i mean we're out out right yeah i
think we're out we still have We have a chance to be in it
if we have final hits.
We could have the biggest upset.
Just if we have most final hits.
That's like final blow?
Like you like final blows.
Final blows.
I don't know if we got that.
Whichever team has the most final blows, the teams that get
eliminated, they pick two teams to be in the next to be in
the day two.
Oh, interesting.
Okay, then let's go hard next game.
You can maybe still get off the final blow.
Yeah, I will say like, especially if we're playing against a
team comp like that, like it's very important to like know
like the in and out and i'm i'm calling it i just need to
say listen
i don't know
shout out work message i have to do real quick
all right
new lobby new lobby
Yeah, it's fucking weird that I was like, I don't know how
the frames are dropping like crazy there too.
Who are these people?
Vibes are a little off, guys.
It's just vibes.
I thought I'd move.
Are you guys in lobby right now?
Apparently US has a spidey player.
So I'd be down to go Namor.
It has an info.
No, they have it.
I'm gonna wait till the lobby turns out.
Play whatever you want.
Well, I could do, I could try the triple support.
Do you want me to do the Ultron?
Or would you rather rocket?
The time to do Ultron.
was like two games ago dude or play whatever you want let's
just let's just have fun for the last match well i'm down to
play for like final blows try to try to qualify off wild
card oh my god
uh i'm gonna play support next game just run triple solo
tank x
I just
think we could have talked.
I would have swapped if I was told to.
I don't need to.
We don't need to ban Gavin.
Hello.
How are the vibes?
Yo, vibes are chill.
Oh, the vibes are amazing.
guys thoughts on our more you playing flank dps luna oh
we're yeah i'm gonna play support next game for sure okay
i think vibes are very off now
which sucks because when vibes are off it affects me too.
Yeah.
She like left.
She was like, I peace out.
Like that should block anyway.
I don't even understand it.
What happens now?
We play and see if we could get final hits.
Yeah, see, I told you guys.
I told you, I was like, these teams are all really strong in
NA.
I was like, why is everyone saying Candace the strongest?
I was just like, see, I told you, guys.
No one believed me.
I was like, even my team was like, USA's the strongest.
I was like, I don't think USA's the strongest.
I think Brazil and United are really, really strong, like,
player-wise.
I think the coach gave up.
Oh, no.
Coach abandoned us midway.
No,
he didn't come back for the bad phase.
I was like, what happened?
He didn't even come back.
I was like, wait, where are we banning?
Where's the coach?
And then, and then ban.
And I was like, oh.
Yeah, coach literally went for milk and never, never came
back home.
He didn't even come.
He didn't even come for the ban.
He can.
He just never came back.
he actually yeah nothing at all
sure for i'm watching the fun i don't like what i'm seeing
what are you seeing sure i'm not i'm watching i'm watching
map one like uh-huh we kill one tank right we're trying to
get to the point like we need your damage onto the tank so
that we could get the point like i'm trying to nitpick every
situation but like we had to
like nobody is focusing tank like that that turns on the
point he's taking like negative damage you're right the
guy's taking negative like the guy's taking less damage than
i am and he's alone with no backup like i not not gonna lie
bro i feel like a moth to a flame whenever there's a cap
behind us i don't know how to just like ignore him to go
shoot like cap or like to go shoot strange like you said if
cap is in yeah we should be shooting cap And then once Cap
is out, it's our turn to play the game.
Which is why I was asking my backline, like, let me know
when Cap is in, because that means I have to, like, I don't
have to, like, go all the way back and shoot Cap.
I just have to play slow because I know you guys are going
to be looking at him, right?
And I'm not going to have help on the front line.
That's awkward because it just feels like he was always in.
Was there ever a time he was not in?
map map one map one stage one um hold on i'm not gonna give
you the exact time on this um at 35 on the other point like
basically at 5 14 okay the chat dies we're 5v6 we should be
walking under the point and clearing the points i'm looking
at the team we're like looking at fucking at gardens and
galaxies and what they're like their tank is not taking any
damage at all and the camp is not he can't be in he's dead
right what map is that x just map map one and gauge number
two at five minutes 10 seconds and ongoing celestial husk
yeah 5 10.
okay i'll try to look at cat more or not cat strange if they
have i'm
just vibing now I don't even know when we're playing.
We're just waiting on everyone.
I'm just going to play a quick play game.
Fuck it.
I can leave a quick play game.
I am playing a quick play game.
Maybe Trevor and I shouldn't have played the I.O.
for seven hours straight.
Maybe that was the problem.
I did practice a bit after.
I can leave a quick play game because I've never left a
quick play game.
Playing the aisle.
It was fun, though.
I had fun.
I just think, like, I need a reset there.
That through, that gambit band fucking threw me off.
So hard.
Maybe I can do both.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Oh, you look tough.
You look like you...
we have a cap?
I didn't even see we had a cap.
Where is he?
The one that's colored like America?
Was that the cap?
Well, we are in the right place for that.
Let's go.
The battle starts in time.
I didn't know.
It was bad.
I played really badly there too because of it.
Because it like threw me off.
Because I was like, what?
Why are you shooting me?
I didn't say anything.
I'm trying.
I swear I'm trying.
Guys, hello.
Are they ready or what?
No, they're not ready, but I wanted to come here to inspire
some malice in your hearts because Team US is about to lose,
and if they lose against us, they don't qualify.
Oh, snap.
But so do we not, though?
Yeah, but we can take it down with us.
Let's grab them by the leg and drag them in.
Is this like a crime and tally that thing or what?
Oh.
Huh?
Is this like a crime mentality?
Like, like, if I can't have it, you can't have it?
It's like, even if we lose, at least we're better than the
US.
You know, it's like that.
Even if we lose, we're better than the US.
Oh, yeah, okay, okay.
I thought it actually helped us to make it.
That's all good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's that type of shit.
I don't think we have more final blows in the US.
No, we don't.
Actually, it'll be a three-way tie if we win against US.
us because so i don't remember what the tiebreaker was final
oh no it's it um within the region it's based on the 1v1
between the tiebreakers yeah so i think
what happens only if uh brazil beats america united right
then we can possible then america united And then we just
need to get called by a final boss.
It's not over, guys.
There's a chance.
Right?
Why don't we just save Cyclops?
And just put Shurfer on Sai.
Shurfer, are you nice on Sai?
Yeah, he just threw that Sai.
I do feel like a lot of these teams have been banning Sai,
so protecting him, we feel like we're like demons on it.
Yeah, I mean, if it was Sai, he can final hit farm for us
true but they also final hit farms literally we just need a
final hit farmer that's it okay let's get in the lobby and
not lift it
vibes are vibes are so up right now guys not for me no they
are so up everybody is so happy sure for you get to shoot
your gun you're gonna be happy be able to shoot your gun i
love that he's honest before the aisle after and then you
babysit me in the aisle
i'm in i'm inviting you guys is it the other team in yet
yeah they are okay i don't have to be center stage Damn, M
.R.
United beat you guys.
I'm telling you, that team was beast, bro.
Like, I didn't want to even...
I thought it was first.
Shifor, could you leave the range so I could invite you?
Hi.
Yeah, I get an invite as well.
Alright, after this...
After we cap, I leave.
Oh, shit.
What's going on?
all right goodbye team goodbye because i can leave a game
yeah i can i knew i can't i don't know if i can request to
join a room i remember
all right hello yo yo yo sure for how warm is the thor bro
you want me to bring up the thor low-key yeah because if we
could i think our best chance to win guys is like you play
thor with exontank and then we play triple support backline
with armory on mantis sure thor oh my god i would love i
think that's the best chance that we have at winning like
we're not doing great in the front to back stuff right now
with group so it's like if we play put worn solo dps right
and then have you on tank and we can like damage boost you
with mantis and put dokey bird on like luna and then we can
play uh fan fan on like cloak or something i think then it
becomes hard for us to die to stuff and they're gonna play
like some dive stuff okay and we can't ban it all out i
think that's the best thing we have and like low-key thor's
pretty good and then this this that also lets me play like
gambit low-key if they leave it open yeah okay yeah someone
was saying it's hard to ban out j3 because you're just good
at every shooting character yeah we're i think we're just
gonna like target bank kingsman like low-key okay this team
will play wolves so i think we just
all right final hit farmer time
all right
just missing warn and x in lobby i invited both i'm in i'm
in yeah because like worst case scenario okay like yeah our
worst case scenario we end up on something like this and i
think we can play that because fan fan says she can also
play mantis so like that would be the worst case scenario
but i don't think they'll let that through so they've been
they've been banning this character a lot so i could switch
accounts yeah i like that too i like that too but the they
can't oh they don't okay uh-oh okay okay okay okay okay yeah
we don't lose this i am good dude i have so much faith in
sure for on thor bro I have so much faith in you, Lane.
Nah, nah, nah.
I'm just giggling right now.
Ah, yes, yes, dude.
No, fuck USA, bro.
Nah, nah.
We might be trash can, but we're not trash can often.
We will win this, trust me.
We will.
Storyline gets infinitely better if we win this.
I need that on my soundboard.
Now we're gonna win.
This is a good map for us, too.
Hell's Heaven's nice.
Okay, so if that's what you want, Aramori, I think this is
what we would do, then.
um
Who's egg rat?
That's emerald root.
I think that's what you do.
I think that's what the line looks like Okay, yo, you don't
want you don't want to ban rocket you really don't want to
ban rocket No, not really that's what they're running.
Yeah, but Thor eats that character up.
Okay.
Wait wait wait hold on
Oh they want an R Yeah, I said oh, yeah
All right, let's do this.
How's it is?
Damn, Lulu Lovely is in the servers, I repeat.
That last ban could be anything.
If you don't think it's a great idea, like there's a bunch
of other things that we could ban there.
We could do this, we could do this.
Like there's a bunch of last bans we could do there.
This USC uses...
Yeah, he does.
but like if it's if it's this triple then then not really he
can touch that but if it if it's like this okay okay we'll
just see what he gives us how you feel about the thor i'm
just letting i'm just letting them talk about bends i don't
need to give input it's a classic it's always it's always
classic oh no especially low key thor no high key thor rank
12 it's all cute no no the skin low keith yeah oh no i don't
think you want to be today too tough well i might have on
the other account but
we can call his wild card if we win this potentially okay i
think we freaking got this let's hand it to these usa frauds
okay you mean south canada oh yeah that's our new canadian
and gambit they're scared i would too don't keep birds got
aura on that character all right let's go reset reset reset
time did you say 11th who said how many problems are there
no no i said oh i didn't say i didn't say i didn't say no
We either become the newest state or they become the newest
province.
Wait, is it?
I thought there were 10 provinces.
Name them.
What are the 10 provinces?
Prove your Canadian.
Prove your Canadian geography check.
Yeah.
Prove your Canadian.
Name 10 provinces.
Fuck.
I'm tapping out.
Name them.
How many provinces can you name?
Wait, no.
I'm going off script but I think this is good I like I like
it good shout good shout or the better target band nice
they're nervous hold on X you can play mag right X is nice
on I can play mag a little bit a little bit of mag but not a
lot of mag no okay I mean it's just bad it's just not great
but yeah I like I like the protect I like the protect such a
good that's actually such a good counter to their first
protect oh bucky that's a great pivot uh-huh and i know what
i'm last banning too
did he play star at all yeah he does they played they played
a little bit of star they played a little bit of star could
be a good ban i'm in a man star i think dub dub dub cloaky
dagger they think you're a one trick fiona flat's always
vans cloak against I hate her.
All right, this is good.
This is good.
We got a good comp going.
Not bad.
Pick your hero.
Okay.
So we can go Thor Mag.
I think X.
Oh.
Yeah, I think you go Thor Mag.
I think X you play Mag because they're going to be on funny.
Right?
You want me on.
I think you play Squirrel Girl here, Worn.
Yeah, I think you go Squirrel Girl.
I think that's fine.
And then you can sue here.
Yeah, I think it's sue.
Are you sure you don't want to swap with me, Armory?
So you can do more on suit?
well if armory yeah let's do it let's do it let's do it well
armory if you're not gonna play mantis you should play fox
listen i saw some gameplay from uh their spider-man like
mantis absolutely right it's about a minute like you no no
no no no no go go see fiona i'm going mantis i'm gonna eat
them up yeah yeah i think armory on mantis is like big win
con all right guys good luck we win this team you say sucks
j3's bald cap is the most likely right because yeah we can't
let a bald is open yeah um x after first if depending on
what they're running if you want to go cap you can um and
like we'll have another support up but mac is just like
generally good into like the pond and everything yeah all
right final hit farming time let's go yeah we fight really
strong okay play together play together
Two left.
I might hit it in.
Is that Elsa?
Can we swing right?
Or wider?
Yeah, sure.
Let's go right.
I'm holding right already.
I'm right.
We're not.
I'm not Elsa.
I'm going back to me.
Help out.
Help X.
All right.
X got ground.
Well, we were just late on the first phase.
I'm playing swimming.
I try to heal you.
I think you go cap here really x oh my gosh this is a comp
we're rewriting the meta I need to give the snowflake to x
I'm gonna have alt first by the way yeah I can damage boost
we're playing for our scroll girl here let me know when
you're ready to go in can you Maybe X.
Yeah, he touched.
And collapse on their B line.
Okay, get ready guys.
Yep, I'm walking.
Let's go.
Ready, three, two, one.
Engage.
They're going to shoot.
Oh, okay.
It's done.
We good?
Elbex.
He's got pulled up.
He got pulled.
Flats is done.
ADMIO.
I'm just backing up.
I'm backing up.
Can you walk to us?
Something he can.
Point moving.
We're not really brawling.
I don't think that's going to work.
Yeah, I don't think...
I think...
Maybe Slash Trimmer off the store.
Yeah, I think I might have to, unfortunately.
Sorry about that.
I was muted, though.
All good.
Well, if we had a little bit more brawling going around, I
think it would be fine, but we're kind of getting choked out
of here.
Yeah.
I'm going to...
It's all about...
Final hits guys Get ready get ready get ready walk up three
two one get closer.
We need touch.
Let's go.
I will first I got hit.
We're it.
We're in Nice.
Okay, I'm gonna go.
I got touch.
I got that.
Don't worry about it.
Three, two, one miles over miles over.
Walk up walk up walk up.
I'm going to actually Oh, I might be dead to this.
Do you have shield?
No, not okay.
I'm feeling no I'm grabbed.
Do I...
No, I'm not even...
Don't worry, no, this scroll's on the way.
Just fodder.
No, he threw the bomb behind my shield.
My X's shield broke the moment.
Ball right.
I had like 150 and like it was...
It would have to be like perfect timing.
It's like impossible.
Yeah.
Superpowers are amazing.
Do they have support all?
The ice effects look great on us.
one right yeah they have one let's um I think we just took
them in just I'll walk up with with strange and we just
stand stand the bucket stand the abilities yeah I'm gonna be
ripping my all do it okay we can win this yeah for this
fight I'm gonna go Phoenix we got this triple DPS just shoot
them gonna speed us out
We can still turn this.
Do you want me to open with all?
Yeah, you can.
See if we can force a support wall.
I just need to be a bit closer.
Last time I threw it too far.
Watch a TP.
They might TP play.
Okay.
Here.
Oh, they're not.
They're main.
I see.
No, I'm with you.
Yeah, I'm top.
Just walk main.
Walk main.
I'll scroll when you guys walk up.
Yep.
I'm ready.
they popped it engage engage or look i can't see you i can't
see you there yeah five four three two one all right i'm
going back to my entrance i'm back in back in a little bit
that's rose i got hooked nice jump we're six oh my god no
we're no longer six doghook bro.
I don't think the Cyclops side does enough damage to this
right now.
Maybe.
Okay.
He's good spam though.
6 DPS.
I'm going right side.
That'll.
Oh, I'm got you.
JFOA.
What do we got?
Maybe.
Nothing yet.
I just got doghook.
Yeah.
I got hit by a
smile on my face war in my eyes
well time to go for some Hail Marys I guess I'm just gonna
off angle as hello here's the here's a snowflake thanks just
do your thing thank you at all you ready Well, it was at
least five.
We're good for five Let's come back.
We have one more fight.
Just four.
Yeah, yeah, one more.
Let's get a good entry at least now Go get hooked I'm I'm
feel feel I'm trying to pocket
Gonna again I think it's fine.
You're fine.
Nobody's all that matters is finals Yeah, we got zero
finals.
Yeah, we got zero finals finals guys um maybe there's like a
wild card for least amount of final blows we got we got zero
out of uh two how about two tanks yo boy playing tanks at
all dude i'll hop on dino i can run it down on the dino dino
run dino just just uh one walk up walk in there and do do
something smile on my face war in my eyes shit wait we all
gotta do something though if i do something we all got to do
something bro i've been waiting for you to do something all
tournament we all have to do something we all of us got zero
limbs
it's the curse
it's the curse it's
all right so our more is that it for for canada and
everything no more we have we have one more game We got it.
Who do we play?
Maps.
Oh, I thought that was it.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
We might have needed a little bit more brawly for the four
there.
We're kind of just getting pushed.
Yeah.
Sure.
He was just existing.
I don't know what to do for him.
But I'm...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now, who am I gonna banish this map?
Uh, if they first...
spam it i can't do anything to help you go where is magic
it's okay we can win one map you know if they don't spend
gambit we do have gambit so okay i'll save your group all
right we're cooking we're cooking we're cooking here i guess
i'm gonna become a us it's not over until it's over it's
literally not over yet
okay i should have saved your group last time cosmic favor
today you guys want to ban like Elsa or something just ban
all of his fucking characters or what does he play Elsa?
I don't even know what up I don't even think I'm going to
ban Bucky looking Bucky really hard I guess he was kind of
like against what we're going to play Bucky counters the
fuck out of us okay because we have no shield and then he
just hooks either me or him well Warren cannot get hooked
that character just can't get hooked Oh, yeah, oh, Dino?
Yeah, he's immune to CC.
I'm walking forward and I'm chomping on him, okay?
Yep.
Okay.
That's okay.
That's fine.
Not a lot.
I'm just chilling.
I don't know what else I can do.
I feel like the moment I look away, like, excuse me.
Are you going to be on DPS and horns on tank then?
It's going to be hit by 20 different things.
I'm going to band-aid you here.
honestly i don't know i looked away for one second and the
xqc fucking died we have dino group if my if wolf gets value
yeah because you because you and you and uh if you're you're
playing vps right yeah or villain i'm not judging we could
go like loki luna loki luna with like sure for on wolf and
you on like punisher or something or you want Elsa whatever
you I play Elsa Phoenix make sure for what do you what do
you want to play like do you want to play like I've been
trying to find the answers so I can find something in my
head the only thing that semi works so far is hella and
hoping I just get two quick headshots I think you looked
good on the wolves if they're not gonna play it you could
just go wolves and I can try it yeah if it Cyclops.
Yeah.
Cyclops.
Like, I know Cyclops is good because there's so much damage,
but it didn't seem like enough.
You could go punny then.
You could go punny.
I do like punny.
If we're going to be in the front of the back.
I don't think I should play Loki.
They're going to go Bucky.
Can we bend?
Oh, he's bent.
I adult tabs there.
All right.
I am.
Uh, X and Warren.
The way my character works is I have to like level up at the
start of the fight.
Okay.
Find and hide.
Yeah, just...
No, no, no.
We can play Agra.
Just be aware.
My damage is gonna be lesser at the start.
Oh yeah, it's like three kills before she's full.
I'm literally...
I don't have any range though.
I can't...
Okay, I'll take a little bit of damage, but just live.
I'm just chilling.
Oh my god, you're already eating slowly.
They have turret.
We have to break the turret.
How do I break it?
Care, care, care, X, X.
Oh my god.
I already...
I had to use the...
Well, let me know when everyone's ready for a kidnap.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll jump.
We have to walk.
We have to walk now.
I'm looking for one.
Get ready in.
Three, two, one.
I'm going in, bro.
I'm with you.
Get him, get him.
You are so low.
Oh, my God.
I'm clapping.
I do not have.
I don't have.
I tried to jump the wall.
What they had is crazy.
I already have in Vaughn.
Oh, they also have in this woman.
Oh, wait.
No, Dino.
Dino, no, Dino.
No.
No, I don't want to go Punisher into Magneto.
I don't want to go.
You can do me play lives, play lives, play lives.
I'm going to go Phoenix.
I'm going to go Hawkeye and hope for random headshots at
this point.
Let's do this.
Yeah, let's go.
Fuck it.
Final hits, guys.
Time to vanish.
Are we out of the spawn yet?
What are we doing?
Push up.
I'm doing Moxie.
I'm doing Moxie roleplay right now.
I like that.
We just push up.
There you go.
Moxie replaced Plank.
We've just been this the whole fucking time, I guess.
I don't fucking know, man.
Give me two moments.
I need Karen on the right.
I have one for two.
Emma's dead.
I got in.
I'm trying to clap.
I'm clapping.
That's up to you.
Favette almost has a hold.
I'm holding.
Page Three is one.
He's won.
He's won again.
Oh, snap.
Take a match.
Get on point.
I have a cap.
We have cap.
I'm here, I'm here.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
They're low on the B line.
I'm going back line.
I made the fall back with my ult.
I got one.
Final hits!
You're actually different right now on Hawkeye.
Yeah, just keep getting finals!
I'm working on it.
I've been working on it this whole time, man.
We can ask them if they can give us finals.
Yeah.
Punisher.
We have coffee here.
We coffee.
Walk up, walk up, walk up.
Walk up, walk up.
No turret, by the way.
No turret.
They're gonna have emerald after this.
All right, do we?
Oh, goodbye.
I'm not at all, I'm not at all.
I couldn't do anything.
Looking at it.
It's okay.
No, no, that's gonna fail!
That is good.
I don't think it's right.
It got blocked.
Get the finals, sure for it.
Get that final.
Here, here's an emerald.
We need work on it.
I'm telling him, work on it, man.
We need more.
Dude, it's literally just, I'm playing slots right now.
I'm just shooting arrows and I'm hoping one hit the head.
I'm looking for the 777s.
It's working though.
Every time you get a final hit, you gambled correctly.
You let it ride.
We might have to go back side.
Don't set too much damage.
Okay.
Following Kat.
He might be a second take.
No, no, no.
That Dino was hurting.
I have a ult again really soon.
I can't do anything.
I'm not being a smelted.
I'm going to flank him.
I'm with you.
I can TP back.
I'm healing you so quickly.
Where are you?
Oh my god.
Right here.
Yeah, we have the TP.
We're in TP.
They know you're in here.
We have Hawkeye all.
Help our strange.
I'm bloody blocking with my clones.
Don't let him cancel.
I'm trying my best to body block.
Can we dodge?
Let's do this.
Let's get him.
I'm cutting him.
I got a final hit, guys.
I got a final hit.
I'm dead.
You got final though.
You got a final.
Yeah, I think they got more finals than us though.
It's a problem.
You got five finals.
Yeah, but they need two teams.
Maybe you should have been hot guy this whole time.
Maybe you should have been hot guy this entire time.
Sure, for you've been noting all tournament men.
You've been getting your picks.
I'm not playing strength.
I'm not going to play Ruggiton to play cap.
If you wish.
Play cap.
That's fun outside of.
I agree with that.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Really deep pressure is pretty good.
Fine.
I'll go tank pool.
My my support just left to like flee for themselves and just
try and live and not get shot across the map and then Wait,
are they playing support or do just more things?
What are they playing?
They're just playing 222, yeah I like rocket I choose to
side with those who would benefit my kingdom most Be careful
The battle starts in five Four, three, two, one All right,
I'm my old All you need to do is capture the mission area
got it once we get this timeline thing sorted out i'm taking
a long vacation somewhere with lots of stuff we got this god
speed watch elsa here okay yeah you hit from come on i don't
know how to play this map it's been a long time since we
play this map yeah where am i supposed to go yo long point
uh one one hp uh i don't know who that
Ping.
Oh my.
What's that?
Oh, Emma.
I need Luno.
I'm fine.
I need us to walk up.
Just walk up and be ready to Luno.
I'm in here.
Watch the Elsa.
I need her.
Yeah, Elsa's gonna...
Three, two.
I got Emma.
Nice, nice, nice.
Final hit.
I'm close to my old, okay?
Play for my old.
Mag, no bubble.
Look at Mag.
Good.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh my God.
Not over yet.
It's not over yet.
Oh my god!
We did it!
FAM, we did it!
Oh, don't!
Overconfidence is so bad!
I can, I can, I can, I can.
I am all here.
I have both though!
I'm getting smashed!
Emma one?
I'm hand.
I'm hand, I'm clapping, clapping, clapping!
I'm clapping, clapping!
Yo yo yo yo!
You have emus!
Aways!
I don't get that close though.
Look!
Can someone scratch my back?
I am ready to it's okay.
We forced we forced we forced that's good.
That's good.
I don't know why no why they did that They really won final
hits too.
I guess My bad.
I was about good early.
Yeah, yeah.
They really won final hits
They're gonna have ammo.
Yeah, I'm gonna go under I got whale though if you want to
walk in on whale I'm going under and touching point.
I'm going under and touching point Can we walk in this ship
it far?
No, I'm on it.
Give me life.
Give me life We're keeping you alive.
We're keeping you alive.
You have double supports.
We kill him.
Nice.
Okay, you get raised.
I'm frozen.
Okay, maybe.
Yeah, you get raised.
We forced all.
It's okay.
I have two people on me.
I have two people on me, so you're fine.
Two people were literally chasing me in spawn.
Who are you looking at?
I'm on you're nice.
On Neymar, nice.
Mike pushing our back line if we can turn from that'd be
huge.
He's on me, he's on me, he's on me.
We stop pointing.
Yeah, yeah, we stop pointing.
Go next, go next.
I have to reload.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I have to reload there.
Um, they're not gonna let us flip point like that again.
I think we just place them.
anyway, I'm doing Emma now.
OK, OK.
I'm going Cup.
Watch the Elsa hold here, ok?
I'm gonna let you heal.
They back up, they back up.
We can walk.
It's tough.
It's safe.
She's looking for the Elsa ultimatum.
Yeah, I'm looking at her.
We're playing for Luna.
Oh, I'm in it!
I'm in it, I'm in it.
Oh, I didn't have Rose.
Wait, can we trade Elsa?
She's pretty deep right now.
Yeah, I'm looking good at her.
She's good, okay.
Oh, we're only down one.
Maybe we could kill Emma.
Come at me, on me, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
Wait, wait.
I just got res.
Yeah.
I will.
My logos aren't working.
I'm fucked.
I'm done.
We're grouping?
I may have all here.
You want to use it.
Wait, I'm not there.
We have time.
Nice.
I'm walking up.
All right.
Hold on.
Can you live?
Fine.
I'm walking up now.
Be right.
Okay.
We need to help X.
It's fine.
My health got destroyed anyway.
Go, uh, flag low, Magidot, Mag, Mag, Mag.
I need heals on point when I'm dropping into your alt.
Oh.
All right, I guess me portal.
Oh, never mind.
Me no portal.
Oh, I'm blocking.
We got strange alt on the way back and maybe Hawkeye can TP.
Man.
Oh, I'm still one.
I'm dead.
Uh, just touching.
Okay, I guess I'm on.
I got one.
I'm almost at whale, almost whale.
Most supports are huge.
Oh my god, the finals!
I don't want to use my own.
The finals!
I don't know how they just let that happen, but...
You have no tanks right now, we're coming.
Dude, your character literally auto-aim one-taps people in
your ult.
Yeah, but they just have to hide around a corner for a
millisecond.
Oh my god, look at the finals you're getting, sure, for it.
Yo, X, you don't think you could get your ult, right?
This time?
No, not time.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna look for whale.
collapse on it if we're gonna win this it has to be early
whale okay okay i'm i'm ready i'm ready is everybody on us
oh they know they know i'm here i'm getting marked i'm
hiding i'm waiting for whale when they walk up get ready oh
they know they know they know okay i'm trying to bite i'm
trying to back i'm a whale i'm gonna whale the point i'm
gonna whale point okay okay i'm going behind okay i'm gonna
whale this right is that good go on the ground i have no res
no res right now no res oh no i have to reposition it Bring
him over time.
Uh oh.
Finals.
We're even?
I'm first little.
Keep me up.
We're trying.
Fuck.
I don't think I can touch.
I'm on I'm on.
X-gging on.
We're trying.
Keep it up.
Too close.
I'm dead.
I'm on it.
I'm on it, I'm on it.
So cute guys.
That was the closest we ever got.
I really was.
I condemned Lato enough.
You did fucking crazy on Hawkeye though.
It's difficult.
We should have put him on Hawkeye the entire time.
Yeah, Ro was him on that.
Oh, GG's there.
GG's.
GG's guys.
Sorry, there are levels to this.
I was not there.
My apologies.
All good, all good.
Thanks for letting me join guys.
I appreciate that.
You guys are awesome.
Next World Cup.
Thank you for taking the time out of there.
Come back.
Oh, yeah.
This has been great.
All right.
Goodbye, goodbye.
Nice to meet you all.
Goodbye.
Nice to meet you.
Good to you guys.
Take care of Team Canada.
Take care.
Bye-bye.
All right.
I don't know what to do now.
At least the last match was pretty vibey.
At least...
I don't think...
Guys, I don't think we're ever going to see each other ever
again.
And then we never see each other again, guys.
Probably.
Everyone just...
Everyone never met up.
This is the last we all saw each other.
Morale, now Trevor was like, I got it.
I'm fucking leave by.
It's like, bye.
I'm debating if I should play more ring.
My yellow carpet.
I got eternity, but the exchange is I lose my game.
My tournament games.
no i'm not it's just it's x that's still there oh my god x
literally went to us's channel you can see it i mean put
that up i don't it's like do i want to keep do i want to
keep going uh no shiver said he's not gonna play isle he's
gonna Go home.
He's- I mean, he's not going.
He's gonna stop.
He's gonna get up.
I could play one game
I will sit I don't know I don't even know if I did my job at
that point.
I don't even know I don't even know I I knew I was just like
when when uh during the game i was like when when teams were
announced i was like we don't really have a second tank
player i was just like hmm
yeah we were not in sync that uh it's all right guys i don't
even think we got guys
I don't think we're gonna get the final hits, guys.
Guys, I'm having a feeling we might not get, we might not
get the final hits, guys.
Just a little bit of, you know, just a little bit of a
little, little,
I don't know.
I'm having a slight feeling that we don't make it via the
final hits category.
Just an inkling.
That's why people were like, well, kind of as strong as I
was just like, I don't think so yet.
I did not think we're the strongest.
I don't even think Shroud...
Shroud dodged a bullet.
I don't think Shroud would have been happy.
Shroud was supposed to be on this team, but he couldn't make
it on the day...
the day of the announcement.
It was really funny because they posted the announcement
where it was supposed to be...
It was supposed to be Shroud.
They posted Shroud's announcement, and then they deleted it.
They...
They deleted it, like, in, like, a couple of minutes.
And then...
And then, uh, posted the new one after it.
Which I thought was pretty funny.
That is, like...
Um...
Go on the Ningo Super Chat, they could thank you.
I still can't believe they leaked the room.
I didn't realize he looked at it.
I didn't realize he looked at it, uh, on stream when he was
like, oh, the disc is on it.
I was, like, so confused.
So I was just like, and then, and then, you know, obviously
that happened, and then I was just like, oh, you know?
I was just like, oh, shit.
edit it?
I think?
I think so?
I'm sorry.
I got a funny message.
I don't know.
I don't know if I have to delete.
I don't have to edit or delete the VOD or anything.
I don't know.
Because, like, I've had that happen before, and I just maybe
I should censor it, but the worst part is just Wait, we can
watch Canada versus South Africa!
Yeah!
Woo!
Let's go.
And then I get to watch Canada lose again!
Let's go!
I can't watch.
I can't watch Canada lose again!
That's my favorite part.
losers.
No, I'm joking.
I'm joking.
They have potential to win only because it's only because
like apparently we're subbing in one of our better strikers
who was on the bench because he was recovering from a broken
leg or something.
Not broken leg, but from a surgery or some shit.
I don't know.
There's a chance.
They're apparently subbing in a really good player they're
not even playing Canada that's the worst part they're
playing oh yeah tickets are apparently so cheap it's like if
you guys for those who don't know a lot of people are
selling their tickets to the Switzerland games because like
obviously all the Canadians bought the Switzerland games.
I mean, like, watch the games because they thought that um
uh
sorry, I'm just I'm getting, like, lots of messages so the
real you're right, you're right, so the real team Canada can
win the World Cup.
You're so right.
You're you're so right.
It's okay, we got the losses out of the way now.
So, so I'm Sunday.
So on Sunday, we can actually win the real game.
Alright.
We all know it's the Warren Doki curse.
Warren and I cannot be on the same team.
Warren and I can never be on the same team.
It's like the Doki Gale curse.
It's the Doki Gale curse all over again.
Gail and I are both okay uh players oh well he's a really
good player and I'm an okay player but like the moment they
split us up we started winning tournaments for those who
don't know um at first um at first it was like every time we
got people kept putting us two together in all the rival
team tournaments and then we all we kept getting eliminated
first or just like Early and then a moment like we finally
got a tournament where me and gail were never on the we're
not on the same team I think like gel got first and I got
like third like
All right, all right.
All right.
Let's see Oh my gosh.
He's still flaming silky still See it he's still flaming
silky you gotta get that engagement bait guys Oh yeah,
Shreveur and I also have a curse.
It's fun playing with Shreveur, but only in rivals.
If it was any other, I forgot, Shreveur and I, we also have
a curse together.
But it's only in rivals.
If it's in any other tournament, like we do okay.
Like we do all right together.
But like we have a curse when it comes to rivals.
In Apex, we've done well together in Apex, yeah.
Like, I've had tournaments for sure for it, and every other
tournament, we've done okay.
Like, we've done alright.
Like, decent.
But, like, it's not sure for an eye anti-chemistry.
It's just somehow in the tournaments that we have, it's
just...
It's just rivals, too.
Like...
It's just rival...
Oh, I'm not doing the Apex tournament because they thought
it was gold, and...
It's weird the format is so fucking weird.
It's like two gold players It's two gold players and a pro
and I was like I'm not they're like do you want the pro
slot?
I was like there's no way in fucking hell.
I'm taking a pro slot.
I'm taking a pro slot when When obviously I have to I have
to like try and help my gold players because it's a huge
disadvantage Because I don't play the game as often Yeah so
i was just like i'm not gonna do that you know like that'd
be like so fucking rough on me
yeah so i was like because and i told i told the organizers
too i was like you're gonna have a really rough time finding
two gold players like because because like the last
tournament it was like um oh two like you can be above gold
just never hit because they were trying to do gold player
they're trying to do one gold player and then they were
struggling finding gold players so they were like okay you
don't have to be gold but you just can't touch masters at
all like like you you can you just have to have been like uh
within the last uh yeah it's just like you just have to have
never touched masters they literally changed because they
couldn't find enough gold players but this tournament
they're like we want two gold players per team and i was
just like Bro, good luck finding two gold players.
This game's been out for seven years.
Like, all the content creators are above gold, at least.
If you want, like, gold, someone who's, like, never been
gold, ever.
Yeah.
Yeah, no content creator.
Like, never been gold, ever.
That plays FPS games.
Yeah.
Because, like, I was like, two?
And I told him, I was just like, bro, it's going to be so
hard fighting two fucking gold players who've never been
above gold ever in the last seven years.
Yeah, they have to get, like, actual new, new players for
that.
Because it's, like, one pro slash apex content creator and
two gold gold.
Yeah.
But I said, like, obviously, because, like, I didn't fit the
criteria.
So they're like, oh, shit.
Okay.
well ggs yeah
yeah i don't know i should i really do want to play more
rink but i really don't want to solo wait i'll ask
all right i asked i want to at least get a win today in my
heart
i'm i'm asking i don't know i i uh i add oh there you go
let's go Let's fucking go.
I got Madara.
We never end with a...
We don't end with a loss, guys.
Let's fucking go.
Hey!
Wait.
We...
Wait, what's this?
We are the same.
We...
I want someone else to feel like...
If I bring him down...
with me you
and uh we're the same we can both be losers together
that's so bad misery loves company guys as long as other
people are equally as That's all that matters.
Yeah, he got knocked out in his tournament.
In his professional tournament.
I got knocked out in the World Cup.
I just think we just needed another tank player.
That's all.
Honestly, if we had another tank player, I think it would
have been easier.
Generally, it would have been a lot easier.
No, we had our tank player.
We could run triple support.
And then, because that was the original plan sort of way.
But then, like, we just didn't really have a second tank
player.
And then, when he was like, please stay squirrel girl.
And I was like, bro, these teams would love it if you play
Squirrel Girl.
You don't understand.
I'm just like, I'm like, bro, this is not like the other
creator term as you did where there's a lot of very weak
players.
No, there's actual, like these players are really, really
fucking good.
And they would love it if you play Squirrel Girl.
Because Squirrel Girl is a noob stomper.
But like, there were not a lot of noobs in the America
region.
We're not protecting Squirrel Girl, bro.
We're not...
We don't need to protect Squirrel Girl, bro.
We don't...
Take the cookie would have won those matches.
Look at the Super Chat, Marty.
Thank you.
It just...
I don't know.
I don't even know if...
I don't know if I did poorly.
I know I've, like, fucked up, like, a bit in some ways.
But, like, I don't know if I...
I feel like I could have played better, but I don't know if
I did play the best of my abilities if it would have changed
anything.
No, I literally said that.
Nobody's batting Squirrel Girl.
I literally, I said that in our chat.
I was like, bro, nobody's going to bat Squirrel Girl, bro.
Like, I was going to...
I even said that in our team chat.
I just knew that what...
I just know that one time where I my vibe like it threw me
off was was when was the gambit bed That was the time where
I was playing really badly.
I knew because it like threw me the fuck off like because I
was not It just fucked with my vibes Because like team
started getting angry Yeah, like team got started getting
angry and I was just like Um, communication would be nice.
And then I just didn't really want to play after that.
That was the one time where I felt like I definitely played
really, really badly.
I, yeah.
Oh, no, Rocket.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Alright, well.
Life energy is a powerful...
Oh.
Oh, what of Miko Ultron.
I feel like I'm better on Mantis still.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
But...
I couldn't concentrate after that ban.
It was hard to reset myself because it was like...
The way it was...
I guess the way it was like...
Communicated.
Felt really harsh.
So I couldn't reset myself in time for that game.
Because I've had time to reset myself.
That's fine, but we were like bad and then we go in.
Yeah I wasn't like tilted it just that my vibes were just
off there Yeah So I didn't have time to fully reset myself
there so that I will say that map was on me because I was
missing everything I wasn't hitting my shots correctly and
stuff The battle starts in five
yeah it just threw me off really bad because i was just like
what like like what did i do you know i didn't think i
i would say i wasn't building maybe i wasn't building my alt
in top enough but it was so hard to build my alt too because
i always have to like look back
i don't know maybe i should have just ignored the star Lord
more.
It is what it is.
What the fuck?
Simple geometry.
We should have pushed her for on Hawkeye though earlier.
We were trying to find the perfect character for him for
final hits.
We were like, is this the final hit character?
I think that's like...
Yeah, let's go!
I was scared.
I thought he was gonna die.
That's fine.
Is it fine?
I think it's fine.
They have so many stuff now.
Let's hope they have...
Oh, we don't have all...
Oh my god.
Oh... It's okay.
I got point though.
It's clear I'm still needed here.
We practiced literally.
We only did like three quick play games together.
I think four?
Four quick play games together before the tournament.
Thanks for the boost.
Oh.
I didn't get out of that!
Oh my gosh.
I didn't remember the range.
Oh, it's rush.
That was my bad.
I fucked up there.
I thought I was around the corner in time.
Also, the fact that Shrevearn, I played the Isle.
Yes, I know.
I played the...
I played Rivals after, though.
I literally stayed up to play Rivals.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to save him right now.
You're welcome.
You're welcome, Luna.
Oh, no, no, no, I'm trying to save you.
I played, I like, one matured my team's, though.
When I played the rival is after, oh, we didn't touch point.
We did not touch point.
I love.
Oh, she has up too.
Oh, we're so dead.
Oh my god, the tree is still behind us.
Oh, the tree is still behind us.
I'm sorry, but now you're so fucked.
You're so fucked.
Oh my god, I'm alive.
Guys, my little puny bullets do not do nothing on the trees.
Oh my god, nice.
The tree is still there!
Don't know you know it!
Oh my god, I'm just gonna use this to hear.
Is there?
Is there a chance to stop them?
There's still a chance!
I'm like, is there?
Is there a chance though?
No, there is no chance.
Might not be another chance.
chance it's all right it's no longer okay wait maybe I can I
can save you don't worry I leave you now though oh no that's
angry I think he's hung it's just our Luna is like hard
DPSing so I need to focus on
oh my god oh goodbye i don't want to be in there i really
don't want to be there oh this is why i don't want to be in
there this is why i didn't want to be here don't worry i'm
doing my best oh my god
that's a lot of damage guys that's a lot oh well i'm sorry i
did not see you behind me
him that was a lot of damage guys we might need more we
might need more damage oh my it might be a lot of damage
tonight might not be the day oh no I went back to save him
and I should have left you to die.
I should.
I saw I need healing.
I was like, okay, let me go into the corner.
Why?
Why did I love helping people?
I need to see that.
I'll be right back.
I died.
There it is.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
I'm not the type.
who fades quietly into the background.
Yo, Meksan, can you go Starlord so that ABG fiend can go
Cyclops?
Round two, go!
All right, I'm back.
That's good, you need to shoot the walls.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready!
Cosmic rays didn't make me who I am today.
All right.
My family did.
It must be hard fighting to protect a world that hates and
fears you.
All right.
Oh, is our Luna flanking?
Here we go.
They want us to make mistakes.
When we do, everyone is watching.
Do you think we're getting really good?
You cannot save each yourself.
Four, three, two, one.
I mean, that's fine.
I'll go Capra.
Give me a snowflake.
Alright.
I'm gonna give me snowflake.
So many people are messaging me.
I'm so popular.
Try raising two Super Bowl kids.
Okay, I'm not gonna go Capra.
Okay, I'm just gonna play for her.
Feeling fantastic.
it's okay guys it's okay losing this is not as bad as losing
a World Cup in the end losing this will never be as bad
it'll never be as bad
true words and this This is nothing to me now.
Losing Kilo does nothing to me.
I'm as low.
Am I solo healing?
Oh, yeah, I am.
I am.
Ground, ground, ground, ground.
That makes more sense.
I was just like, huh?
Feel like...
I feel like I'm...
Oh yeah, 100%.
It's...
Nothing hurts me no more.
Nothing hurts me anymore.
We can cage them with Invis.
They won't have yet.
Push the cart, push the cart.
Don't die up front.
Oh my god.
He's coming.
Is that my...
Marvel Rivals and Night Pro players.
Oh, never mind.
Fuck it or Star.
Don't worry, you're so safe.
Groot, Groot, Groot, Groot.
On the left, on the left.
Someone's over here.
Elsa, Elsa.
Oh my god, try my best.
Yo, hold me on.
Okay, no, it's fine.
Oh my god.
There, there, I'm front back!
I'm front back!
I'm literally front backing!
The thing is, I couldn't even use my all anyway.
because it was just...
Alright.
Hello.
We're alive.
You know, I don't have to worry about double support
because, like, literally, he doesn't have anything.
Oh my god.
Front back!
Get out of here!
Ah!
Not me!
Get out of here!
And then it hits me and sit all right there you go here so
easily maybe yeah bro can you just give the flag to our cap
so we have the same oh we we don't have a cap and i've been
healing because this guy is making us play 5v6 because he's
bitching about my playstyle why would you play flanked in a
one way or two it's a good playstyle that's the main
playstyle i play very good in slash jump It just plays down.
You said what?
That's a very good and plus joke.
You're against two really good DPSs.
I mean, I've gotten...
I've gotten to the top 50 on the leaderboard doing this, and
one of them all.
I believe it.
Anyone can do that.
Power team homeless on the one's shop and only Punisher.
In the end, it'll never be as bad as what happened in World
Cup, because at least this is funny.
It just becomes increasingly difficult with people like
silly 845.
At least...
At least this is funny.
Funny toxicity.
It's not sad.
You know, I'm fine with this because this is funny.
Not not sad.
Oh no, not again.
Not again.
No, not again.
Yeah, the other one was just...
Was a little sad.
And awkward.
Oh my god.
That was part.
We should be able to kill him, right?
Yeah, there we go.
Not me.
We're up to the fourth.
I swear, yeah, there is.
I can only walk out.
Kirk got behind.
All right, there you go.
You're alive.
I am ready to put on a show.
Shoot the Luna, shoot the Luna, shoot the Luna, shoot the
Luna, shoot the Luna, shoot the Luna.
We're shooting the Luna.
I don't know where he is, but I think I'm shooting him.
Oh, no.
I'm just assuming I'm shooting him.
He said shoot the Luna, and I was like, that's Luna, right?
No big wall.
Get the
fuck off me!
Oh my god.
Okay, we do have a silly guy, though, on our team, and he's
pretty silly.
We do have a silly guy here.
We do have a...
GG, good job.
It was a Sasmuch.
It's very heavy.
Was it a little silly?
I got P, though.
I'll be right back.
Me P. Guys, BRB.
I'm back.
More typing.
Duck, Minler, Anne, Smug, Rice, Papa, Solid, Forward, Medi.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
All right.
LaCone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Who am I going to type, type, type?
Did XQC calm down?
I don't know.
I mean, we could check.
Is he still... I feel like that's really smart because now
people are going to remember this over the rivals
tournament.
People, people remember the XQC versus Soki over the, um,
um, over the, the overall rivals tournament.
Like that's just gonna be on livestream, fellas.
Hello, Kitty.
There was a tournament?
Yeah, it's just- Hey, baby.
How do you know?
I'll wait for sure to do what was in the lobby.
Please ban this, please hate this guy.
Please.
Hey, but people are gonna remember it though.
Holy mox win.
The right heroes can make all the difference.
I just end this.
Quietly into the background.
Is he still?
I'm pretty sure he left the VC.
Round one.
Even when you can't see me, I'll still make you believe.
He'll be coming in 30 seconds.
uh silky he's a really well-known uh rl streamer right i
don't keep up with like fleshy streamers to be fair i
promise to stick to my
the battle starts in five four three two one you have to
stop them from securing the mission venom white fox fork the
elsa Did you go in top left?
I'll mark.
There we go.
Did I just broke my shield?
No, I did.
Get away from me!
Oh my god, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Yes, I didn't get you.
Okay, I'm swapping.
I'm swapping.
Oh wow, he's 1v9.
All right.
I think we just got it wrong.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
This also is running it.
We can kill him, maybe.
There we go.
We're down to support.
Try to stop spawns.
Alright.
We all casually walk away.
Oh my god, please stop- No!
I couldn't get out!
Back up, we gotta stop staggering.
I tried to TP!
I'm getting over here.
Oh shit, all right.
That's awkward.
Oh my god, I can't do anything.
It's just full dive.
Oh, hang on another fucking thing.
There's still a chance to stop them.
Too much dive!
We can touch them last.
That shouldn't have wasted that.
Not me.
Hit one.
Can we race?
Not me.
I'm peeling.
You touch.
Look at DD.
Look at DD on the left.
I'm straight.
No, we all went to peel.
Why did we all peel?
This is a mess.
Guys, this might be a mess.
Leave one of us to die.
I don't care.
Just leave me.
Me to die!
Needed a little boost.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Burn, burn, burn, burn.
I
hope I live.
Burn the pox.
Run inside and move tab if you want.
That's the most I needed.
I got cancelled.
Oh my god.
Burn, burn, burn, burn.
I hope I live.
Let's walk.
Miles down.
I'm playing on cart, look at the whole...
But...
I'm a little worried.
Look at the LC move.
Sure.
I'm backing up.
I'm just making sure.
Oh, whoa, okay.
Oh shit, I didn't really I realized our captain was going to
do it next.
Front Hulk, front Hulk, front Hulk.
I thought it was me next.
If you, if the fox doesn't have it, only if the fox doesn't
need it.
Hey, what do you say?
Didn't you?
Yeah, I don't think.
You need a care assault.
That's what's not right.
You can't be looking for fun.
I hear him.
I hear on the hunt.
Venom plan, Venom plan.
Oh my god, I didn't hear that though!
I can ult at the end of this.
We have no DBS, we can walk.
I was like, I didn't hear that!
Venom purple.
And Luna, Luna, Luna.
Follow your tanks.
Thank you.
That's the post I need.
Oh my god.
What's up?
Hello.
All right, that's five.
That's five.
I can hold it in the right.
It's five.
Paragon diamond.
I'm a one, I'm a one, I'm a one.
Jesus Christ!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I don't believe.
Oh my gosh.
Like a fox.
Burn it, burn it, burn it.
It's a bird.
I can't tell
I'm grabbed but it's okay I'm grabbed my son, but it's okay
Oh, it's no longer okay.
It's no longer okay It's no longer
Yeah, I was like, it's okay.
It's no longer okay.
We can push in with Starlight right here.
Going in three, two, one.
Oh my god.
I haven't played eternity games for so fucking long.
Grab my heel spear.
My heel circle.
Don't worry, just get in my heel circle.
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Heel circle, heel circle, heel circle.
Ball clicking on that.
Yeah.
Look at Phoenix, Phoenix, Phoenix, Phoenix.
Oh my god.
Carry over, carry over, carry over, carry over.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I saw them.
Can we burn Hawk?
He's half, he's half, burn Hawk.
Burn Hulk behind.
He's so low.
He's low.
I'm putting circle!
Get into my circle!
Okay.
Okay, okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It's...
Oh my god, kick up the air.
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
He wasn't trying to even grab me!
But did nobody body block me?
Why did no one body block me?
me is my fault i haven't played the training games and so i
don't have to touch two seconds like i just usually just get
to turning and call it there i'm on you can go you go that's
my bet this is my bet i'm literally like
i'm exalt sound sound sound sound i am on oh i'm we did it
all right not even close honestly not even close so hard not
even fucking close guys not not that scared oh I remember
that don't remember that that you were my it's alright your
inspiration was a was a person leaving voice chat all right
I don't know if that's a good inspiration but i'll take it
no bro i was just so here you go wasn't even worried at all
like i said after today's world cup nothing matters to me
you want me to throw your first life on wall
after after that nothing matters i swear it's so bad come on
come on i also you can't look how to spawn with me on In
your hands, by the way.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Take me on your hands.
We can't walk up the spawn together.
There's a bug.
Yeah, I won't let you go out the door.
You have to grab my back.
Yeah, it's a bug.
Yeah, I'm throwing your head first into this lamp.
All right, here we go.
Nothing you get through my skin anymore.
I also don't really care.
Like, like, you know, yeah, it sucks to lose tournaments,
but like, I've done so many of these that I don't even care
anymore.
Like, everyone loses.
I've won tournaments.
I've lost tournaments.
I've placed decently in tournaments.
Like, it does.
I get free money.
I could get more free money.
Yes, I could.
But that's not on me if we don't get more free money.
I will say that.
I don't think it's on me if I don't get more free money.
Yeah, it's gonna be great.
Yeah, there you go.
I make portal for me.
Oh, oh no.
They have a grab.
They have a DD on a portal.
Just care.
I'll get back to them.
There you go.
That's five.
I missed this.
I'm going to need help with DD.
Don't land.
Hold behind.
I'm back behind.
Hold on.
No bubble.
Hold on up the point.
Nice.
There we go.
Yeah, it ain't worth getting mad.
It's a team game.
I might have fucked up some stuff, but I don't think I was
like the biggest issue there.
Like sure, we could have had a, I could have been a better
support player, but I don't think like...
I fucked up too many times to make it bad.
I can go on backline.
I can taste it.
Is it?
I don't, this guy's been chasing me the entire game.
Is that, I fucking hate my gun.
I'm just holding my gun.
Who's still fighting the ground?
That's fine.
Got another ground.
I'm gonna.
Oh, it's fine.
Oh, it's not you.
Not fucking, let's go!
Push, push, push, push, push.
Look at the Bucky, look at the Bucky.
Pull from, pull from.
Never mind, let's stop going.
Let's stop going.
I think we go with cappel if we can build it.
Yeah, there just wasn't synergy.
Actually, I'll go with mine.
I'll try to force the Emma.
I'll go with mine.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Oh, shit.
Listen to this guy.
This is crazy.
Damn.
I wanted to.
start scratching oh shit i don't oh it's fine it's one guy
it's one guy who cares they have no support right now am i
yeah there you go care fox i'm at them i still play yeah the
fact is by the way this is more sweaty is because like both
team had this my team has like pros and great i'm on point
grab burn on the first nice that's right i'll scratch you up
where is he where is he like this guy hates me bro i need
i'm killing please please go yeah it's my girl genie no this
guy actually only is this oh you can watch it on defense
it's after me all right here we go they're off of emma
they're on things they have no Oh, if we need like, turn up,
turn up.
There you go.
It's fine.
Get in my circle of he is!
Oh, man.
Someone help her some.
Oh, my God.
Okay, no longer want to be in my circle of he is.
Not going to lie.
I'm behind them.
I broke it.
What the fuck?
Where did this guy come from?
Don't worry.
Let it ride!
Care thing, all, all, care thing all.
Oh shit, don't let it ride.
Don't let it ride.
I'm leaving.
Let it ride!
Just hold it on left.
He has hold on.
Let it ride!
Never mind.
I was like, is this a bad idea?
Hmm.
That is lived.
That's the key.
We're so back.
It's so over.
We let it ride.
You know what?
Let's get...
Not even close.
The biggest gamble of my life.
I knew it was...
I knew that was the play.
We're so back.
I can win in this evil.
I knew I can.
I'm glad I got invited, though.
I'm...
The World Cup.
Situation has been contained.
I'm going till we lose.
I don't know.
I just want to play more.
You know?
I just feel like playing.
I just felt like the games were, you know, the games weren't
super competitive.
Well, I mean, they were competitive, but it like felt, it
felt like a little...
I just I just actually want to play play a game like
yeah I want to repair the vibes I want to say it wasn't a
stomp it wasn't a stomp stomp it was just bad synergy bad
synergy and chemistry more time together maybe it'd be
better um but like we i think the the worst part is that we
didn't have our full team ready until the day before the
tournament and apparently some teams were finalized
finalized like for a week but our team we didn't know who
was going to be on our team fully because people were like
you know we had like dropping people like we had you know
dropping out and like we had like last minute changes to
rosters and stuff so we all found out about our team like
literally the day the day before the tournament yeah so we
the only time we actually practiced was uh like an hour
before our games yeah i know like other teams were already
like hard practicing and stuff apparently uh apparently it's
just like uh america united uh we're all and stuff from like
a week ago.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
That's why their synergy was like really, really good.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
Or no, the reveal was yesterday.
The reveal was literally yesterday.
But it was just, it wasn't just, it was like, some teams
just had people dropping out or like last minute swaps and
stuff.
that's why it's just hard you have to get 72 streamers
like 72 streamers uh to coordinate everything and it's hard
no rocket's really strong he's like one um the right heroes
could make all the difference life energy is a powerful
weapon against evil
What is this thing?
Oh yeah, Rocket is like super strong in this Elo, in
Eternity.
He's a target band now.
I'll play Luna.
It's just hard to coordinate 30...
Like I said, it's hard to coordinate 72 different streamers
in general.
So like, there's gonna be last minute drops and stuff.
I'll put it on road.
Um, it's because his alt builds the fastest out of all
supports now.
And...
I'll take it.
At least we have to sue for that.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my...
Oh!
That was like...
That was very scary.
I will say, that was very, very, very...
scared there's a lot of hooks there's like three different
hooks right now i might have to go white flocks too that's a
dive go down go down stay down i have no white flocks here
it's just too many people too many dive characters
oh oh oh um try my best to heal I'm trying really white fox
now.
Can someone go white fox versus that?
It's me!
Oh, goodbye.
I guess me go white fox!
It's me!
Oh, I fucking, I fucked up.
Oh shit!
She doesn't know I fucked up there.
Thank God I have my dash.
Alright.
It's not cool.
What are you gonna do?
Kill us?
It's alright.
Me, little do they know?
You know when they were like, do you know?
Little do they know?
I have like four hours on this character.
But I'll never tell that.
Aww.
I thought I timed it correctly.
I guess not.
Oh shit.
There you go.
There's no way he's gonna try and kill me, right?
Oh shit, maybe I need it.
Oh.
Please, please heal me!
That all was on me!
Or at the bottom.
You don't make no progress.
Alright.
It's alright.
know she didn't know guys it's okay that's okay it's all
right that's all right yeah keep going fuck him i didn't
even have to do that fuck this guy all right there we go i'm
glad i think he hit his head i think he's gonna hit his head
that's why um oh we don't have anything for dd that's
unlucky tell me if it's dd all right be ashamed of there was
a daredevil right now i'm so vulnerable
look how vulnerable i am right now oh my god there it is
They're not on fold.
All right, there you go.
That's fine.
Team portal?
Yeah, nice thing.
You should.
I think we make it.
No, he like hit his...
That does that.
He can...
You can hit your...
Yo, it's in the cart!
Oh, that's the worst part.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
That was a little...
That was bad.
It was on the kite.
I'm fine.
I'm kind of going for now.
Peter Quill.
Just don't go.
Spin rolls.
I can throw the tank.
Just like that.
That's fine.
Things will be okay.
Oh, this side.
I grab her, I grab her.
Oh my god, there's too much damage.
There's too much damage.
I, what do I, I, there's too much, Freddie.
There's too much.
This is my VC audio low.
No, it's at 100.
Why is everybody's mic so quiet?
That's much better.
Guys, I will try, Nicky.
It is first.
Somebody is first.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Oh, wait, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, wait, nice, nice, nice.
in here i don't want to go in there i really ah
i'm stomping i'm stomping oh my god i'm going back
i have roguelks when they walk you can let them in a tiny
bit i'll drop here oh three two one Got it off!
Slight!
Oh shit!
Not again!
Where did he come from?
Oh my god.
The current score is...
Two, three Time to switch things up Including each side Holy
shit Not again You'll need a top notch team to win this one
Agent F1 I'm going in Alright
That was a wild alt I know I didn't even see Elsa Just go to
triple Where did she come from Alright we go triple Oh, all
right All right Oh, he has the mag you say he doesn't play
tank but he had a lord mag He had I told you I told you guys
no one has a lord mag willingly It's not a consensual lord
Ultron's probably better there, BB
He had a lord mag he's like guys I don't play mag guys
That's true.
I was like, how the fuck do you- oh, it's mag.
Oh, it's just pro players flirting with each other.
You know how they deal.
Just homies, you know.
You know, you know when the homie gives another homie a
little kiss?
Good for good luck.
I know.
Don't you give your bro a kiss good night?
That's true bro behavior.
Hello.
That's right.
Use my ring.
I want to blink.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Hey.
Oh, that's a lot of damage.
That's a lot of damage.
Hey, I need your bro.
I need a bro like that.
get yourself a bro that'll give you a good good night kiss
is he truly a bro he doesn't care about you like that oh
that's whoops
terrible one
hello goodbye
All right, hello and goodbye Okay, he didn't get me though
Oh, he got a lot I'm not wasting a teleporter there
I'll waste it here Oh, I couldn't surrender in time I was
too busy in that game It's okay guys Sometimes This means
nothing.
This is nothing to me guys.
I will say I feel nothing.
I don't feel anything anymore.
Oh shit.
I got three!
Is this worth alting?
Because I don't think it's worth alting.
I am immune to this pain.
It's okay.
You win and you lose.
It's the circle of life.
I've already lost count how many.
Oh my god, he jumped in front of me.
He just...
Nothing doesn't mean anything to me anymore.
I just...
I scratch.
Fuck you!
I stop now!
Oh my god, I can still stop.
I still stop.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
I stop!
I feel no more pain.
I don't feel no pain no more.
I'm doing something really fucking dumb I don't know I was I
feel I also not think anymore I
just did something it's okay I just did something really
dumb I was like surely I can maybe let it ride I did a
little 50-50 you went wild there It's just like, fuck it!
The doom kill.
Not really a doom kill.
Oh, wait, I lose 17.
So it's not my fault.
You know it's not my fault when I lose 17 points.
That's how the cookie crumbles.
It's not my fault.
It was only 17 points, guys.
Yeah, you can't win every gotcha.
Exactly.
Oh, guys, I don't have a problem.
I do want to play more Overwatch, though.
I should say I've been meaning to wanting to grind more
Overwatch.
This will heal me.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
out drag my daughter oh my daughter left oh everyone leaves
me eventually guys
it's okay it's okay everyone eventually leaves me i've
accepted it i've oh it's okay
Bro build.
It's okay.
It's...
Back to solo, cute.
It's alright.
Guys.
Nothing can hurt me no more.
Nothing can hurt me, guys.
See?
Good thing I didn't stream on Twitch.
I'm glad I didn't stream on Twitch, guys.
Let's go.
I don't have people rating me.
Sending rate hates on me.
Facts.
Yeah.
I was like, we have no chat hoppers.
No chat hoppers.
Moths don't have to go over time.
dodge the bullet because i know knowing twitch knowing
twitch chat i know things i know a lot of people must have
got banned in a lot of people's chats i
the shade ain't nothing you're mad and see they give us
super chat they can thank you it means nothing to me it
doesn't I've I'm like in the pain now I can make new friends
Maybe I'll meet a new friend who wants to play with me I'll
do two to three more games and I'm gonna call it here Time
is it Oh four hours I'll do two to three more
I hate the skin I only did it just for the I literally hate
majority of the lunar skin I think lunar skins are fucking
ass I don't know.
I think majority of Luna skins just don't look good, which
is, which is like crazy because she's an industry plant.
Like, yeah, she's literally an industry plant, but I
legitimately hate majority of the Luna skins.
The race one's good, but they get to pay real money for it.
Like, like, this is like fine, but I don't, not like a huge
fan of it.
There's, yeah, she has so many skins, But, like, her, like,
original, her base default skin is the best.
But, like, a lot of her skins are ass.
I just don't like it.
I don't know.
Like, the colors for this?
I'm not a fan.
Like, the blue-pink colors on her?
Not a fan.
And then the star on her titty?
Like, the giant star on her fucking right titty?
Like, why is it...
Okay.
and this is like the decent one that I have yeah but it's
not even like the full cotton candy colors though that's the
thing it's not even the full cotton candy
like Rocket has a lot of skins I actually like aesthetically
it's like aesthetically pleasing to me like I think this
looks cool but like Luna skins I don't know they really push
the asymmetrical thing a lot They push the asymmetric
symmetry thing a lot, but then like the asymmetry this
asymmetrical thing just doesn't work that well
It's just like the color schemes are so fucking weird at
least like Jeff the other industry plant at least has like
lots of really good skins Luna just has like what one good
Luna skin.
I think that is like actually aesthetically pleasing in my
eye
like her default is real i like her default her default's
really pretty but um i feel like yeah
yeah but it's like everything but then like a lot of the
asymmetry thing is like pretty ass not gonna lie
yay wait a minute
I should put my spine.
I was like, this wrist sucks, but I'm like, whatever.
Big ol, big ol, big ol, big ol, big ol.
Good, quick, quick, quick, quick, quick.
Don't worry, I got you yet.
Whoa!
Who's got me?
I can't believe nobody broke my wrist yet.
That was actually such an ass wrist.
Let's go.
I'm true
See look I already have I'm closest to all right now I don't
even think I should I should reposition my wrist.
I don't even know how this is fucking over Sir one sir one
ours got broken There you go.
I gotta put that the Rez, the Overse out in time.
Trader TB.
Kill strange, kill strange.
See, their rocket had a little too.
Wow.
I'm just gonna chill here.
We live for a little bit?
I think we're Rez.
Just live, just live, just live, just live.
We're alive.
Kill Luna, kill Luna, we're kidding.
Goodbye.
Hiding.
Whoa.
Walk, walk, walk, walk.
Whoa!
She's still looking at me?
She's still looking at me.
It's fine.
If he's looking at me, he's not doing anything.
See, if he's looking at me, he can't do anything.
I can't... I don't have... It doesn't matter.
I was doing the ulted, so, like, they don't need me.
Good job, guys.
They don't need me in the fight.
I was like, yeah, they don't need me, but they need you.
So I didn't really care.
Honestly.
Oh.
That's just quick.
They used a star, Luna.
Yeah, that's soon.
Stopping.
Can you walk?
I have, I have sorrow.
Yeah, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, three, two.
We're trying.
You're trying.
That's how I'm playing is one HP.
Nice.
Phoenix is walking.
Kill a Phoenix.
I am up to I can swap I can reposition reposition my res now
there's no way they see this right it's a little in the open
that's fine it's just a little in the open it's just a
little in the ocean Oh, nice.
That's fine.
I'll take that.
That's like that.
Like, I'll take it.
Yeah, hiding in flame sight.
Like, what are you gonna do?
Destroy it?
That would be crazy.
Okay, okay.
I'll let her heal more.
Look Luna, look Luna.
I'm just cart bitch now.
Oh, I thought she was going to...
I thought she was going to...
It's fine to have parlias.
It's fine.
We're good.
Why Luna?
See, that's why I say rocket's just way too good right now.
Wait, what did they say?
Oh, first.
Oh, yeah.
Phoenix oh it's time to play chicken
Whoops, I need help.
I need help I need help I need help I need help There's one
wrapping me one wrapping me feed feed feed feed feed feed
feed feed Okay, he didn't have The more I will rise up here
in plain sight
There we go.
Oh, there we not go.
I'm alting.
Don't double support.
Oh, it'd be a shame if I just got 100 just now.
You ready, boys?
This is my turn.
All right.
It's my turn, guys.
Get ready.
I'm ready.
Clap, bang.
Clap bang.
All right, here we go.
Thanks so much.
Here you go.
I'm throwing my orbs.
Beautiful.
Nice.
Oh, they're on.
Oh, yeah.
Go to here.
See, guys, it's not in the open anymore.
I'm no longer throwing.
It's no longer in the open.
Yeah, we need to go faster with Star.
Could we burn the rocket?
They're gonna have rocket.
Could we force it with Luna?
Holy shit.
Okay, you start.
You start.
Oh my god.
He is very passionate.
Oh my god, he's a squirrel girl.
Is that Warren?
All right, ready?
Three, two, one.
I'm gonna
put that on him.
Three, two.
Back, back, back, back, back, back, back, back, back.
Oh my god.
Oh!
There's a...
Stay on the raft.
This course won't hit you.
Okay, yay!
Oh my god, one got to eternity.
Good for him.
Are you even live?
I climbed the magic spout.
That's how I live.
And now I'm here.
See you guys?
Squirrel Girl does work.
Sorry, that's a little bit of a cheap blow.
I'm sorry.
Look,
we all fucked up in that tournament.
I went Gambit.
It didn't.
I would say it just didn't do a lot of damage.
like I could have done more damage and did more heals and
stuff
put the rest here I don't know where to put the rest here
once we get this timeline thing sorted out I'm taking a long
vacation somewhere with lots of stuff to steal
slapping slapping slapping back I mean it's still really
strong it was just the fact that I had to I always had to
look at the star lord I always whenever I was gambit I
didn't have the privilege to like do much because I was
always having I always had a flanker and like I I know I'm
supposed to deal with flankers, but like I need a DPS to
help me because I know I'm not as good as like like a rank 1
DPS player, you know?
So if the another DPS turnaround with me to kill the
flanker, it would have been easier.
We just had no hit scan player.
And we did, but it was like sure for Pat to be playing other
characters.
We had to multitask a lot there.
The Luna on your left.
I swear.
Yeah, and then the moment I look away, my tanks got mega
melted.
Are they playing Phoenix?
They are.
I'm just going.
Just tight, tight, tight.
Just live, just live.
We have res for once.
Yeah, that's fine.
Our hella lives.
Let's go, let's go.
Our tank!
Turn!
Not a heart, dude!
Okay, let's see here.
Trust me, I'm trusting, I'm trusting.
Oh!
Fear!
Stop me.
I'm jumping because I'm trying to get the heels over there
because i'm trying to angle it as like simple geometry
that's the only reason why i'm jumping who isn't my turn now
we run see now i'm already at 73.
oh surely how does i have all that for this hey three two
one three i got you i'm gonna oh yeah we didn't need that we
didn't We did not need that.
That's my bad.
We did not need that.
What's up, both of them?
Oh.
Oh, this rocket's in, bro.
I can't kill him.
I think they gave up.
Yay!
Oh.
I'm happy.
Alright, let's avoid this guy.
This guy...
Actually, I don't know about this guy.
I mean, this guy sort of tried.
Like, it was this guy that was like...
What the fuck was he doing?
I don't know.
This guy was the what the fuck he was doing?
But, like, this one...
I don't know.
He sort of tried.
He flexed.
he did flex like i'll give him that
like that it's like he tried and then he obviously gave up
in the end vibes weren't there i get it buddy i get it i was
just like you like i get it i get it buddy
bottom You're not supposed to jump in Overwatch.
Jumping in Overwatch is bad, but jumping in rivals is like
okay.
I don't know.
I don't know why, but it's just less punishable versus
jumping.
Because that's what I learned.
Like it's okay to jump in rivals, but in Overwatch it's too
predictable.
Because in Overwatch, I was trained not to jump in
Overwatch.
Uh...
But, like, because it's just the angle and stuff.
Like, the...
Like, it's just predictability.
Same with Apex.
It's like Apex.
I think it's a...
Maybe it's a first-person thing.
First-person shooter thing.
Because it's similar to Apex, where you're not supposed to
jump in...
In Apex.
Because it's very easy to track someone when they're
jumping.
But in Rivals, like, it's fine.
Bum-b-b-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum.
I'm sorry, I'm disassociating.
I'm disassociating right now.
Blackwood was so hot.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Oh no.
Now, who am I going to banish from this match?
Oh my god, people are so mad.
Oh my god, I feel so bad.
People are so mad on my Twitter feed.
Yeah.
Mad about what?
No, not about me.
The Scarlet Witch is actually pretty good.
Not about me, but maybe just about Team Canada.
Holy shit, my algorithm is full of it right now.
No, no, no, no.
They just played against me, bro.
Half those people just played against me.
No work.
Brothers, Cyclops is a permaband.
Yeah.
Starward are from a ban?
They clearly banned me, obviously.
Oh, they banned me.
No, I didn't really do anything.
Uh...
But it's just Team Canada over a...
Can I not solo take, please?
No, you're a clown.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Just joking.
Because your name is on.
Even when you can't see me, I'll still leave.
Not exactly me as a problem.
Please be Oni Wukong.
Not exactly me.
No, I...
No, it's...
You might know who...
is getting the brunt of it.
Yo, why am I naked?
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Honestly?
I made it.
Let's go.
Just going badly.
Oh, good job you.
Thanks so much.
Hey, there's two on me.
That DD's one.
My boy.
All right.
Whoa!
How did he die?
So...
Oh!
From where I got you, girl.
Oh, I don't know if I got you.
getting though girl oh that's unlucky oh that was a huge
boulder from me it's a little hard no
worries i got your back you said to you are you running solo
team i'm so like forward that you need setting in that
corner you can see a south park out there the fucking wall
all right i'm walking in you're up top yo mag play like like
you got big nuts bro you're playing Bro, calm down.
Bro, calm the fuck down.
He just, guys, he just bonded.
He literally was just born, guys.
Oh my god.
I tried.
Judge, Jerry.
How about supports?
We don't have supports.
I don't know.
I swap.
This is like...
I can't play.
This isn't...
No, no, no.
Go punish her.
What?
We might need a second tank, guys.
They are out DPSing us.
We got two support outs, then we got one.
The math is mapping.
Well, I would love...
Thank you.
Alright.
You know what?
I'm gonna I'm a cop for it.
Let's go.
Let's go All right, let's go Let's hope I live Let's oh,
let's go They have um spider-man up
Don't mess with the amazing spider-man.
Oh, that's not good for me That's not good for me.
That was not good for me.
I'll TP back.
I don't give up so easily.
I'm TPing.
Oh my guys, I suck a tank.
Only for...
I'm just gonna go with photos right on point.
TP off their supports if you can.
They're coming back together.
I don't like you.
Hex!
He just won.
Okay.
Oh, planned.
Magic is still alive.
Wait, wait.
Oh, they're not right.
You're not going to go strange?
I'm going to swap off the double take that was working for
us?
You're...
Yeah, I was going to say!
You're going to swap off the character that I'm sorry.
wasn't helping us yeah you're the god on screen i want to go
cap we could die together actually oh i hear him he's like
this was working i'm gonna swap off guys
is that crazy it was working earlier oh my god let's hope
Nice.
Thanks so much.
Okay, they're done enough support on them.
Oh, your support's don't really get healed that fast.
Oh.
No freeze.
It's a little harder.
I'm with you.
We can kill him.
Oh, please.
They're trying to walk on there.
Oh, my God, please.
That was a huge pull.
That grabs me.
That's crazy.
Oh, my God, please.
Why did we kill Gap?
Oh!
We're okay
Appreciate it All right, I really need all I really need all
I really need all here.
Oh, I gotta get out Please Never mind uh, let's walk out.
Let's walk out.
I'm gonna get it.
Go ahead.
I can't go.
There you go
There you go.
That was a good ult.
That was a really aggressive ult, but I figured it was worth
it.
I know it was super aggressive, but it was so worth it.
Okay, that, I don't know.
That, that, that, I'm not quite sure, though.
That, I'm not quite sure.
I'm not quite sure about that one.
If they match, we have, we're going to be up Luna all here,
so we'll be killing.
Are they here?
Hello
Wait, he swapped off strange wait he swapped off strange,
but it was working Wait, he swapped his because if I'm sold,
I mean, I can't like he swapped up
he actually swapped up there's a two on the left it's like
it's been working I'm gonna swap this is two I'm sorry
you're gonna get fucking slam dunk
alright why did you be in front of you Alright, that's fine.
I'm gonna keep...
I'm diving backline in three, two, one.
I'm running.
That's fine.
There we go.
Nice.
I almost have a...
I'm gonna push a little bit.
Alright.
Let's see what I can do.
grab some i'm gonna try to i'm gonna try to force the
support here do not match it oh well do not match it
all right it's fine it's still winnable oh it's so winnable
it's huge
I'll use it later not yet
They have no support ulti We I just wanted to go ah, it's
fine.
It's a zoning.
It's a zoning up It's fine.
I zoned them and I'm gonna give I'm gonna give my Luna
chance to heal Oh nice
Guys it's a zoning up good job There we go.
We need to self-sabotage.
We're doing too well.
Which side you're on?
The right heroes could make all the difference.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
I would suggest avoiding the TTV flow guy.
Pretty good avoid right now.
Alright, let's go.
What would we have known?
Well, we didn't really have two tanks.
We still were doing one tank.
All right, here we go.
Here we fucking go.
We got this, guys.
Let's just say me and Jack are all the questions.
We got this.
Nothing to worry about.
Hey, do we have Ultron?
Put it on the wrong one.
Whoops.
They are and you don't know, Tron.
Okay, I'll get off there.
Why are you running?
People somewhere?
That's much better.
Oh, they must...
That'll be cool.
Oh, yeah.
I might have to push these guys away from my fucking
strange.
Like, he's getting fucked up right now.
Oh, get away from my stream.
Nice kill.
I didn't use it to push people off of him because I feel
like...
I'm just gonna stand on the side.
It's just gonna pierce me.
Oh yeah, they are running triple.
Oops.
Didn't mean to press E there.
Gonna use this for myself.
Oops.
My bad.
there you go I got you Luna get away from my stranger okay I
could use it aggressively hmm oh my god I can use that okay
it's fine it's fine we have we live we live we fucking live
we live that's a good an exchange.
Goodbye Luna.
I'm sorry.
All right, play back a little bit.
We're gonna be down to support for a bit.
I'm still around.
They should have no support olds.
Yeah.
You said push up a die?
Yeah, yeah, I'm going to push up a die.
I got you, fam.
I'm gonna hit my ball ball.
Play your snowflakes.
I'm a DDL.
Oh, he's not a black ass.
Can we walk?
Okay.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
All right, my shifts are not fine though.
I will say my shifts are absolutely terrible.
It's okay.
We have Sunday.
for soccer it's okay we have soccer though strange for
portal maybe no they're walking they're just doing it for
the scarlet witch they're just doing it for Not me!
My bad, I should shield up.
We got trouble.
What did you do?
Not me!
Totally WJF.
You're using spawn camp, by the way.
You have the back there.
Throw, throw, throw, throw, throw, throw, throw, throw.
Oh, you gotta help back.
God damn, actually, uh, fucked over.
Let him, let him do damage.
fucked over by this.
There it is.
There's split.
That's crazy.
You can kill for it.
I'm gonna stay out of here.
If you guys can go do your fucking thing, you're going to.
Hey there.
The paid acting.
That Jeff was, yeah.
I have a feeling that fun affair game.
They were Canada.
That was Team Canada.
Good luck for Canada.
We lost.
This is how it feels to be Brazil.
Right now.
Yeah, Brazil, America.
Doesn't know that.
What does he mean?
Yeah, what does he mean?
Like, good luck.
What does he mean?
He's...
He doesn't know.
He doesn't fucking know.
That's crazy.
lazy.
Bada.
All right, let me disassociate.
You guys get, you guys get twerking, Jeff.
That's not twerking.
That's business, Jeff.
Wait a minute, am I?
Okay, no.
You guys get twerking, Jeff, for a second.
Disassociation tab.
Brother lacks critical.
Actually, was there anybody I should have avoided in that
game?
Overall?
Like, I avoid the flow.
I mean, the Daredevil did his job.
I don't know.
I feel like everyone else was...
Oh, wait.
Maybe our...
Maybe?
I mean, the Scarlet Witch did his thing.
But, like...
I don't know.
Was he actually just play Scarlet?
Pfft.
Okay.
Alright, what was his...
I actually don't...
Actually, no.
That's too much.
That's too risky.
I'm not...
I'm not here to be your 50-50 bro I'm not here to do that 50
Do I have two streams tomorrow?
I do?
I thought I was just playing Armored Core tomorrow Two
streams yesterday Yeah, no, I only have Armored Core Guys
Sunday is to watch a lot
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum oh oh oh oh
oh oh my god this is also why i stopped playing high you
though the cues are way too long guys i forgot this was also
another reason why why i just hated playing this, Elo.
I just hated waiting.
I hated like, I remember now.
I literally booted up fucking Roblox because of how long it
fucking took.
Oh my god.
Just took way too fucking long.
Come on.
Bum,
bum, bum, bum, bum.
it's a bit of a slag it's a bit of slag
uh which hero do you think you want to be today
all right we're in game banning guys life energy is a
powerful weapon against every spider-man player who am i
gonna banish from this match you guys want to bet spider-day
all right oh we have a spot i can't put much here so he'll
be like bro they're behind a hypnotic way currently busted
guys the hypnotizing thing just to hypnotize thank you the
super chat el thank you thank you i guess just banditi or
rockets i don't know
you'll need a
top-notch team to win this one
all right let's see what's there
all right here we go oh shit you guys want me to play
all right let's go
how are things going on quick koa right but it's not easy
getting adjusted to living in a whole new timeline you don't
have to tell me sometimes i feel like an old soldier in a
war what the am i getting dragged into
oh it's just team cat of the thing It's just Team Canada
things.
Oh, wait, this...
Wait a minute.
This matches a little high elo.
This is a high elo game.
I can't disassociate anymore.
I can't play with my vibes on the line.
I go for Zyglobs.
I'm on it right now.
I recognize these players.
Oh, what's...
Alright, buddy.
Here you go.
Whoops, that's my bad.
I did me, did me, did me.
I yolo'd that.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, I would love to heal you.
Oh, fuck it.
Oh my god, are you guys okay with it?
I am ready to put on you.
Oh, I'm so close to it, though.
Shane, we didn't have damage.
We were just like this.
Feeling fantastic.
Can you go to the next one?
You want to look at the next one?
Yeah.
We have to move.
There you go.
Look at their wolf over time to do some damage.
Damage!
Kill him!
There you go.
They might pour it out.
I'm gonna stay over here.
Oh, nothing good, though.
Oh, there's three of them.
of us.
There we go, we get it.
No, it's just, you know how they're like, you know how much
of a funny, he-he-haha team, like, oh my god, I'm against
Cooper.
Cooper's really fucking good at support.
I will say.
That's why I was like, oh shit, this is a high, high, low
game.
I was not ready for this.
I'm like, I don't know.
I'm like low eternity.
If I low eternity, is this decent?
Oh, shit!
Thank you.
Bro,
where the fuck is he?
There we go.
Oh my god.
I don't... Oh, get me out of here.
I won't go back to my coffee.
Celestial games.
Give me back.
Low eternity Celestial games.
me out of here.
I mean I'm not going to grieve to get myself out of here.
I'm just saying I'm this is a release.
This is really stressful.
This is really stressful, guys.
I'm not, I'm not grieving.
I'm just saying I forgot how stressful.
I guess they're just burning.
Might be a lot.
Holy shit, this is like a pro lobby right now.
I don't know if I if I fuck with that.
You should only have loot out.
Yeah, close to life on someone.
Yeah, they throw through walls.
They have walls, they have chariots on top, but close walls.
I'm just shooting it out into the open.
I should stop that.
I should save my Sith.
I need to remember what Elo I'm in right now.
I'm literally just playing with vibes right now.
I need to remember.
I need to remember what Elo I'm in.
I'm literally...
I'm literally chucking it out into the open.
Oh no.
Only me, only me, only me.
It's okay, we haven't Viz Hall, so...
That's unlucky.
Coming back the other bullet.
Burn it, burn it, burn it.
Three, two, one.
Killable vault, killable vault, killable vault.
There we go.
You're fine!
We're alive!
That's a good match, nice.
Get back in.
Kill, shoot, don't kill.
Oh.
I want to back out a little bit because it's strange.
Alright, there you go.
I said, I need to remember what Elo I'm in.
Because I'm just checking it in.
Because I haven't played in this Elo in so long.
Because I literally stopped.
I always, like, stopped playing when I hit Eternity.
So, like, because I'm like, this is too much.
This is too much work.
And I just want to hang out.
cool bag we're gonna have auger oh my god i looked away for
one second what the fuck happened that was worth it it was
worth it
it was so worth it i have my trink here there you go i can
check here's carolga carolga carolga all right I mean, damn.
That's a good up though.
Straight up.
Two, two, three, two.
Yeah, I need a back up.
Pulls, pull.
Pulls.
Oh, my.
Oh, whoa, that was...
That was an up.
I have to walk my cap.
You need to make the circle so they're...
Just make the circle so they're going in and out.
Holy shit!
What's going on?
I'm so stressed out.
I'm so stressed out right now.
This way.
This way, way, way.
I'm walking.
I'm so stressed out.
you are nothing oh we did not break it we did not break it
we did not we have to play past the corner we cannot just
keep watching our wolves can you play wolf cycles i'm hurt i
don't know am i safe out here coming out of your mouth right
now guys do they see me whoa this is such a wolf is gonna
help you i totally play wolf use lunifers you use lunifers I
wonder if you play wave or not.
I asked if you can play it.
If you don't know how to play the round, you can play with
them.
You can be very careful to move here.
Oh my god.
Oh!
There we go!
Oh no.
Back here, back here, back here, back here.
Alright.
Oh, I just jumped it.
I jumped it.
I'm ready to put on the show.
three looks looks just feeding feed feed feed feed feed feed
feed oh nice he missed you missed you missed you missed you
missed you missed you missed you killed you oh there's a
thing behind me oh i'm gonna
i don't know this will help but it's just me right now it's
just me it's just me
I'm gonna fall okay all right Luna Luna Luna Luna Luna
straight shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot oh my god I'm
scared oh shit time to vanish
I don't have it.
Here you go.
Oh my god, Invon, Invon, Invon.
Walk,
walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Look, walk.
Like kill me, bro.
Three, two, four.
Keep it going.
This is your difficult thing.
kill straight straight back right back all right all right
here we go the right heroes could make all right I am Loki
goddess of mischief and the queen of Asgard stack lobby i'm
not ready for this mentally i was not ready for this i oh no
i forgot what it was like i forgot what this was like like
the moon i shine in darkness
this is why this is why i always play on all the chaos
I'm back in the trenches.
Wait, time's too long.
Game's too hard.
Why do I...
Why do people do this to themselves?
Honestly.
The battle starts in class.
Four, three, two, two, three, one.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
I swear if this outfit gets ruined There will be hell to
play
I pulled that man, pull that man Go for him, go for him
Whoa Look at that man, look at that man, look at that man
I'm shooting There's an ultron all right oh they're running
triple two come on let me heal you all right that's a lot of
damage
that's fine right now three two run i'm fighting
there we go i pull i pull which looks i clap
all right
we're gonna have trink first that's fine when they walk
again a little bit of a topper thank you they're swapping
they have one tank now it's just like us oh no Cooper's sad
Cooper's sad and mad yeah
I'm doing it.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming back, guys.
This is my come-up.
I can alt-first.
Alright.
Venom's no touch point.
Oh, never mind.
He's in spawn.
He's up.
Alright.
Oh, Cooper's on tank now.
Oh, they had a...
Oh, their team was all support player.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
It's the little things in life.
Yeah!
Oh, support.
Yes!
They're Team Canada now!
I am ready to put on a show!
Yeah!
What a polar when she's not.
I feel better already.
have to be center stage their team team canada
oh we move up we're moving up can we go
You know, I didn't even do it.
I just want you to know there was no countdown.
You know how he was like 3, 2, 1?
And I was like, this is the countdown.
For one.
Everyone was 1 HP.
He's like, I'm doing a countdown.
And I was like, full on damage.
What is he gonna shoot it?
Oh!
Oh my god, I did not expect that.
Cassiante.
Where the fuck?
I don't have holes for the venom.
There's no blue.
Nice.
Yay!
Oh my god.
From all support players to like one support.
I think I know like they had four support players I think
I'm pretty sure oh no now I'm getting even higher now I'm
getting even higher rank guys oh no wait a minute I started
solo queuing then I started winning maybe I'm not the
problem All I'm seeing, I started solo queuing.
My steak is so juicy right now.
Like, what is it?
Oh my god, are you serious?
I'm three games away from top 500.
I...
But Doki, we're gonna lose the really cozy games.
You're so right.
You're so lost your butt.
Stake too juicy, bread too buttery.
Let it ride.
Just three games.
All right, we lose the next one.
I'm calling it.
Like, I don't really care.
I'm tough.
If I get tough, I would really not.
I really don't care.
All right, here we go.
all right let's go back to back to the way actually should i
avoid anybody i don't even know like individually these play
like mikey cooper zay individually they're all good players
i don't know about these three like i just think they just
had four support players not gonna lie i think that was just
the their biggest problem they I had four support players.
One of the supports, there's no way it'll happen again,
right?
There's no way.
There's no way I'll get another.
I'll get this again.
I'm taking the risk.
I'm gambling.
I'll let it ride.
Because individually, they're all, individually, they're all
good players.
They just had four support players.
Imagine an even juicier steak.
And I'm even more buttery and lobster.
Oh my gosh.
Just imagine, guys.
You know the best part?
We lost together.
We all lost together.
I don't know.
Come on, bottom.
Oh, US won the...
They won the final hits.
They got the final hits in.
I think they farmed it off of us, for sure.
They definitely did.
They definitely got it off of us, guys.
Yeah.
We might have took them to the end.
What hero do you think you want to be today?
Who am I going to banish from this match?
Alright.
We're in.
Oh, hey, it's March.
Oh, man.
I'm in lobbies where I recognize these players.
It's been 20 years since that happened.
I forgot what that was like.
I would never recognize anyone on my team.
I actually recognize these players.
Wait, March wants to play.
Oh, today is a...
Oh, it's whiny!
Yeah, I trust him.
I trust him.
Uh, let's try.
Isn't...
Wasn't Winy the...
Our Jeff player from...
From the Trust Me team?
Am I confusing it with someone else?
The other...
My support from the...
Trust Me...
When I was with Trust Me.
Couple months ago.
I don't know.
I play with so many people.
I've lost track.
I'm sorry.
All these pro players have blurred in my head now.
I've met so many pro players.
They all, like, I don't remember names anymore.
Is that the same one?
It's him, right?
It's the...
It's the guy that was...
That was my support partner.
It would have trust me for Bougar Bash, right?
I just so hard to keep track It was that it was a while ago.
That's why I was like I don't remember it Because the name
is familiar
Oh my god, I'm freaking going down here
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do What the fuck
Oh nice Oh, not nice.
What did he get?
I don't even know who he got.
Oh, shit.
I didn't see.
I'm so sorry.
That was my bad.
I did not see.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm trying.
I tried.
I think I'm going to swap.
I might need this.
I'm swapping.
I have time to swap.
I'm going to swap.
You don't need me on...
They're not dive.
Okay.
You just need more heals, honestly.
Oh my god!
Nuclear bomb!
A fucking nuclear bomb just happened.
Holy shit!
Yeah.
No, she's good.
I just, nobody was diving, so there was no point in playing
it.
I sure swapped like earlier, but I was just like, oh, that's
bad.
Oh, well, that's my bad.
That was a little too.
I should have saved it.
All right.
Whoa.
Whoa, I think he's okay.
Never mind.
I definitely should have kept the, I should have saved the
Invis up there.
I don't know, I thought, I don't know.
I thought at least I could save my Groot, but I guess not.
Oh my god.
That's unfortunate.
That was actually unfortunate.
But.
That should make a difference.
Oh,
that was a good freeze.
How did they...
What?
Oh my god, I'm almost heavily up through you.
Okay, I don't even know how the players died, honestly.
I was like, what happened?
Like, what the fuck happened?
Yeah, no, our Luna is pro.
We have...
I don't know if Silas is pro, but...
Uh...
Um...
But, uh...
We have at least three pro players right now.
It should be our Luna that's moving up, but...
I'm stupid.
I should let our Luna push up more.
I feel like everybody's in a Discord right now.
Everyone's so quiet for pros.
What?
For pro players, they're all so quiet.
Not gonna lie.
I feel like, yeah.
I feel like everybody's just in a server right now.
Like, why is everyone so quiet?
Oh my god.
I'm trying not to heal too much, but I'm...
Oh, maybe I should start healing more.
Am I... I'm alive.
Alright.
Wow!
Maybe a little too much, guys.
We went a little too wild there.
Wow!
Yeah.
There must be, like, in a Discord call or some shit.
They're way too quiet.
They love yapping Too much odds, man.
Okay.
I am ready to put on a show.
Nice.
Yo, I got it.
It's worth it.
Nice healing.
My back.
Okay.
Take them all.
They're just cool.
What are you aiming at?
Don't worry, Wani!
No, I tried, Wani!
I tried!
Oh my god.
Hey,
we have Groove.
We have Groove.
You're just following me, bro.
Just following me, bro.
Thanks for the boost.
Yeah, the star were to eat.
Wow!
I fucked up.
I fucked up there.
Oh, but he's with his one as well.
It's a good old tune.
You have to do it for him.
Now.
Go, go, go, go.
Okay.
I was just unfortunately in a corridor.
I could have used my shield to block it, but I was in the
corridor.
And this place is worth a good luck.
So like...
Yeah,
I hit a wall.
So I couldn't do it.
Including which side you're on.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
I'm not the type who fades quite.
All right.
It is winnable.
Guys, I'm winning too much.
I say that, I know I'm going to lose this one.
I'm jinxing myself.
Guys, I'm purposely jinxing myself.
Oh my god, I am winning so much right now.
I'm...
Oh my god.
Like...
Oh yeah.
And...
There.
Made it just in time.
I asked to be heroes, but we always answer the call.
It was ironic, so I think you're fine.
They'll be coming in 30 seconds.
Stay strong.
All right.
I forgot I kept it red for stuff.
All right, here we go.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All right, I got that one, correct?
At least.
You think this is a challenge?
You're raising two super-powered kids.
No worries.
I've got your back.
You won't...
Oh, no.
No!
I thought your legs were broken!
Nope.
I thought they broke your legs!
Why are you still here?
I hope you're a killer.
I really do hope...
It's clear I'm still needed here.
Bro, you can't hit a shot!
Bro, why did you hit a shot?
I'm talking it's just so hard!
What was that?
That was me assuming he would hit a shot!
Oh my
god.
I don't think he'll live.
He missed the freeze though at least.
It's like when you watch at once I want to score a fucking
goal.
He won't be needing that.
I'll die for you.
We're heavily staggered.
He said my bad, though, Doki.
All is forgiven.
Okay, now we're fully reset.
Now we're fully reset, right, guys?
Are we all good?
A nice deep freeze.
Oh, thanks so much.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I am ready to put on a show.
Gotcha.
I wasn't gonna live that.
Yo, Winnie and Doki Bear, can you guys wake up?
I can't keep people.
I don't know.
She ulted.
Like, how is the fuck?
What are you saying?
I killed one.
I killed two.
Go ahead.
Guys, I had a bad day, guys.
Please be nice to me.
Hey, guys, please be nice to me.
I lost every game on Team Canada.
Losing.
Oh, my God.
What?
I should be back up, man.
I don't have any budget right now.
I'm like, I was on your team last team.
ever you were fine with my here oh I don't want to be
needing that I think maybe Winnie's with silence oh my gosh
I don't know where is he oh I was like where is the guy oh I
hear him
oh I couldn't get to oh please
let me live oh my god okay okay all right
Oh, I fucked up.
It's clear I'm still needed here.
Oh my god.
I'm coming over.
Okay.
All right.
No.
That was scary You're like how every time I'm like begging
like please let me live Oh my Please let us live please let
us oh We were not living we were It's just us begging for
our lives
They got a end result that's it yeah situation definitely
not definitely not contain right get out of here that should
make a difference I did oh I'm trying I'm so scared there's
too many things happening on my screen oh my god oh my
god raven oh it's not worth it it's not worth i'm not using
it all right i leave i'm not using um don't give them
another inch
I hope I live.
Please, please, please.
Oh, I didn't want to all...
I didn't want to all...
I hope that was not a mistake.
There's a block up behind, guys.
You're going to need to have it in this...
Oh, please save me.
Please.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh my god, where is he?
Oh, I fucked up there.
That was my bet.
That was such a...
I threw that.
Oh!
I threw that!
I thought there were more people there.
I threw that support alt.
I thought there were more people.
I fucked up.
Yeah.
That was my bad.
I actually threw that one really badly.
Oh, that's on me.
We lose it.
If we lose that, that's on me.
I fucked that up.
I should have.
Oh, I should have held it.
I was just like freaking out.
was like okay there has to be like people fucking running at
me right now that was my bad I take the blame if people
avoid me but JK I I'd be offline anyway no I panicked there
that was my bad I fucked up
if I save that all we win that but I was like I was like I
don't know I was just paranoid
I messed up we messed up oh my god what the fuck such a
weird lie
stop down with them I what do I do I don't know what to do
in that situation situation
It's clear 30 seconds.
I guess I should have saved my jump there
I should have saved my jump I'm gonna try to save my jump
more All right, I'm alive though at least we'll have a
little good no that's good
One our little no here
It's good I won't build up though I'm like so far from
building else That's bad because they have support else and
we don't
Oh, I don't have support I think my game is being re-traded
made quite literally
I just need oh I don't get angry.
What the fuck?
Oh, come on.
Oh, I can't live!
I'm getting dumped so hard!
I'm getting dumped so fucking hard and I feel so bad.
I wish I could do more.
I'm sorry!
Come on, Winnie!
Clutch this...
Oh, yeah!
Current score is...
Three, two, four.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Winnie is...
I'm on Winnie's backpack right now.
I don't know what I can do.
I'm just like I'm on his backpack.
I'm like the drooling kid and being like.
I'm like drooling and I'm like, I'm sorry.
I just, I just got these new hands.
The Phoenix always rises.
I think you could help me in the cycle for good.
This world is not done with you yet.
Alright, yo yo.
I don't know why.
He had his food.
Okay, kill myself without...
Oh my god.
They're taking so much damage and it's scaring me.
They're taking so much damage and I'm really...
Oh, I'm really scared.
Ha ha ha ha!
all right all right here we go i'm sorry whiny
oh my god oh what is this win trade like actually what is
this win trade hey gg literally on live on dream just win
trading dying and over on purpose.
Hey, well played, bro.
We gave it all.
Can't win them all, man.
Peace, GG.
I don't even know.
Is he mad at me or is he mad at March?
Who is he mad at?
I don't...
even tell who he's mad at.
He's like, I'm like, I swear I'm trying.
I swear.
I don't know what happened.
It's because I was getting picked non-stop.
I can't tell.
I literally can't tell who he was mad at.
I was doing my best.
I felt really bad for why I need, though.
I felt really bad for it.
I could have healed the why anymore there.
My dope heart.
Alright.
I don't know if that should be my last game.
That felt like a really bad game, though.
It did feel like a really bad game.
I know I said last game a while ago, and then I kept
playing.
I know.
lonely girl no one wants to deal with me it's okay I don't
need anyone I did say if I lose that's true I don't know I
don't know I definitely fucked up there with positioning I
should position myself better um but it was also like like
whiny was able to live but i couldn't when he was getting
dope so i was just like i was dope
it's just one of those days
can never end on a loss you're right you're right i'll do
one more i'll do one more fuck it one more for the road I've
accepted my solo queue life
I've accepted it I'll do one more A little bit of doom queue
won't help But that will help Yeah What cat vibes That's
good I just felt so bad I was like, why do I'm sorry I'm so
sorry why do
what he's trying to get more food what moya what no no no no
no no he's trying to get more food but like he already ate
up full dinner zero thank you the super chat thank you thank
you your team winning um last solid team candidate is good
we all played a part in that loss though i will say we all
played a part
so it's a fair you know it's fair Oh
that up
i'm i'm disassociating that's what happened to me sorry i
was i might have been a little disassociated there i just
wanted to jam to him shaking his ass
you lost me for a you lost me there for a sec
but um all right here we go i need that disassociation yeah
i did i really did I needed to, like, not be here physically
and mentally.
Put it in, put it in, out, put it in, out,
out, out, out, out, out, out, out, out, all right, here we
go.
I just realized, like, we never comboed, too, 18 Canada.
Like, we just so un-synergized.
We never tried a combo.
all right oh yeah oh two all right this is actually my blg
i'm too disassociated now this is my blg i'm way too
disassociated oh
i hear i hear a flanker
Nope, I don't have another one.
I don't have another.
Oh, I didn't have another one.
That's unlucky.
Oh, we don't.
We have two dive tanks.
I'm not going to lie.
Don't even try to dive there back then.
Yeah, I was going to say, we have two dive tanks, but no
dive DPS.
I just saved this for dive.
Wait, I can play white fox.
I'll play white fox.
No, I don't feel like I'm not like in the same place
anymore.
Oh,
I'm gonna go.
I'm swapping.
Kill me, please.
I would like to be killed.
Oh my god, fucking kill me.
Just kill me.
Oh, white foxes!
I didn't even realize!
Alright, it's fine.
I didn't even realize White Fox was bad.
Oh, this is much more difficult than...
It was very difficult.
Oh, I should have stopped.
I don't know why.
I should have stopped.
Why did I...
I was too confident.
I should have stopped.
I'm not mentally here anymore.
I'm...
I'm not even there.
I should have stopped.
If I have it
Oh merit Fuck it I'll merit I got a little too scared I know
I shouldn't mirror it But like I did not trust You have
combo Yeah combo Yeah combo there You have combo Damage boo
three two one venom still behind
oh i didn't know oh please don't die we don't have squirrels
now they have everything they have star lord and fdd and
star lord
oh my god we're in a room we're in a room we're so safe in a
room we're so safe we are so safe hey the priest for you
she's careful she smells crap she's so we're so venom diving
no worries i've got your back all right venom no even we'll
see we feel so safe we're so safe i feel so safe i feel so
fucking safe.
That's huge.
Nice.
Alright.
I don't know if it's nice or not, but I hope...
Oh my god, I gotta make sure our fucking team lives, though.
Guys!
There you go, that's fine.
Oh, no.
Not for him, though.
Not for him.
Maybe I should not have.
I should have definitely kept that.
Okay.
We only have one thing for now.
I feel so safe.
All right, here we go.
Oh my god, get me back here!
Oh, I'm coming back.
Actually, never mind, never mind, never mind.
The loot is back.
I'm in the damage.
She's on damage next to her life.
Yeah, it's fine, it's fine.
I can build mine.
I can build mine first.
All right, here we go.
He's crying.
Chew?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I got dope.
I couldn't do anything.
I got fucking dope so hard.
Oh no.
I got dope.
What do you want for me?
I knew I shouldn't play that last game.
Next dive, let me know when you want to go in.
Oh my god.
I think you just have to play this game to soft point,
honestly.
Yeah, that's the way I do.
Third point, knock it off.
We can do a dive for now since points are on auto.
What do you want from me?
I had a bad day!
Alright, I'm gonna dive right in there.
We're gonna get one of our stars.
Invis, walk the home, please.
I am!
What do you mean?
I've been walking up!
I was literally right behind you!
Walking up!
Oh my god, she can't say that.
I was literally right behind trying to walk up.
This last game was a mistake.
This girl's a...
I could just stop playing.
Play in front of me, girl.
Force first!
What do you mean?
There's no tanks!
I'm gonna walk in front of three people!
Holy shit!
Are you stupid?
Are you fucking... You're a fucking... You're so stupid.
You're actually so stupid.
Walk in front of three tanks.
Like, you're actually fucking stupid.
I'm sorry, it actually tilted me.
She's like, walk up!
Walk up!
And I was like, there was a two tanks in front of me.
Oh my god.
That actually tilted me so hard.
That Ashley tilted me so hard because like there were two
tanks in front of me and she was like walk in front of me
and I was like are you you can't be serious you actually
can't be fucking serious like oh I will go street fighter on
you I will go street fighter toxic on you.
What?
Three, two, one, two, one, one, one, one, one, one, one,
one.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
Oh my, that actually tilted me so I've never been so fucking
tilted.
I'm healing you.
My Invis is just like- What do you mean?
Holy shit, you can't say- Everyone look at him.
My Invis wasn't healing you.
Oh my god, if you're a streamer, if you're a streamer, I
hope you never have a career.
I hope you're always, this is all you have.
you have i hope i hope you're never make it anywhere in life
i actually my invis didn't heal you oh my god i'm muting
here i'm actually muting here this person i hope you never
have a career in anywhere in your life like
uh do you play a tank because i can play dd here uh if you
can play like a tank like
no it's because i i hate these types of players i really
fucking hate these types of players but like we just my
ambition just doesn't walk forward there's no way there's no
way
there is no way yeah i mean it should be easter on attack
here like there is no way there is actually no fucking way
she's like walk forward i see two tanks in front of you want
me to walk into those two tanks like yeah oh my infus wasn't
healing i was shooting at him and i see my heels hitting him
i hope you stay at two of you forever i legitimately you do
not you do not you'll never make it with that type of
attitude especially in rank that actually made me so mad
like i was just like yeah yeah it's fine if you're like you
know joking around off train but if you're like like that
type of toxic and passive aggressive like like there's no
way i'm gonna get set up for a bad here i'm gonna wait till
venom backs up then we'll go on give them okay nice i'm
gonna go back my hands there's no way oh yeah you need help
yeah like holy shit i i hate these types of players so much
i bought the sports looking at each other they'll just kill
yeah deal with them we're fine just deal with them oh my uh
we have another show you
guys fastball and i can dive off the fastball Can we
fastball?
Come on, come on, home!
Come on, hold!
Alright.
The guy is so low.
By the eye.
All right.
Luna's isolated, left side.
Luna is isolated.
Look at Luna.
Look at that.
Oh my, uh.
Luna, they use Star Wars, they use Venom.
Holy shit.
Luna's isolated.
That actually Tilt pissed me Not tilted It just pissed me
off
That actually Like Shit like You can't be constructive But
that was not constructive At all Alright I'm gonna wait
Silver Walk A little more Then I'm gonna go back And then
playing The blame game too When I was clearly healing Okay
Okay Like, playing the blame game, be like, she didn't heal.
I was like, do you know I didn't heal?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Was, like, did you see my POV?
that one hurts.
I'm going to run set up.
Let me go.
Three, two, one.
I'm still contesting this, of course.
I'm contesting.
Oh, my God.
I don't even know what I'm looking at right now.
Okay, okay.
That's much better.
Sorry, I never, like, get that toxic, but like that actually
tilted i've like already had like so much passive
aggressiveness um from people and i was like i'm i do not
care anymore i was like i've already had so many people
being yeah sorry i'm never this toxic before but i was but
like that was just too much That was literally just that was
literally like my my breaking point
Maybe I should you're right I should not have oh my I should
not have said also do not do not go over hate raider stream
guys It is like we're better than that
We're better than that you know Like
I could dive again like five seconds.
That's good grab.
I'm on support.
I'm ready to put on a show.
Keep going.
I'm knocking.
I'm back.
Shoot it.
How about a hole?
I don't think we could shoot it.
Not gonna let it move.
Up our hole.
Man, I wish I was more front line.
all right here we go it's fine i'm okay now i've reset
myself
also i know i've said some really up but that actually like
pissed me out because i hate people who are who are like
that like i that passive aggressively just pisses me up
Yeah, you're alive.
Oh,
I couldn't get inside in time.
Like, yeah, I fucked up some way, but it's like...
But like making shit up too is what pisses me off.
And I vented off my off game because I don't want to fucking
ruin vibes with my teammates.
You know?
I am ready to put on a show.
Alright.
I've been busy, I've been busy, I've been busy.
Oh.
Trying to keep him up.
I don't want to use my ult.
Alright, that's fine.
That's a huge...
Oh.
Oh my god, we got point.
It's fine.
Oh!
Yeah.
I won't disappear so easily.
Holy shit.
I'm so reset now.
I'm reset now.
I'm just focusing on game.
We're down in sync.
We're down in DPS.
Alright.
I'm a full focus here.
I need to reset myself.
Wait.
Oh my god.
I was trying to find her.
I didn't know where she was.
Oh my god, everybody's so low.
Oh, that was...
I'm not gonna live this.
I knew I wasn't gonna live that.
Holy shit, that actually...
Oh my god, I need to fucking reset that.
Oh my god.
Why did she walk forward?
oh okay i'm fully i i need a chill i need a chill like it's
fine when you're like oh it miss you're doing track but then
like she did the blame like the fact that like she said
things i did that i didn't do you know that's and the
passive aggressiveness of it fucking pissed me off yeah and
it like I just hate that so much and she told me to walk in
front of her when our tanks were dead
yeah oh my god yeah and I literally was like I was looking
at Emma in the face of course I was gonna back off you know
i was like that's an emma in front of me and that was what
broke the straw like that was what broke my back i was just
like wow fucking wow this is also i don't play in this elon
anymore these players make me so mad in general they
actually they make me so mad like because they it's the the
like the the types of players around that helo oh your
celestial okay
our invas is not healing like what the fuck do you mean we
both have more healing than the enemy supports like why
would you put the blame game you don't you don't even have a
final hit Oh my god.
She's a heal bot.
You don't even have a final hit on Luna.
When she's the strongest DPS support.
Holy shit.
You want to know what?
Do you know what?
This is what Luna should be playing like.
This is how a Luna should be playing like.
having final hits.
You should be doing final hits.
This is how Luna should be playing, like.
Like, holy shit.
The fact that you were blaming me for not healing when you
were just heal botting.
You were...
That's fucking insane.
And this was...
This is when I was your rank.
This is when I was in your rank.
Doing that.
like oh my god
if you're gonna play the blame game where the fuck is your
final hit
holy shit oh my god i'm sorry i'm sorry that's this i'm this
is the old dokey i'm sorry that was the old dokey i'm
reformed now This is what I was like before.
This is what I was like before.
I'm trying to be the...
Oh my god.
It's...
God.
I hate Pikminis so much.
I...
Oh my god.
I never knew the side of Doki.
It was literally the...
I had a rough day and this was what broke my back.
I usually we could laugh it off.
But like, that was the last straw.
Oh my god.
Like, I was like, I was so I was really fucking toxic back
then.
And obviously I got better.
hiding my talk because I don't care.
I don't fucking care about Elo.
Like, I don't care that I lost what I care about.
Like, like, I don't care because I've already hit top 500 in
every game I like to play.
Like, I've hit top 500 in all the games that I enjoy and I
don't care about Elo.
I don't care anymore.
I'm just playing to play because I enjoy playing competitive
and it's just like no I was gonna I was gonna say some
really mean things and I stopped myself because I'm like I
had to stop myself because I know she's gonna look back this
VOD because she's gonna be like who the fuck is Doki Bird
and I'm gonna say fuck you like change your attitude please
like no one would want to play with you if you act like that
at all like no one would want to play with you if you act
like that like Like, you might flame the wrong person, by
the way.
You're gonna flame the wrong fucking person if you act like
that in game.
And I hope you learn and grow better as a fucking person,
and then maybe you'll have a, maybe, maybe people will watch
your stream.
Because right now, acting like this and and like being that
passive aggressive does not help you as a person people
watch stream streams to like be happy you don't want to
watch streams to be mad and angry that's why people liked
watching my rival streams at first because i was one of few
people that was happy when i play rivals because i
definitely because i genuinely enjoy this game and i make
and i like don't care when people play because i just be
like that's funny but that shit like this is like That's
just, I don't know.
Like, you're not helping yourself.
Do you like to be mad, though?
That's the thing.
But, like, you can be, like, a rage.
You know, there are streamers that make, like, do, like,
engagement baiting.
But it's funny engagement baiting, you know?
It's funny.
Like, I can say Lucky Zeal.
He's, like, one of the engagement baiters in Rival, like, in
the Rival streaming community.
Like, yeah.
he's he's literally he's just engagement baiting he knows
what he's saying it's just like rage bait people like tyler
one is that's not that tyler one is pretty funny too like
yeah
i wonder if you're with shy parachutes but you don't have to
fucking let it out on people in the game like i had a bad
day and i'm making fun of myself like i'm just fucking
around like i had a bad day but that's just that it doesn't
matter that's just like is just it's just dumb like yeah and
he's playing a persona he's playing a fucking persona that
girl legitimately wanted me to die if i i feel like if like
because i was ruining her elo and i was like bro this is
this is imaginary numbers bro like this is make believe
numbers that don't really matter in the
Yeah, Nixie, they give a super chat, thank you, thank you.
Where you did rage bait, it was mostly unintentional.
Holy shit, I can't...
Oh my god, that March game when he, I don't know, when he
was just fucking around should have been the sign, I should
have stopped.
I was just like, just one more game.
Like, yeah, I'll just do one more.
Oh, yeah, yelling at teammates never helped.
Like, do you think I would play better if you're being,
like, a passive, passive, aggressive piece of shit?
You think I would play better if I was being if you were
going to be passive aggressive to me It's why how I like I
Like when that rat like you know when they randomly snapped
at me Even though I felt like there could you could have
communicated that I literally play really badly because I
like and like I had no time to reset myself too Like I I
like knew that like you know where we're I tried my best I
still try to do my best in this situation that we were in.
And like, I still tried to like, you know, maybe not do as
much vibes as like my other teammates, but I didn't like let
it out on anyone, you know?
At best, I was just like, maybe we should swap Squirrel
Girl.
I think we should swap it.
And I told my reasoning why being like, I can't fight the
flankers.
We don't have a hit skat.
I still didn't try to take my anger out on my own teammates.
I just maybe I vented a bit like to you guys but that's
different that's different I know venting to my like I know
being like aggressive to my teammates isn't gonna help
anyone so I just vented to you guys about like oh man blah
blah but like I still tried my best in the situation we were
in yeah
and it's fine like oh oh my god i had that that that was so
explosive from me i've never been that mad before but like i
just hate because it just reminded me of like of like
earlier today and that like pissed that actually was just
like i hate it when people when people are like that yeah
hopefully this watch survives what if i just don't i'm just
not gonna censor and see what happens like because it's like
it's not me like it was just some unfortunate instance that
happened like
it was just dude i at best it's just it the monetization is
off because like i i don't think i can i play too long i
fucked up i streamed too long so so i can't edit it anymore
there's a bond limit for how long you need a stream for it
yeah even
more mad than splatoon days think of super chat like thank
you thank you no this is like how toxic i was during like
early overwatch i was so toxic i remembered like i like this
how bad it was back when like um i never vent i never said
this to aspen but like i got really mad at aspen when we
were both in overwatch back in the long days when she was
first starting out and she was like a full mercy one trick
at that time like this was like early seasons like maybe
season five and six and i like i was so mad because like
mercy wasn't meta back then and she was a mercy one trick
back then and like i i got like i never vented at her though
i never said it at her i just told one of my friends and i
was like i hate getting her on my team oh my god because
back then she was only a mercy player back then obviously
now she's a really great talented player but like back then
i was so mad because i was just like it was it like it
wasn't uh it wasn't mercy meta so people were for like i
just hated people forcing mercy now and then so um and i was
just like i hate getting her on my team and then like that
was how toxic i was i was so toxic but it's like not her
fault it wasn't her fault i just was just like and my friend
would be like yeah but she's a good player and i was like i
just don't like playing with mercy like i don't care if
she's a good player like back in the day now obviously like
i'm reformed but back in the like early season like season
six basically season six or five whenever she first start
like appeared in high elo i was just like i fucking hated
getting her on my team and we didn't have a voice slots back
then but like i was so toxic about it and i was just like
i'm i'm like but now i just like i don't care anymore i just
like if you're one trick i just avoid you well just move on
like
yeah like i was such a i was so fucking toxic like you can
tell i was like ready to rip it
i was i was fucking ready to say something
yeah i held it back i like held it back that was like the
closest i've ever got to like being full blown like toxic
there oh my gosh i'm feeling a lot better now i think it's
also i'm just like a little frustrated um because um
everyone i used to play with don't play the game anymore and
i just want i wish i had more duo partners instead of solo
cute because it's you It's cool that I can solo to high to
like not high elo eternity, you know, high elo, but you
know, it's a cool accomplishment, but I don't care about
that.
I like dueling with people.
I just like more relaxing more, you know?
I don't like I don't want to like I don't want to like solo
all the time, but it's like no one I use like everyone I
used to play with don't play the game anymore or they just
are like I can only play like two to three games.
um and it's like it gets frustrating a bit because you know
i've been yeah like soloing is very boring it gets very
boring and also like the cues are so fucking long the cues
are too long in this elo i forgot how fucking long it is
because in the past we just be like we'll get in and then
like to like you know in 10 to 15 seconds we get a game
yeah and then and so i forgot this is why i also stopped
playing high elo because it was just miserable doing it on
stream and in a way where like i just didn't have fun
waiting
like i didn't i just didn't have fun waiting like two to
five like you know two to five minutes for a fucking game
yeah Uh cat cat is thinking super chat think you think you
get yourself a treat man you deserve it.
I just need it That's why I play off stream a lot because
like when I'm solo queuing off stream and the queues times
get too long I just alt tab and like do something else.
That's basically it I just tab out and do something else
until my game pops up, but when I'm streaming I can't really
do that at best.
I can disassociate but I'm always having to be like like at
that point Um, and, but, like, usually I will try to, like,
you know, try to be active.
Yeah, so it was just like, oh my god.
This is why I stopped really playing High Elo 2 and just
play it off stream if I do get there.
Um, and, like, it's just, oh my gosh.
I just wish more people I know play this game.
Like, more people play in the round my rank.
game or like i uh i like yeah i have all these people but
they're all too high elo they're either all too high elo or
i'm or or like uh they're they're too high elo or i'm i'm i
uh or my other friends are too low elo yeah i'm stuck in
between okay i'm like so calm now guys i let it all out
and be fucking embarrassed at herself.
All right.
I hope.
Let us see what's at the student line.
Get some good rest later.
Thank you.
The super chat, Rice.
The demon.
The demon in me.
Oh my god.
The demon in me is purged.
It's...
I don't like getting angry.
I don't I can get very angry.
I
can get really really angry and I was all I almost wanted to
I was almost there
And it's the thing it was super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you time for one more.
I can't I can't do that.
I can't do that, bro I can't.
Yeah, I got pushed near my limit there.
I do want to say, I do want to say I appreciate that my
arrivals did invite me to participate.
I don't know if I'll get another chance again to participate
in the World Cup like this.
This was my first time.
But if I do have another chance, I hope I can redeem myself
for next year's World Cup, if they host it again.
and you know we were just we just didn't have i feel like
our synergy as a team like everyone's a good player
individually it's just synergy as a team just wasn't it and
that's like not on us individually it's just sometimes that
happens and i don't want to like i don't want to blame
anyone i think we all made mistakes during like i made
mistakes everyone made mistakes during that game and we had
to have last minute dropouts and stuff too so um so it's
like you know it's not really anyone's full fault it's like
everyone's individual everyone together as a team we like
you know we lost as a team we are and in the end and uh and
we all we you know we all tried to our best ability i will
say like i did throw one of the games actually because i i
was just not it was everything was just throwing me off in
general so i did throw during one of those because I just
wasn't in the right mindset to play.
Yeah.
I do think, like,
I think it got better during the last map when we all just,
like, fucked around and actually try to have fun.
And just, yeah.
And just, like, you know, just messed around.
Like, that, you know, that helped a lot.
But I think, like, you know, we all, tried our best and like
tried our best in a way like what we have with what we got
yeah thousand you for the five gift of ships thank you thank
you we all tried our best with what we got yeah
yeah and don't send hate to any of my teammates i should
have said that in the earlier like it is what it is i know
like i know like i know i said some stuff with armory
because i you know just caught me off guard but she was also
like really frustrated and angry like like i don't know if
you guys know this but um she wanted to she hasn't been
doing haven't hasn't been like having good luck with created
tournaments and uh and this was like her one time like where
she could potentially break her streak so um so that's
understandable that she got really frustrated but yeah it
just you know she hit she shot everyone not just me yeah I
mean I've lost some I've won some I've just learned to roll
with the punches because I in the beginning I always I'm
always getting like super depressed about it but like I've
learned but I've won tournaments you know I've won
tournaments I haven't lost every tournament I've done um but
I've like so I've learned to like you know you would
eventually win you would eventually not be like last place
and like i'm had those moments i could they give the 10
gifted ships thank you thank you so like you know she shot
everyone not just me like she fucking shot at sure for and
he was just like why you shoot me for even sure usually sure
for it would wouldn't say anything but even he was like what
the fuck like the verb thank you the five gifted ships they
could thank you i was like yeah i was just like i was like
why did she shoot sure for bro he's getting all the kills
like he's just like i don't think it was guys i just got
nine final hits guys
yeah it was just like so random yeah why you say fuck me for
i think she was just really frustrated with everything which
you know makes sense with it yeah everyone yeah we just all
got hit with the blast range too
yeah so like you know it does it happens it happens it comes
and goes like I she'll get a win eventually you can't lose
every tournament like like that was me at one point when I
first started doing tournaments I was I never was like at
the top for Like, I've always, like, like, at the bottom or
middle, I was never, like, you know, top five or something.
And then eventually, I started winning.
I started, I've hit a stride of wins.
And it just takes, you just get there.
And I got used to it.
Like, losses don't fucking matter to me anymore.
Yeah.
Zekka, thank you, the 10.
Get the ships.
Thank you.
Yeah, you gain experience.
And eventually, it happens.
Yeah.
But, yeah.
Thank you guys for watching.
all the support i hope maybe maybe we'll get another
opportunity i hope we get another opportunity in the future
uh stuff sharky the you five give the ships they can thank
you um oh we get another opportunity in the future i love
doing these tournaments even like you know you win some you
lose some it's free money it's it's it's it's like not too
mad it's literally free money i stream free money i also get
prize money free money like what's there to be mad about I
could have got more free money but like that's fine like
this paid off my world cup ticket like my soccer world cup
ticket for Switzerland versus Canada
yeah and like you know I felt like you know I had three days
to remember how to play Marvel rivals like oh i could have
my lobster more buttery and steak more juicy yum yum yes it
was just a little guy i love playing with sure for it like
he's just i i think these must be like i should stop joining
these more of the story free of money mike thank you for the
super chat thank you i won't be surprised troopers like
maybe i should stop I love playing with that guy.
He's so fucking funny.
I think we have really good chemistry together, too.
Or maybe I just love rage baiting him.
But anyway, guys, I'm going to head off now.
It was nice just, like, chilling, vibing with you guys.
As always, I mean, he likes free money, too.
To be fair, to be fair, he also likes free money.
So, so, like, he's joining this fort also for the free
money.
But anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated,
posture check, get up and move around and get that blood
flowing.
And if you, stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.